Ich weiß nicht, seit wann gibt es irgendwie nichts Neues?
Peek-Apple.
Das ist seit Jahren im erweiterten Zombie-Modus. Also das ist so...
So I am really pleased to give you, our closest friends, the first glimpse of the next generation of Mac Pro.
Und alles so yeah, genau so richtig so geil, endlich wieder, wie wir uns das immer gedacht haben.
So, ist jetzt alles gut. A new generation Intel Xeon chip. This is double the CPU performance of the previous generation. ECC memory, that's double the performance. It's ten times faster than any hard drive for the Mac Pro before.
Edge-Router Lite.
Edge-Router Lite, 75 Euro, einen VK. Also jetzt nicht mal irgendwo schummelt oder von irgendwelchen Lastern gefallen, sondern einfach so. Hat keinen Lüfter drin, ist also auch sehr hohen Kompatibilitätsfaktor in Haushalten, wo man nicht alleine ist. Oder in Studios zum Beispiel.
Die WWDC-Sondersendung machen wir dann nächste Woche. Wenn wir richtig durchblicken, weil es ja so viele sind, wir müssen auch mal abbeißen.
Das wäre schon sehr unübersichtlich gewesen alles.
Jetzt noch ein Bierchen, oder?
Also, wir haben noch keinen Plan gefasst, wie wir jetzt erstmal Bierchen holen, aber ich würde gerne... Was wollen wir zuerst machen? Wollen wir uns an dieser Keynote entlang hangeln? Oder wollen wir uns zu den Themen so greifen, wie wir sie geil finden?
Also ich finde den Vorschlag nicht schlecht, erst Hardware zu machen.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass mit der Software das franzt aus.
Genau.
Ja, Hardware Kapitelmarke hier. Das erste, was sie angekündigt haben, war MacBook Air, das hat sich ja auch abgezeichnet. Und mit dem MacBook Air Update zusammen gab es auch ein Airport-Update.
Ja, den eigentlichen Tower, der rauskam.
Genau. Also die Time-Capsule und Airport-Extreme, das heißt auch in diesem Line-Up haben sie relativ wenig verändert.
Ich dachte, wenn es echt, als du das hingemalt hast auf dieser, auf dieser Linksart, die haben ja irgendwie einen Grafikfehler oder so was, das ist irgendwie, das kann ja nicht sein.
Das ist merkwürdig, wie so ein Toastbrot, so ein senkrecht hingestelltes Teil.
Ja, das kann nun gar nicht sein, aber sie meinen das ernst.
Ja, und das Argument war ja, dass sie dann mit dieser Bauform...
Das ist Beamforming, dass sie halt mehrere Antennen haben, wo sie halt die einschalten, die am besten irgendwie auf den Device zielt. Und deswegen brauchten sie halt ein bisschen Volumen im Gehäuse.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist anders. Die Forming geht noch anders. Die Antenne wird nicht nur selektiert, sondern die feuern alle zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten. Das funktioniert so, dass wenn du das Ding anfungst mit deinem Gerät, dann, und da sind jetzt noch mal so sechs Antennen drin an so einem Ding, oder sagen wir mal nur drei, dann kommt das Signal, was du an die Kiste schickst, zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten an, bei diesen drei Antennen. Weil die Laufzeiten sind ja unterschiedlich lang, je nachdem, wie die Geometrische stehen. Genau. Das merken die sich in der Hardware, das heißt, die schieben deine Signale wieder auseinander, merken sich diese Laufzeit-Differenzen und senden selber mit derselben Verzögerung, also mit demselben Timing wieder zurück.
Über alle Antennen, aber?
Über alle Antennen. Das heißt, du liegst dann sozusagen in einem Kreis, in einem virtuellen Kreis, du liegst genau auf der Kante eines Kreises, wo sich sozusagen die Wellen, wenn sie dann bei dir ankommen, maximal verstärken.
Aber alle Antennen sozusagen für diesen Ort, da interferieren die nicht, sondern addieren sich sozusagen zusammen, während sich bei den anderen eher auslöschen.
Das merken sich für jeden Kleinen und Einsen bzw. die Hardwaremacht. Also sie merken das, wie gesagt, aus deinem Empfangssignal, daher wissen sie, wo du steckst und machen Senden mit demselben Timing, bloß rückwärts wieder zu dir hin. Damit formen sie sozusagen ihren Strahl oder sorgen dafür, dass das Energie-Maximum, nämlich da, wo sich alle Wellen aufeinander addieren, genau dort ist, wo du auch bist.
Aber drei Antennen hatten sie in dem Excel?
Ja, das kannst du mit N-Antennen bauen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viel sie da drin haben.
Aber drei hatten sie vorher schon irgendwie.
Vier oder sechs kann man machen.
Gibt es ja Hersteller, die haben 48 oder so. Antennen?
In einem Access-Point?
Vor einem Jahr oder so. War wahrscheinlich nur so eine Studio oder so.
Ja, es gibt ja immer Leute, die versuchen, einen Schritt weiter zu sein. Also dieses 802.3 AC, was sich hier etabliert, dieses Gigabit LAN.
Was aber noch nicht abgeschlossen ist.
Aber du kannst es jetzt einfach mal kaufen. Immerhin ist es jetzt schon da. Das heißt, die Leute arbeiten jetzt natürlich wieder in Next Generation. Und dort kann durchaus sein, dass die damit ein paar Antennen mehr basteln.
Wikipedia behauptet, dass man damit 6900 Megabit hinbekommen könnte, also 6,9 Gigabit theoretisch. Das funktioniert auch nur noch auf 5 Gigahertz.
Ja, sowieso. Zwei, vier kannst du komplett vergessen. Ist durch, weil so viele Legacy-Devices da sind. Gerade hier in Prenzlberg, hier gibt es ja mehr Babyphones als iPhones. Und dann würde sich die Videoerwachung von dem Laden nebenan ganz vergessen. Dann noch eine Mikrowelle dazu und schon eine Schicht im Schacht im 2,4 Gigahertz-Band.
Ja, das nächste heißt dann AD. Das, was aus dem nächsten Jahr kommt.
WLAN-AD, dann kommt wieder das Kabel.
Na ja, gut, müssen wir sehen. Also auf jeden Fall das Air, das Air hat es. Und diese Airpods Stations haben es.
Die nächsten Pros werden es auch haben.
Und das iPhone 5S hat es auch. Alle haben es demnächst dann. Aber aktuell erst mal die MacBook Airs, die es ja auch schon gibt. Man kann schon klicken. Bei MacFixit schon auseinander genommen. iFixit.
Bevor die Leute hier anfangen, irgendwie feuchte Hosen zu kriegen, man muss natürlich auch ein Internet dahinter haben, was das auch mitmacht. Oder halt wenigstens ein Fileserver. Jetzt vergessen die Leute immer wieder.
Ja, es kurbelt die Wirtschaft an. Ich find's gut.
Na gut, aber so von DSL Modems und so weiter ist natürlich nach wie vor nichts zu sehen in diesen Airports. Das ist halt irgendwie der gleiche Shit. Und es gibt auch glaube ich keine neuen Ports in dem Sinne.
Von DSL? Wie meinst du das ist nichts zu sehen?
Nein, du hast halt keine VDSL Modems oder sowas drin, wie bei so einer Fritzbox. Ich meine, du kannst da so eine Scheiße...
Achso, die können nur normales DSL. Also die können PP, OE, aber sie können halt jetzt...
Die haben kein Modem drin.
Und du kriegst keine Modems einzeln mehr, ne?
Ah, DSL Modems gibt's wie Sand am Meer.
Ja, aber wenn ihr jetzt VDSL hier haben willst, dann gibt's...
Es gab nie vernünftige Modems. Es gibt dieses eine, das über Ding, was die Telekom verteilt, was so unglaublich grottenschlecht ist, diese HS300 oder sonst irgendwas.
Aber haben die nicht noch so einen künstlichen PPoE-Ausgang, dass man weiter seinen Shit irgendwie am Start haben kann?
Ja, aber diese Dinger sind Morgs. Du kannst eine Fritzbox mit einem Trick dazu bringen, dass sie dir hinten PPoE wieder rausrückt. Das ist noch ein VDSL-Modem, ist aber unsäglich teuer.
Der Trick ist, es genauso zu konfigurieren.
Das kannst du nicht. Du kannst eine 7390, eine VDSL-Fritzbox, kannst du normalerweise. Da gibt's keinen GUI-Haken mehr für. Hab ich mich schon öfter beschwert.
Bei den Älteren gab's das noch.
Ja, gibt's schon lange nicht mehr. Hab ich mich gerade neugierig beschwert. Dann haben sie mir gesagt, naja, hier ist der Trick-Hackset-Konfig-Fall von Hand um. Dann geht das wieder. Aber wenn da mal noch jemand kommt oder wenn da mal ein Zuhörer noch mal einen Tipp hat für ein freilaufendes VDSL-Modem, nicht mit Routertriller drin, sondern wirklich, wo hinten nacktes PPP-Ö rauskommt, wäre ich sehr dankbar. Kann ich auch gut gebrauchen.
Mich wundert das so ein bisschen, dass Apple da doch ein wenig am Markt vorbei produziert. Weil man kann das ja keinem empfehlen. Normalerweise hat man ja nur dieses eine Gerät, was dann WLAN und eben die Internetverbindung macht.
Was machen die ganzen Kabelmodem-Leute? In den USA sieht die Infrastruktur anders aus.
Ich bin aber jetzt explizit von deutschem Markt.
Da interessiert die Amis nicht. Ist dir jemand schon mal aufgefallen, dass sich Apple dafür interessiert hat, was der europäische oder deutsche Markt macht oder tut?
Selbstverständlich nicht. Aber das heißt ja auch nicht unbedingt, dass jetzt immer jede Entscheidung, die für USA passt, auch in Deutschland komplett an der Spur vorbeigeht. In diesem Fall ist es aber leider so. Ich wollte es nur nochmal betonen. Kann man auf jeden Fall nicht empfehlen. Was man vielleicht empfehlen kann, sind die neuen Airs. Was sie nicht haben, ist Retina. Was sie haben, ist angeblich längere Laufzeit.
Na, ich glaube nicht, dass es noch angeblich ist. Angeblich ist vielleicht die Menge, die die gesagt haben, von neun und zwölf Stunden.
Hast du schon mal einen Computer von Apple, einen tragbaren Computer gekauft, der diese angegebene Laufzeit auch erfüllt?
Ja, der da.
Sieben Stunden.
Ich bin auch zufrieden mit meinem.
Sieben Stunden? Sieben Stunden was?
Sieben Stunden...
Draufgucken auf ein Log-Screen.
Nee, sag mal, du surfst und liest hauptsächlich und kriegst nicht die ganze Zeit und hast Flash am Laufen, sondern so ein normales... Sag mal, du bist auf Spiegel, das wäre so ein Ding. Mit Flash ist alles aus und deine Ads blinken nicht, sondern du liest die Artikel so in Ruhe, das würde der sieben Stunden durchhalten.
Ich mach auch so Terminals...
Und zwar natürlich nicht bei voller Helligkeit, ist ja klar. Also ich meine, dass die da schon auch mit so einem moderaten Setting arbeiten, ist schon logisch.
Mir ist das unbekannt. Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass meine Rechner in meinen von mir gefahrenen Konfigurationen jemals auch nur ansatzweise die Nen-Überlebenszeit durchgehalten hätten. Also dieses R, wenn ich das aufklappe, frisch geladen, dann ist es einfach, nach zwei Stunden ist es einfach mal durch, wenn es überhaupt so lange hält.
Ja, dann sind halt die erst bei dir nach vier Stunden jetzt durch das neue Ding.
Ja, okay, ja, aber das ist für mich noch nicht der Durchbruch. Also mit All Day, wie haben sie es genannt?
Ja, aber die werden jetzt nicht für dich Power-User irgendwie da so eine dreifach große Batterie einbauen.
Da kommen wir gleich noch zu.
It won't call it a day until you do. So sagen sie.
Weil es es immer noch nicht hat, die Schweine backen. Und das finde ich viel eher krass. Es hat immer noch keinen SIM-Karten-Slot.
Hast du nicht gerade erzählt, seit wann interessieren sich die bei Apple?
Nein, das haben die Amis auch.
SIM-Karten?
Ja, sie wissen das bloß nicht. Also sie verkaufen es ihren Kunden nie so. SIM-Karten kennen die dort nur aus dem Krimi, wenn nämlich der von der Polizei verfolgte das aus dem Taxi wirft.
Na komm, steckt in jedem AT&T iPhone drin.
Ja, aber das wissen die Leute nicht, weil das immer nur mit dem Telefon zusammenverkauft wird.
Du kriegst doch immer den SIM-Kart- Removal-Tool dazu.
Wie dem auch sei. Also das wissen die Amis jedenfalls auch, was eine SIM-Karte ist inzwischen. Und das funktioniert da auch. Es gibt da auch Operator, die sowas anbieten. Zumindest in den Städten, da wo die ganzen Apple-Jünger rumhüpfen. Gerade auch in Kalifornien. Warum haben die das immer noch nicht drin? Ich find's vor allen Dingen immer peinlich. Weil ich versuche so ein bisschen die Apple-Fahne gelegentlich mal hochzuhalten. Dann kommen die Leute mit ihren stinkigen Thinkpads von 2004, drehen den um, ziehen die Batterie ab und zeigen mir den SIM-Karten-Slot und lachen mir frech ins Gesicht. Und das find ich halt einfach immer so, ja, was soll ich da zu sagen? Und diese USB-Dongel draußen dranstecken, nur mal geht mal gar nicht.
Nee, das geht überhaupt nicht.
Und diese Gedongel ans iPhone dran geht auch nicht, weil ich mit meinem Telefon auch noch telefonieren muss. Deswegen ist mir auch die Batterie in meinem iPhone heilig. Ja, das ist auch so unzuverlässig. Ja, wenn ich das zum Dongeln benutze, dann ist das Radfahrt leer. Das ist echt für den Fuß.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Ich muss wahrscheinlich sowieso demnächst mal wieder komplett neu installieren, wahrscheinlich schon wieder alles im Arsch. Aber ich habe einfach viele Probleme damit. Und ich finde einfach, der Rechner muss selber Herr seiner Netzwerk-Interfaces sein und alle nur erdenkbaren Optimierungen da ausfinden können. Und ich verstehe das auch nicht. Gut, ne, selbst so trotzdem, die Geräte nach wie vor attraktiv. Und durch die angeblich längere Laufzeit sind sie sicherlich nochmal attraktiver geworden. Sind sie eigentlich auch billiger geworden?
Ja, 100 Dollar wohl.
Wir starten doch bei 999, das war doch bisher auch so.
Irgendwo stand, dass sie durch die Bank durch 100 Dollar billiger wurden, mir war so. Kann mich aber jetzt täuschen. Aber egal, der billigste ist auf jeden Fall 999 Dollar, ein Euro, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du einfach mehr Zeugs fürs Geld. Also du hast irgendwie verdoppelten Flash oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, du kannst doch zumindest jetzt nochmal etwas amtlichere Konfigurationen zusammenklicken. Also du kannst zum Beispiel einen 11 Zoll R mit 512 Gigabyte Flash klicken. Das kommt bis vor kurzem nicht. Und ich finde ja, dass 13 Zoll nach wie vor eigentlich am interessantesten ist. Was ich eher eine Enttäuschung finde, ist, dass sie nach wie vor nur 8 Gigabyte RAM bieten. Wobei, da verweisen wir dann gleich nochmal auf die OSX-Diskussion. Vielleicht entschärft sich das durch neue Software. Das kann gut sein. Ja.
Sonst ist da nicht viel zu sagen.
MacBook Pro gab es gar nichts Neues. Ups. Und dann haben sie halt den Can't Innovate My Ass ausgepackt. Jetzt die Kapitelmarke bitte. Bevor jetzt einfach die Töne zu machen.
Den Mülleimer.
Den Mülleimer? Den Dalek. Mit dem Dalek fand ich auch sehr schön. Irgendwie verschiedene Leute schlugen schon vor, man könnte das Teil ja super auf einen Roomba installieren.
Wie ist der Fail von vor 10, 12 Jahren, wo du so abgelästert hast?
Oh, der Cube. Ja, jetzt kann man wieder oben reingreifen und was anfassen. Es ist so...
Was, jetzt mit einem Lüfter greifen?
Also, in gewisser Hinsicht ist dieser Mac Pro so meine erste erfüllte Befürchtung von Zwei, die eingetreten ist, dass sie halt jetzt dem Karten, der Erweiterung durch Karten quasi...
Den gar ausmachen.
Nö, er hat doch mal gesagt, gib dir ein Kästchen, wo du reinstecken kannst, extern.
Ja, aber bestimmt nicht von Apple.
Vielleicht auch von Apple, aber es ist egal, es ist trotzdem ein externes Kästchen per Kabel, die man auch noch nicht mal festschrauben kann.
Ja, Thunderbolt-Kabel, genau. Diese kleinen flaky Stecker, die erstmal 5 cm in die Waagerechte rausschießen, bevor du irgendeine andere Richtung einschlagen kannst. Ist ja toll, dass ich oben in diesem Mac Pro da oben reindrehen kann und so weiter. Bloß wenn da hinten so ein Gewürr an Kabeln ist und vor allem diese flaky Thunderbolt-Kabel und da drehst du da oben einmal rum, dann sind deine Platten und deine Grafikkarten und deine ganzen anderen Video-Import-Devices und HDMI-Adapter und so weiter sind einfach mal gone. Also das ist einfach mal kein... Das ist nicht pro.
Nicht.
Nix ist da pro.
Das ist übrigens Thunderbolt 2 oder plus. Oder wie haben sie das genannt?
Ja, Thunderbolt 2. Ich wäre ja mal froh, wenn sie mal eins mal hier wirklich an den Markt kriegen würden, dann wäre ja schon mal was geleistet.
Vielleicht haben sie die Stecker auch verbessert. So ein bisschen, weißt du, wie bei diesem Lightning-Anschluss, so ein bisschen rasten oder so.
Was wollen sie da jetzt noch groß machen?
Kannst du noch machen, kannst du oben den Däler rein drücken, dass das einrastet.
Ja, mal so Locking-Stecker, das wär ja mal was. Ich meine, was erwarten sie, wenn ich so eine Box anstecke mit Festplatten, Rät und mit Karten, also mit PCI-Equipment? Was denken sie, wie oft ich das im Betrieb umstecke? Und anstatt mal so einen Stecker zu machen, so eine Pro-Variante, ich meine, wo ist der Thunderbolt-Pro-Stecker, der wie so ein amtlicher XLR-Stecker da einfach mit Katschak reingeht und dann geht der da auch nicht ab. Und dann kannst du irgendwie diesen Scheiß-Daleck an diesen Kabel durch den Raum schleifen. Und der Betrieb ist nicht gestört. So muss das sein. Aber doch nicht so ein fancy Kack. Da haust du einmal auf den Tisch, stellst einmal kräftig die Bierflasche auf den Tisch und schon fällt dir die ganze Scheiße ab.
Vielleicht bauen sie hinten noch so eine Büroklammer dran, so ein Drahtbügel, den du dann über diese Interface darüber klappen kannst, dass der Stecker nicht rauskommt.
Jeder VGA-Stecker hat da mehr Industrie-Quality.
Wobei das auch mal so ein Gemurks ist, an den ich mich nicht so gerne erinnere. Diese Geschraube immer mit den Fingern da zwischen den anderen Kabel. Aber man konnte fest packen.
Es war einfach dran. Es war irgendwie gut ingeniiert und es gab viele Schraubenteile, die konnte man nicht drehen und so. Und mal hat einer dran gedacht, vielleicht mal so einen Schlitz reinzumachen, dass du da mal zur Not auch einen Schraubenzieher bewegen kannst. Aber das ist alles leistbar.
Mal hast du die Muttern mit aus dem Gehäuse rausgedreht.
Das passt immer eigentlich. Was würde sie daran hindern? Aber da gibt es halt nichts zum Reinschrauben.
Ja, aber man kann jetzt die Ports beleuchten.
Eben.
Ja, dann nicht so lange wieder einzustecken.
Wenn dir die ganze Scheiße rausfällt, kriegst du sie wieder rein.
Wahrscheinlich hat das OS jetzt auch dieses Sea-Lion so ein Feature, dass irgendwie, ups, deine Platte ist rausgerutscht, du hast 30 Sekunden, um eine Stecker wieder reinzuschieben, solange machen wir die on hold. Und da schlägt dann nämlich auch das Power-Saving zu, weil der Rest ist nämlich dann angehalten.
Verstehe. App-Nap ist sozusagen sozusagen da, die Stecker wieder reinzustecken.
OS-Nap.
Nap. Ja. Also dieser Mac Pro, und der kommt dann halt auch erst im Fall, wie sie so schön sagen. Also ich vermute ja, dass dieser ganze...
Fallobst sozusagen.
Das Fallobst kommt im Herbst. Ich vermute ja mal, dass sie mehr oder weniger OSX, also dass die neuen Mac Pros einfach nur unter dem neuen OSX laufen.
Aber so was von.
natürlich das neue iPhone und neue iPad, dann wahrscheinlich auch alles nur mit iOS 7. Steht noch was anderes an zum Update, was sie angekündigt haben? Nee, ne? So. Aber darauf läuft es hinaus. Das heißt, bis September passiert jetzt eigentlich nichts weiterhin. Also es wird dann ein Jahr lang mit der Ausnahme dieser MacBook Air Updates und möglicher weiterer Updates, die wir jetzt noch nicht erblicken können. Aber sie erzählen ja die ganze Zeit Fall, Fall, Fall. Nichts passiert sein. Weil jetzt ist ja eigentlich auch nicht viel passiert. Okay, MacBook Air ist ein bisschen größer, schneller, weiter, hält länger.
MacBook Pros können ja jetzt in den nächsten Wochen irgendwie nachziehen, wieso nicht?
Ja gut, aber auch das wäre jetzt nur so ein Speed-Bump. Ich versuche jetzt nur an diese Diskussion, es passiert nichts, in das Wert ist, zu schließen.
Nichts Neues meinst du an dem Zeug, an dem Hardware?
Aber schauen wir uns doch nochmal den Mac Pro an. Was ist dran am Gerät? Wie finden wir das Teil?
Ja, also es hat überhaupt außer dieses SSD-Modul, also es hat keine SATA-Ports, es hat keine PCI-Ports mehr.
Du kannst da auch gar keine Festplatten mehr reinstecken?
Nee, ist kein Platz dafür da.
Kein Platz und keine SATA-Ports, also du könntest nicht mal schummeln und das irgendwie da ankleben.
Also du hast ja diesen dreieckigen Air-Duct, oder wie auch immer du das nennen willst, diesen Kühlkörper, und dann schrauben sie ja von drei Seiten einmal das Motherboard und die beiden Grafikkarten an, dieses dreieckige Ding ran. Und dann ist der Platz ja auch schon verbraucht.
Naja, wobei das Design ist schon interessant.
Also kannst du halt noch irgendwie vier RAM-Module reintun und der Rest ist über hinten.
Achso, und das ist natürlich jetzt auch nur noch Single CPU. Da sind nicht mehr zwei. Bei der Mac Pro hier.
Haben sie sich dazu geäußert? Ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Nee, aber es ist ja eigentlich ziemlich klar, dass das nur eine CPU ist. Es kommt demnächst, die gibt's ja noch nicht, kommt im September oder so, kommt von Intel die 12-Core-CPU und die kommt halt da rein. Also wenn man sich die große Version ordert. Die gibt's noch nicht jetzt, aber die wird's dann geben. Und ob die gesockelt ist oder nicht, ist mir noch nicht ganz klar, ob man die dann später tauschen könnte. Das ist an den jetzigen Mac Pros ganz cool. Du kannst ja zur Not wirklich in hier K&M, gibt's hier noch keine Ahnung, hier Alternate, wo auch immer, Cyberport, hingehen, kannst dann eine CPU shoppen, kannst sie in der Mac Pro klatschen und kannst sie ein bisschen aufrüsten und so. Bei dem geht das, ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, ob das geht.
Ja, also ich meine, es könnte natürlich, was sie nicht gesagt haben, ist, was das Teil kosten wird. Natürlich nicht. Natürlich nicht. Könnte sein.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, gar nicht mal so viel, weil du musst ja noch 1000 Sachen dazu kaufen, wenn der richtig vernünftig einsetzbar sein soll. Also diese ganzen externen Geschichten. Ich meine, wenn du da nicht mal eine Platte reinkriegst und nix, also da kann ja auch nicht so ein riesen Netzteil drin sein, weil es hat ja gar nichts zu versorgen.
Haben sie gesagt, wie viel SSD sie da...
Na da ist ein so ein Slot-Modul da irgendwie.
Also zumindest sah es so aus, als wäre es ein Slot-Modul, der... Das ist unglaublich schnelles, ja, das haben sie gesagt.
Ich meine, das ist ja nicht verkehrt. Du hast ja deine SSD nicht per SATA angebunden, sondern per PCI-Bus oder wie auch immer. Also ohne Slots, aber direkt auf dem PCI-Bus. Das ist ja schon alles ganz schick. Aber ja, extendable ist da nichts. Also eigentlich musst du da nie wieder ran an der Kiste, wenn du die einfach mal im Vollausbau kaufst.
Aber es ist schon krass, ja. Also dieses Ding hat drei Seiten. Eine Seite ist CPU und die anderen beiden sind GPU. Also diese Maschine ist eigentlich eine einzige...
Kraftnobel. Eine Krafttonne.
Meine gut, vielleicht haben sie da auch einen Punkt. Die Batterie. Genau, das ist eine Batterie. Und das könnte natürlich dann auch dazu führen, dadurch, dass dieser ganze PCI-Karten-Kram ausgelagert ist, dass du eben auch dazu übergehst, häufiger zu aktualisieren. Weil jetzt können sie quasi den Mac Pro jedes Jahr Speedbumpen bis zum Get-Know. Und es handelt sich dabei sozusagen nur so um Herz-Extraktion und der Rest...
Aber hätten sie bei dem alten Mac Pro ja auch machen können, haben sie auch ewig nicht gemacht.
Ja, nur wenn du dann dein Gerät wechselst, dann musst du da wieder deine Karten umstecken und dann hast du wieder einen PCI-Zustift. Dann passen die Platten nicht rein.
Aber die Frage ist, was hast denn du überhaupt für Karten drin? Ich weiß, du hast jetzt noch Audio drin, aber die meisten Leute haben da eine Grafikkarte drin.
Ich hab nicht Audio drin, aber ich will Audio drin haben.
Aber die Apple Leute wollen Displays dran haben. Die steckst du jetzt an einen von diesen sechs Thunderbolt-Dingern und chanest die nochmal hintereinander, wenn du willst, kannst du auch machen. Steckst du schön deine Displays dran und wirst sehen, das wird von Apple auch irgendwann wieder mal das super Hyper Duper Display geben, das 4K-Display oder sonst irgendwas mit Thunderbolt dran.
Das, was man sich reingesteckt hat, ist eh nur das, damit man seinen Rechner so ein bisschen noch am Leben erhalten kann, zum Beispiel USB 3 und irgendwie eine fettere Grafikkarte oder halt noch eine mit SATA 3.
USB 3 haben sie drin von Hause aus, deine Grafik sollst du per Thunderbolt machen, aber wenn Tim jetzt sagt, Audio-Karten... Audio haben jetzt wieder nicht so eine Wahnsinns-Bandbreite, dass du die jetzt nicht wirklich in eine externe Kästchen da mit Thunderbolt dranstecken musst. Da brauchst du auch nicht PCI-Super plus Doppelscharf oder sonst irgendwas, da reicht auch... Isar.
Da kommen schon ganz beträchtliche Bandbreiten zusammen, wenn du dann mit 102...
Die haben noch nicht genau gesagt, was über Thunderbolt 2 jetzt eigentlich rübergehen soll.
20 Gigabit. Das sind dann vier Express-Lanes?
Nee, zwei. Also Thunderbolt normal war eine Express-Lane. Also eine PCI-Lane.
Das reicht doch auch für Audio. Aber für Audio reicht halt alles dicke mal aus.
Also du hast ja in der Präsentation hatten sie ja diesen einen Typen, der irgendwie Videoschnitt gemacht hat und vor drei Displays saß. Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ziemlich genau die Anwendung, die sie damit im Blickfeld haben.
Also wenn du jetzt wirklich drei 4K-Displays anschließen kannst, dann schreit jetzt erstmal keiner nach einer anderen Grafikkarte.
Nee, als die Mac Pros damals rauskamen, hat auch keiner nach einer neueren Grafikkarte geschrien. Aber in zwei, drei Jahren schon.
Na gut, aber wenn sich das Teil dann halt auch schnell aktualisieren lässt, so kaufst du einfach die nächste Generation.
Ziehst du den ganzen Stecker ab und stellst den nächsten in den Mainzer?
Also jetzt immer diese ganze Beißleinheit, alle da drin zu haben mit irgendwelchen Karten und so, das ist schon ein bisschen gemolken.
Hört euch ganz schön nach Stockholm-Syndrom an.
Mein alter Mac Pro sieht geiler aus.
Ich glaube, dass die kleine Tonne wahrscheinlich auch günstiger zu produzieren ist. Und es ist jetzt immer schwer, Apple-Preise vorherzusagen. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er zumindest der untere Ende, das untere Ende, also die billigste Ausbaustufe, möglicherweise dann günstiger ist, als das, was man bisher für ein Mac Pro zahlt.
Auf jeden Fall muss es günstiger sein. Es kann ja auch weniger.
Und der, meine, vergess mal noch eins, der Ding ist sehr viel kleiner, wird wahrscheinlich auch deutlich weniger Strom verbrauchen und angeblich macht er auch deutlich weniger Krach.
Ja, mit einem so großen Lüfter da oben sollte es schon ruhiger sein.
Gestern irgendwo auf unserer Webseite habe ich mal so einen Vergleich gesehen, da haben sie diese Tonne neben einen alten Pro gestellt. Habt ihr dieses Bild auch gesehen?
Das Ding ist nicht so hoch wie der Einschalter vom Mac Pro, meinten sie irgendwie. Aber schon, wenn ich in so einem rauen Betrieb bin, da wäre mir so ein Mac Pro, wo man auch mal gegen treten kann, schon lieber als so eine kleine Tonne.
Dennis, dein Mac Pro steht aus gutem Grund unter dem Tisch. Die Tonne ist so klein und leise, die steht so oben auf dem Tisch, da brauchst du nicht mehr gegen treten. Dann hast du auch diese Kabel-Thema mit, ich reiß mir meine Kabel raus, und dann tippe ich nicht mehr.
Und vorne gibt es die eigentlich gar nicht so in dem Sinn, oder? Man kann die Seite mit den Kabeln zu sich drinnen. Es gibt nur eine Seite, wo was ist, nämlich die mit den Anschlüssen, oder?
Genau. Und er hat ja gesagt, wenn du das Teil drehst, da ist irgendwie ein Motion-Sensor drin, dann geht das Gelichte an.
Ja, aber das ist albern. Ich meine, du hast da hinten dein Stromkabel dran. Und alles, wenn du da drehst, was hilft dir das Drehen, wenn deine ganzen Kabel hinterhergezogen werden?
Wenn das Teil in der Ecke steht und du drehst die Kabel nach hinten, damit sie weg sind. Jetzt willst du ein neues Kabel einstecken, dann drehst du das nach vorne, dass du das Kabel einstecken kannst. Dann drehst du wieder nach hinten.
Dann kannst du deine ganzen Thunderbolt-Kabel raus.
Vielleicht siehst du das mit den Thunderbolt-Kabeln auch ein bisschen zu eng.
Hat der in der Präsentation von Sechsfach Firewire geredet? Hat er sich da verquatscht oder nicht?
Ja, hat er sich verquatscht.
Von Porz ja hat sich nicht viel getan. Ein USB-Port mehr, glaube ich, standardmäßig.
Aber USB 3, bitte schön.
Haben sie was gesagt?
Ja, haben sie gesagt.
Steht auch in den Specks auf der Webseite. Ist USB 3.
Natürlich ist es USB 3. Ich wollte fragen, ob sie gesagt haben, dass da ein Lautsprecher drin ist.
Ich kann in dem Bild eigentlich noch gar nichts erkennen. Was sieht es aus mit Ethernet, Audio und so weiter? Also da oben ist Audio.
Zweimal Internet, zweimal Gigabit Ethernet, wie jetzt auch.
Und auch immer noch Gigabit.
Das ist HDMI, den sehe ich eindeutig.
Kein 10 Gigabit?
Ja, genau. Warum bauen die das, was sie jetzt für tralala und super toll halten und bauen da kein 10G-Interface ein? Okay, das ist jetzt immer ein bisschen oder SSD-Mod.
Mit SSD hast du da drin. SSD kannst du eigentlich Dateien irgendwie mit einem Gigabyte die Sekunde hin- und herschieben und dann geht's nicht, weil du nur Gigabit Ethernet hast und kriegst gerade mal 120 Megabyte die Sekunde drüber.
Da kannst du beide bündeln.
Wow, 240.
Na gut, 10 Gigabits kriegst du schon ein bisschen mehr raus. Also du kriegst es raus.
Dann müssen wir einen Adapter dafür bauen.
Also es ist irgendwie...
Naja, aber der holt sich ja auch Sachen vom Netzwerk, wenn du, also wenn du da hier neues Final Cut Pro mit dem Ding bearbeiten willst, dann willst du ja nicht deine dicken Movies da über diese dünne Leitung schieben. Und auf dein Flash hast du sehr wohl kaum.
Wenn du nur drei Displays anschließt, dann hast du doch noch drei Thunderbolt-Ports frei. Also mit sechs Thunderbolt-Ports bist du eigentlich nicht auch...
Also was jetzt fehlt, ist das Storage-Array, was man direkt mit Thunderbolt 2 anschließt, was direkt 20 Gigabit darüber macht. Aber Apple hat ja irgendwie nach Storage und Zeugs und haben ja auch alles eingestellt vor einer Weile. Also da kommt ja dann höchstwahrscheinlich erstmal nichts, oder doch? Oder war das der Grund, dass sie eingestellt haben, weil jetzt was Neues kommt?
Was eingestellt haben?
Na, ihr ganzen Storyschkram haben sie doch eingestellt.
Naja, sie haben das ganze Server-Fitness eingestellt.
Das machen die nicht mehr.
Ja, aber gerade jetzt bei so einem Gerät wäre das ja aber wichtig.
Ja, aber da setzen sie halt voll auf den Third-Party-Markt. Also ich meine so...
Ja, aber der Third-Party-Markt setzt anscheinend nicht auf Apple. Ja, wo sind denn die ganzen Geräte?
Pegasus.
Pegasus. Die wären sicherlich auch an Thunderbolt 2.
Wie lange haben sie jetzt gebraucht? Zwei Jahre? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Pegasus war gleich von Anfang an dabei. Die war von Anfang an. Insgesamt ist dieser ganze Thunderbolt-Markt echt unterentwickelt. Und man kann jetzt nur hoffen, dass mit dieser Büchse sich das noch mal ein bisschen beschleunigt. Aber an sich sehe ich da gerade noch nicht so richtig...
Na, immerhin ist Thunderbolt 2 eine Aussage. Wir setzen weiterhin aufs gleiche Pferd. Und nun schneller. Hätte ja auch sein können. Oh Gott, ist das alles doof und wir können es nicht auf die Reihe. Und wir machen jetzt doch USB 3 oder was es doch immer da alles so gibt. Der Thunderbolt Anschluss ist eigentlich der exakt gleiche. Ist der pin-kompatibel, also stecker-kompatibel?
Ja, angeblich soll alles Backward-kompatibel sein. Es gibt ja noch andere Buden wie Sonnet zum Beispiel, die schon länger Thunderbolt-Produkte ankündigen. Ich weiß immer nicht so richtig, wie verfügbar die immer so sind. Das mag sich jetzt etwas verbessert haben, aber hier ist auch unter anderem auch von einem 10 Gigabit Ethernet über Thunderbolt die Rede. Und die haben auch, glaube ich, aber da gibt es auch andere Anbieter, auch solche PCI-Büchschen. Oder? Welche Bude war denn, dass sie diese PCI-Enclosures?
Sonnet fahrt auch schon mit.
Ich weiß zumindest noch, was von Apple demnächst ein neuer Hardware kommt.
Sprich?
Ein 4K-Display.
Das denke ich auch. Dieses Heldendisplay, was ich vorhin meinte. So wie früher, da gab es auch früher mal so ein Ding. Der 30 Zoll. Der 30 Zoll, das war ja damals so ihr Premium-Ding für die echten Chefs.
Das war aber nicht 4K.
Nee, aber es gab immer mal so ein Premium-Display für richtig teuer, für die Leute, die sich für echt wichtig halten. Und da denke ich, so ein Ding wird es auch wieder geben.
Ich kannte mal jemanden, der hatte so ein Ding.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so ein... Natürlich ist es teuer bei Apple und so weiter, aber es wird nicht ganz so ein Mega-Premium sein. Bei 4K-Display sind es einfach die nächsten Dinger, die kommen müssen, oder?
Es sei denn, Apple schafft es tatsächlich, die Teile als Retina rauszubringen.
Na, das 4K wird Retina sein, weil wie groß soll das Display werden bei 4K?
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass sie bei diesem Bildschirm überhaupt mit dem Argument Retina kommen werden, weil es einfach nicht diesen definierten Bildschirmabstand gibt. Also, den könnte man sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch noch aus der Nase ziehen. Beim iPhone und beim iPad gibt es halt einen mehr oder weniger natürlichen Abstand, den du zu diesen Kräten hältst.
Beim Macbook auch?
Vor der Nase und beim Macbook auch, weil das ist ja sozusagen der Abstand deiner Arme.
Und beim Bildschirm nicht, oder wie?
Und beim Bildschirm ist das nicht unbedingt so gegeben.
Bist du da näher dran, oder was?
Da bist du auch in so einem gewissen Abstand.
Ja, du bist in einem gewissen Abstand, aber man könnte jetzt nicht... Wie auch immer. Ich sag, ist es auch nur eine These von mir, ich glaub nicht, dass sie da mit dem Retina-Ding ziehen werden, sondern sie werden mit 4K ziehen. Wenn sie das jetzt schon so nennen, dann werden sie auch bei dieser Bezeichnung bleiben, dann ist das einfach das Apple Thunderbolt 4K...
Retina-Display.
Genau, die müssen sich ja unterscheiden von den anderen 4K-Displays.
Jetzt bitte ins Tool eintragen. Wenn man es im Film sagt, heißt nicht Retina-Display.
Denn es heißt 4K-Retina. Oder wahrscheinlich sogar nur Retina. Weil 4K heißt es bei allen anderen sowieso schon. Apple braucht ja was, die müssen sich ja von der Masse absetzen. Aber ich erkläre noch mal kurz, warum es Retina ist.
Wie viele 4K-Displays kennst du schon?
Sony und diese bei anderen Buden da. Gibt's doch schon. Also Fernseher weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau. Jedenfalls, das 24 Zoll, das größte Display von Apple... 27 Zoll mit 2.500 Pixel, richtig?
Kann sein.
Wenn du das jetzt hochskalierst auf... Wieviel ist denn eigentlich 4K? Das ist doch...
Fuck.
4K nach unten, oder? 4.000, keine Ahnung.
4 in der Breite. Wir sind wieder die Vollprofis am Werk. Ich gehe jetzt mal raus, dass es 4K in der Breite sind. Jedenfalls, wenn dein 27 Zoll 2.500 hat und du willst es auf 4K hochziehen, dann wirst du das ja weiß nicht, wie viel, über 30 Zoll sonst, wie groß sind, das geht einfach nicht. Deswegen müssen sie die Pixel enger machen und wenn sie die Pixel enger machen, die DPI steigt, dann können sie es auch Retina nennen. Und da macht es auch wieder Sinn, finde ich.
Wie groß sind die anderen alle, die du so schön nanntest?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wir sind hier bei Mobile Max.
Jetzt der TPLF von dem Ding, der Tim-Prittlauf-Lag-Faktor. Was sagst du denn zum Design von dem LM?
Diese PCI-Express-Boxen von Sonnet, die heißen Echo Express. Die gibt es in drei verschiedenen Varianten. Pro, 2 und mit ohne irgendwas dran. Und in der Pro sind zwei PCI-Slots drin, mit X16. In der Express 2 hast du auch zwei, irgendwie nicht ganz so lang. Und in der normalen Echo Express hast du einen Slot.
Der Zeug ist teurer als die ganze Kiste.
Die Pro kostet hier bei Amazon 846 Euro. Ein Stück Metall, in das du zwei PCI-Karten reinstecken kannst. Geht's noch? Also für Leute mit Kartenbedarf wird's teuer. Es sei denn, dieser Mac Pro ist so billig, dass du dir keinen iMac mehr kaufen willst.
Jetzt sag doch mal, würdest du dir den überhaupt auf den Tisch stellen? Oder ist der nicht leckig genug?
Wenn der 1000 Dollar kostet, klar.
Ich meine jetzt hier unseren Chef-Design.
Da muss noch einiges... Nee, ich finde meinen alten Profi geiler. Ich will das da alles reinstecken und klappe zu und Schluss. Und mit diesem Rund und klein und hat oben einen Griff und man stellt es auf den Tisch, da bin ich mal ganz vorsichtig. Weil das mit dem Cube, das war schon so ein Fail.
Auf dem Boden willst du das Ding nicht stehen haben. Der saugt ja von unten den Staub an, die Luft. Und das bei Mac Pro war schon ganz cool, dass er so ein bisschen, ein paar Zentimeter am Boden schwebt, weil der Dreck ist immer ganz unten.
Das stimmt.
Kannst du wahrscheinlich... Das ist geil!
Du kannst es sozusagen, dann brauchst du gar keinen Roomba mehr, du musst eigentlich nur noch so eine Rollmechanik darunter bauen, dann kannst du deinen Mac Pro durch die Gegend fahren lassen.
Ja oder du stellst ihn wirklich auf einen Roomba, dann hast du mehr Power.
Hat das Ding eigentlich auch WLAN drin? Ja, er hat nur AC-WLAN.
Die WLAN ist ja auch noch nicht Power.
Deswegen lässt du ihn durch die Gegend fahren.
Wahrscheinlich musst du es sogar auf einen Roomba stellen, damit du den entsprechenden Staubfilter am Start hast. Der Roomba, der haut dir erstmal den Staub weg, damit oben der Pro, naja.
Wie gesagt, und dann mit schnurlos Gigabit ESL, 812.11ac fährt es auf deinem Roomba durch die Gegend.
Nur noch der Funkstrom ist so. Bis dahin war es schön. 846 Euro. Was kostet denn die normale Echo Express?
Tims subtiler Versuch, euch zum Flattern zu bringen.
Echo Express Pro. Echo Express SE. Eine kleine Karte, 380 Euro. Ist geil, da kostest du eine 150 Euro Karte und steckst sie in dein 380 Euro Gehäuse.
Was meint ihr eigentlich? Das war ja, was die vorgestellt haben, mit 12 Cores und zweimal Grafikkarte. Kommt auch ein Mac Pro mit nur einer Grafikkarte? Warum nicht?
Das ist sowieso eine kleine Serie. Die sind sowieso handgezimmert.
Dann lassen sie einfach ein Modul weg.
Ist doch egal. Wenn wir gleich zu OSX kommen, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe, ist auch die Nutzbarkeit von Grafikkarten extrem angestiegen für das System. Ja, die können mehrere Grafikkarten gleichzeitig besser nutzen als bisher. Nicht nur für weitere Bildschirme, sondern auch generell für die gesamte Performance. Da sie die gesamte Acceleration von allen möglichen, Scrolling und so weiter, zunehmend auf diese Subsysteme auslagern, Core Animation und so weiter, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das Gerät eine Menge rausholt aus diesen Grafikkarten. Und dadurch, dass sie ohnehin mit dem Versprechen, du kriegst hier schon mal drei fette Bildschirme angeschlossen und du hast eh keine Wünsche noch eine externe Grafikkarte.
Ja, aber das war jetzt das rechts unten Modell, was sie da vorgestellt haben.
Ich argumentiere mal andersrum. Max ohne Bildschirm hast du ja den Mac Mini und du hast dann diesen Staubsauger Mac Pro. Und der Mac Mini, der ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt langsam, aber er hat halt irgendwie nur eine Grafikkarte und alles. Und du willst natürlich als Apple, willst du natürlich dieses Upselling vom Mac Mini zum Mac Pro halt den Leuten auch schmackhaft machen. Und wenn du da jetzt ein Modell hast, das nur eine Grafikkarte hat, was dann nur so eine Sparvariante davon ist, dann ist der Abstand zum Mac Mini nicht groß genug, dass die Leute sagen, ja es lohnt sich jetzt dafür, einen Tausender mehr auszugeben.
Ja, aber Mac Mini ist ja jetzt auch trotzdem nur so eine Low-End-Grafikkarte drin und in dem Mac Pro könntest du ja trotzdem eine fette Single-Grafikkarte reinmachen, weil der Kühlkörper ist halt da. Und ich weiß, was Grafikkarten an Power verbrauchen.
Na gut, aber wenn sie in der Lage sind, die Performance von beiden Karten für das System auch zu nutzen, gleichförmig, dass du die Nutzen nicht nur dann hast, wenn du viele Bildschirme anschließt. Ist ja eh schon so. Ich meine, du kannst drei Bildschirme anschließen und du hast zwei Grafikkarten.
Ja, du kannst doch jetzt schon drei Show mal anschließen an eine Grafikkarte.
Ja, aber was ist, wenn du drei an zwei betreibst? Ist dann sozusagen eine Karte für zwei?
Na wahrscheinlich.
Und die andere Karte nur für einen Bildschirm zuständig? Na, da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher. Also vielleicht gelitten ja, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wie sehr die miteinander verwoben sind. Dass sie das jetzt irgendwie anders verteilen. We don't know. Wir werden es sehen, wenn das Teil rauskommt. Mac Pro sieht lustig aus. Ich finde, also mein erster Gedanke war Batterie und das werde ich irgendwie nicht los.
Batterie?
Ja. Ich denke an so eine Batterie, wenn ich das Ding sehe.
Das sieht ja wirklich aus wie hier so ein Sektflaschenkühler.
Du meinst so eine Atombatterie, die man so oben in seinen Fluxkompensator reintut?
Genau.
Das passt dann auch zu diesen Ansagen, dass das irgendwie unglaubliche Geschwindigkeit so sein soll. Wie hieß das nochmal im Deutschen bei Douglas Adams? Diese Raumschiffgeschwindigkeit?
Der Unwahrscheinlichkeitsdreif.
Nee, aber gab doch diesen Faktor irgendwie unglaubliche Geschwindigkeit 2 oder sowas?
Blödsinnige Geschwindigkeit, das war aber glaube ich, das war diese...
Ich könnte mir jedenfalls gut vorstellen, dass es auch so ein bisschen, dass das die High-End-Variante ist, die sie da gezeigt haben und dass natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr was Low-End-mäßig kommt. Und es kann ja nicht sein, dass sie da einfach nur eine billigere CPU nehmen, sondern da werden sie auch so ein bisschen abstecken. Vielleicht ist es ja weiterhin Dual-GPU, aber halt eben ein bisschen schwächer und nicht dieses Fire GL Profi-Stuff, was sie da irgendwie ein paar Höckern von AMD.
Wir werden es sehen.
Spaceboards.
Klappen wir mal, ich glaube, können wir jetzt zumachen das Thema, oder? Kapitelmarke.
Ja, dann würde ich mal sagen, damit wir noch ein bisschen, weil wir jetzt gerade schon so bei, wir sind halt noch nicht bei Mobile, würde ich sagen, wir machen jetzt mit dem Sea-Lion weiter.
Bei der Hardware, bei der fehlenden Hardware. Wo ist die Uhr geblieben? Wo ist iWatch geblieben? Alle Leute haben monatelang iWatch geschrieben.
Ja, nächstes Jahr.
Dann glaube ich ja auch nicht dran.
Next.
Also wer weiß, vielleicht ist das jetzt das große Ablenkungsfeuerwerk gewesen und in ein paar Wochen kommt die iWatch, wo keiner mehr mit rechnet. Aber ehrlich gesagt, das ist, wie sagt man so schön, Thema für eine andere Sendung.
Ich denke mal schon, dass da auch noch andere Kram kommt.
OSX 10.9, also known as OSX Mavericks.
Ja, Mavericks.
Da war schon mal bei Grafikkarten an.
Das war wohl nix.
Da ist ja dein OpenGL 4.0 unterstützt. 4.1 sogar, echt?
Warte mal, ich hatte mir...
Gib mir jetzt mal dieses USB-Teil her, ich mach das jetzt mal.
Ich finde übrigens C-Line viel besser. Ich finde, wir sollten hier bei C-Line bleiben.
So, kriegst du den oder hast du den gerade? Dein USB-Stick.
Ne, du kannst den haben.
Scheiße, meine Uptime. Ich hatte letztens 80 Tage Uptime, bis dieses Scheiß 1084 kam.
Das sind das alte Scheißkram. Ich hab noch ein altes Handzulaufen, das läuft seit über 5 Jahren durch. Und davor auch nur, weil ich seine andere Dreck einbauen musste und eher den Strom klauen musste. Und wie gesagt, du mit deinen 80 Tagen, dieser Apple-Kram, dieser User-Kram.
Ja, meine 80 Tage abzeigen, die waren inzwischen in Hamburg, in Paraborn und was weiß ich nicht, überall. Nee, in Hamburg war sie gar nicht. Aber ich trag das Ding jeden Tag mit mir rum. Deine steht wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Ecke und wird nicht benutzt, sonst wäre die nämlich schon offen.
Eine Sun? Die steht seit über 5 Jahren im rechten Zentrum.
Der Seelöwe.
Welche Musiken hier starten Mavericks an?
Also es gibt hier mehrere interessante Aspekte. Ich finde, das neue OSX, was sie angekündigt haben, ist vor allem mal ein ganz signifikanter Bug-Fix. Es sieht ja ganz so aus, als ob sie so ein paar Folgen Mobile Max tatsächlich gehört haben. Und dann gibt es noch einen zweiten interessanten Trend, nämlich dieses, alles, was so auf dem iPad an Mehrwert geschaffen wurde, kommt jetzt auch so ein bisschen mehr wieder ins Heim. Zum Beispiel iBooks. Ja, das finde ich mal ganz ordentlich, weil das hat mich schon total immer gestört, dass diese ganze Buchlese-Geschichte so auf dem Mac überhaupt nicht stattfindet. Du konntest da irgendwie so ein paar Files in deinem iTunes ablegen, aber mal ein Buch lesen und so weiter war einfach nicht möglich. Also so ein Betriebssystem ohne IPA-Brieder halte ich auch, könnte man schon gar nicht mehr so richtig ernst nehmen.
Aber meintest du ein bisschen, dass es doch auch, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Totgebot ist ja noch ein bisschen zu früh für, aber viel benutzt wird das nicht, oder? Also man liest relativ wenig von neuen Büchern, neuen Produkten. Wenn man hier, ich lese ja mal McSurf, und da ist ja wirklich alles abgebildet, was so passiert, von Büchern lese ich echt immer nix.
Also ich sag mal so, in letzter Zeit kaufe ich schon immer mal das eine oder andere E-Book von O'Reilly. Und da ist eigentlich immer ein PDF und immer ein EPUB dabei. Und es nervt mich eigentlich jedes Mal, wenn ich auf dem Mac das EPUB nicht lesen kann, sondern dass ich das eigentlich nur auf dem iPad lesen kann.
Aber gibt es da nicht irgendwelche anderen Reader?
Ich hab keinen gefunden, der auch nur annähernd brauchbar war. Insofern, es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie die große Verheißung, dass da jetzt irgendwie E-Books für Mac OS kommt, aber sie füllen damit eine Lücke, die irgendwie schon auch mal gefüllt gehört. Finde ich.
Also auf jeden Fall, hier schreibt einer, ich hätte Kategorien vorausgesagt. Was für Kategorien habe ich vorausgesagt? Weiß ich von nichts. Ich vergesse ja immer wieder alles, was ich sage, das war auch ganz gut. Ja gut, also E-Books kommt, finden wir gut, ist okay. Dann, was ich definitiv vorausgesagt habe, waren Maps.
Das hatte ich aber auch vorausgesagt.
Wer nicht? Das hat Roddy auch vorausgesagt, genau.
Ja, wer nicht?
Ich nicht.
Wir haben es irgendwie geahnt, das war auch der totale No-Braner. Ich meine, jetzt wo sie die eigenen Karten haben, ist es klar, dass sie das damit reinheben. Und wenn ich das so richtig sehe, gibt es jetzt dieses Map-Kit dann mehr oder weniger auch in derselben Funktionsfülle unter iOS und auf dem Mac. Das ist natürlich gerade für Cross-Platform-Development.
Wenn man das noch Cross-Platform-Development nennen kann.
Das ist das einzige Cross-Platform-Development, was ich irgendwie interessant finde.
Aber ich kann immer noch nicht übers Web draufzugreifen, das heißt, ich kann jetzt nur irgendwie eine App bauen, die dann diese tolle Programm da hochfeuert oder wie auch immer. Oder kann ich das auch in eigene Apps integrieren? Also richtig die Grafik.
Du kannst jetzt halt so ein Map-View in deinem Programm aufmachen.
Ich kann jetzt nicht wie bei Google Maps oder Open-Street-Maps mit irgendwelchen AP-Keys oder sonst irgendwas...
Nicht im Web. Nur da, wo es sich monetarisieren lässt, ohne Werbung. Über den Verkauf von Hardware. Trotzdem, das, finde ich, gehört rein in so ein Desktop-OS. Das fand ich schon immer schlecht, dass das so nicht da war. Manche haben sich ja dann so beholfen mit irgendwie... Aber auch eher schlecht als recht. Man findet überhaupt recht wenig Karten in Programmen. Und das fand ich eigentlich schon immer anprangungswürdig.
Also die Maps-Applikation, ich hab sie ausprobiert, die funktioniert halt genauso, wie man es erwartet. Außer das Einzige, was mir nicht gelungen ist, ist irgendwie die Karte zu kippen. Also es gibt da so einen 3D-Button, den kann man drücken, dann kriegt man einen bestimmten Winkel. Und wenn man nochmal draufdrückt, dann ist es wieder gerade.
Ja, ich hätte gerne dasselbe Verhalten wie bei Google Earth. Weil im Prinzip mit ihrem Flyover-View, der ist halt besser als Google Earth. Also von der Optik her, finde ich. Und das hätte ich gerne hier mit meinem E-Probe.
Du kannst jetzt durch den Eiffelturm durchgucken.
Na, es gibt hier so dieses, ich hab ja hier diesen kleinen 3D-Connection, diesen Space Navigator. Das ist wirklich ein schickes Teil, weil da kannst du einfach mal so Gelände ganz interessant erfassen. Das haben sie ja in der Demo gezeigt. Also sie haben da zumindest schon mal so einen Rotierer um den aktuellen Viewpunkt herum-Modus.
Ja, das geht auch mit so einer Rotier-Pinch-Geste. Das ist mir gelungen. Was mir halt nicht gelungen ist, ist halt die View-Ebene, also diesen View-Winkel zu verändern. Warum auch immer. Vielleicht ist es noch ein Bug, aber...
Richtig angefixt bin ich, wenn das hier mit dem Space Navigator funktioniert. Wenn dieser Space Navigator sich da reinplackt. Ja, weil das ist einfach das Beste. Du willst einfach so viele Achsen steuern können bei solchen Flyovers.
Naja, also ich mein, wir müssen mal schauen. Das ist die Developer Preview 1. Das ist so das, was irgendwie eine Woche vor der WWDC irgendwie aus dem Bild-Server rausfiel. Und dafür ist es schon sehr, sehr gut.
Ja, das müssen sie ja gar nicht mal selber unterstützen. Der Space-Navigator muss sich da entsprechend einklinken. Die Frage ist, ob sie die Möglichkeit bieten, sich einzuklinken. Ja, also Maps findet statt und da sind ja und was ja auch dann ganz interessant ist, dass du ja auch hier Directions hast. Dann haben sie diese Demo gezeigt, mit dass du diese Directions dann auch gleich weiter schicken kannst an dein iPhone. Das heißt, du kannst am Rechner bequem suchen und tippen.
So wurde ja auch Zeit.
So, was haben wir hier als nächstes? Wir scrollen mal hier so durch, wie die Features hier so auf der Webseite angeboten werden. Kalender.
Also der Kalender sieht anders aus, aber tut nicht viel mehr als vorher, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Hast du das mit dem Scrolling probiert im Wochenmodus?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Ist ja genauso wie auf dem iPhone. Läuft gerade irgendwo? Hast du gebootet da?
Dauert.
Ja, aber es ist leider von diesem USB-Stick extrem langsam.
Naja, also sie sprechen halt von Continuous Scrawling. Scrolls smoothly through weeks and months and stop anywhere you like. Klingt jetzt mal so, als hätten sie endlich eingesehen, was ich seit Jahr und Tag gesagt habe. Und ich frag mich ehrlich gesagt, was sie davon abgehalten hat, das nicht schon immer zu tun. Ach, nur komm.
Sei nicht so gemein.
Ja, gemein. Ich mein, jetzt hast du lange noch umgejammert. Jetzt haben sie endlich auf dich gehört. Jetzt haben sie wieder nicht früher noch auf dich gehört.
Ich will mir das erst mal angucken. Ich trau ihnen halt da alles Mögliche zu. Also es gibt auf den ersten Blick Verbesserungen, auch was so die Visibilität betrifft. Es ist ja derzeit noch nicht mal leicht zu sehen, was eigentlich der aktuelle Tag ist. Das haben sie so ein bisschen verbessert. Aber ich fand die Visibilität beim Kalender doch sehr verbesserungswürdig.
Ja, so richtig vom Hocker gehauen hat es mich nicht.
Ich finde einfach, dass sie aus Zeit generell nicht genug rausholen. Ich finde, Zeit ist etwas, da kann man mit dem Betriebssystem eine Menge machen. Es ist schon ganz nett, dass sie jetzt so Travel-Time damit reinnehmen und so. Das heißt, du hast dein Meeting und kannst die Anfahrt dazu nehmen. Das hängt natürlich auch sehr davon ab, wie gut diese Qualität ist, diese Travel-Geschichte. Wenn man sich hier ein bisschen durchs Brandenburger Land leiten lässt von Apple Maps, da ist auch noch einiges zu tun.
Da ist Polen offen, also zumindest kommt man schnell dort an.
Genau. Safari wird dann hier noch groß gefeatured. Interessant finde ich hier, dass sie jetzt wie Chrome auf das One Process per Tab Modell wechseln.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte das so in Erinnerung, dass sie das schon mal großartig angekündigt haben.
Nein, da haben sie einen, sie hatten zwar so einen Mehrprozess-Modus, das war mit WebKit 2. Der sah aber so aus, dass das gesamte Rendering quasi in einem Prozess für alle Seiten gemacht wird. Deswegen gibt es ja auch diesen merkwürdigen Effekt, dass wenn jetzt mal irgendwas hängt im Rendern, dann so, ich bin irgendwie kaputt, Hilfe, drück hier Reload und dann lade ich aber auch alle Tabs nochmal neu. Und das heißt, alles hing letztlich an einem Prozess und ich finde auch diese ganze Performance war nicht da und das hat bei Chrome sehr viel besser funktioniert. Gerade wenn man auch so unter Security-Aspekten drüber nachdenkt, macht es einfach mal total Sinn.
Wie du meinst, die haben ihre Anfangsstrategie jetzt über den Haufen geworfen und sind jetzt zu dem Weg, den Google gegangen ist, umgeschwenkt. Hatten wir jetzt WebKit 2 eigentlich vorher schon oder noch nicht?
Seit Safari 6.
5?
5.1? 5.1 war WebKit 2 und der war dann zwar schneller, aber hakt auch häufiger, finde ich. Ich habe sehr oft dieses Fenster gehabt mit irgendwas, das Braun laht alles neu und das ist einfach mal, es geht gar nicht. Überarbeitet mit irgendwas, irgendeine bekloppte Webseite, die gerade gar nicht wichtig ist, führt dann dazu, dass in einem anderen Tab, wo ich gerade ein halbes Formular ausgefüllt hatte, mir irgendwie alles um die Ohren fliegt und das ist so ein Zustand, den finde ich einfach nicht akzeptabel. Also ich habe da jetzt sehr viel mehr Hoffnung, gerade auch in dem Gesichtspunkt, dass sie jetzt so viel Wert auf Performance und Power legen. Also das Xcode ist ja voll mit neuen Performance-Testing-Sachen. Das ist schon ganz sinnvoll. So vom Gui-Layout her finde ich das ganz vielversprechend. Also gerade so die Bookmarks nicht mehr in diesem, also die Bookmarks in so einem Sidebar anzuzeigen, ist eine ganz sinnvolle Sache.
Ja, auch dass sie dieses 3D-Theater-Ding jetzt da wieder rausgebaut haben, ist eigentlich ganz schön.
Coverflow ist verschwunden, auf dem iPhone auch.
Coverflow ist aus der Music-App rausgeflogen aus dem iPhone.
Zeit wurde es.
Zeit wurde es, ja gut. Das war mal ein Gag, aber ist jetzt auch wieder gut.
War schon immer eine scheiß Idee, ja. Ja, dann muss ich doch nur schon sehr grinsen, als sie irgendwie diese iCloud-Keychain angekündigt haben. Ja, jetzt!
Du meinst die NSA-Keychain?
Die NSA-Keychain.
Nee, aber das ging doch irgendwann mal mit Mobile-Meet-Zeiten oder davor noch. Wie ist das irgendwie? Wie ist das vor Mobile-Meet?
Ja, aber nur zwischen Max und nicht von Max auf iOS. Und das ist das Feature, was sie jetzt glaube ich damit angreifen wollen, dass du jetzt deine Passworte reinhackst, dann kann die NSA sie lesen und dein iPhone. Nicht?
Die Aluhut-Fraktion.
Die Aluhüte sind ja nur seit letzter Woche runter. Meine Prism ist jetzt ein anderes Thema, aber all die Leute, die uns Aluhut-Träger geschimpft haben diesbezüglich, die mussten sich jetzt auch mal gerade in die Ecke stellen und schämen. Also von daher.
Gut, also unabhängig jetzt von dieser Überwachungsfrage, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist diese iCloud, also ist diese Keychain aber schon so, genauer noch weiß ich es nicht so ganz genau, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, wovon gehe ich denn eigentlich aus? Wovon können wir denn ausgehen?
Wir könnten davon ausgehen, dass wir zum Kongress da mehr zu erfahren. Zumindest hoffe ich das. Leute, ihr da draußen, bitte schön, ich zähle auf euch.
Also sie haben auf jeden Fall sich eine Menge abgeschaut bei One Password, was man auch daran erkennt, dass sie halt auch diesen Keyword, also Password Generator, mit eingebaut haben.
Ja, aber Password Generator gab's schon immer in der Keychain.
Ja, aber du hattest es nicht im normalen User Interface im Safari, dass jetzt wirklich dir an der Stelle, wo ein neues Passwort von der Webseite verlangt wird, dir automatisch dieser Generator angezeigt wurde. Oder? Also sie hatten den schon immer im System, aber so richtig genutzt haben sie ihn nicht. Und so eine Abstraktion wie Kreditkarten gab's in dem Sinne vorher auch noch überhaupt nicht. One Passwort macht natürlich immer noch tausend Sachen besser und vielfältiger. Und vor allem kannst du halt sünden ohne iCloud zu benutzen.
Und wenn du dich traust, kannst du sogar nach Windows sünden. Weil es ja One Passwort für Windows gibt.
Ach so, richtig.
Wie gesagt, aber das muss man sich halt trauen.
Aber sagen wir mal grundsätzlich erstmal natürlich auch kein Fehler, dass jetzt die normale OSX Keychain sich eben dann auch auf deine anderen Geräte und mit iOS erschliesst.
Ja, wie gesagt, also ich meine, dieses von einem Mac auf einen anderen, jetzt mal unabhängig davon, dass es zu iOS nie ging, das ging ja schon mal mit Mobile Meets.
Ja genau, das haben sie dann einfach gedroppt.
Dass es dann irgendwann nicht mehr ging, das hat mich ja schon tierisch genervt damals. Multiple Displays. Ich würde mal sagen, dein Traum ist wahr geworden, wa?
Das sieht in der Tat so viele Leute.
Aber ich meine, das war ja auch klar, dass sie diesen komischen Bug fixen, dass man, wenn man zwei Screens hat und eine Fullscreen App startet, dass da irgendwie diese Raufasertapete kommt.
Aber weißt du warum?
Das hätten sie auch schon in der Mountain-Line fixen.
Die haben die Raufasertapete rausgenommen und dann haben sie gemerkt, jetzt ist es nur noch grau.
Ach stimmt, das Linen ist weg. Oder?
Ich glaube ja. Mach mal das Message-Send da auf.
Ich kann ja nix aufmachen, Roddy. Das Besteck ist so langsam, da ist meine Diskette schneller.
Das hat nicht alles mit Scott Forstl zu tun. Ich glaube, das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass auch Steve raus ist. Weil dieses iOS-7-Desaster, das hätte er bestimmt verhindert. Aber da kommen wir gleich zu. Multiple Displays. Jetzt loben wir mal hier den Apfel. Von dem, was ich bisher gesehen habe, würde ich sagen, ja, danke, endlich, schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Das war in etwa das, worüber wir gesprochen haben, oder? Du kannst jetzt auf jedem Bildschirm separat sagen, was da Fullscreen ist. Mich würde sehr interessieren, wie sich das verhält, wenn man jetzt auf Bildschirm B so eine App fullscreens und ich auf Bildschirm A ein Fenster nehme und das dahin ziehe, wo dieser Bildschirm ist. Ist dann irgendwie belegt, kann ich das da trotzdem noch dahinter schieben? Das war mir immer so ein bisschen unklar und das war auch klar, dass sie da eine gute Antwort haben. Nach wie vor ist es ja schon so, dass quasi jeder Bildschirm für sich ist. Aber um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, du hast jetzt den Menu Bar auf jedem Bildschirm, das finde ich sehr sinnvoll.
Die switcht irgendwie so komisch rüber, ne?
Ja, das war schon immer total verwirrend, dass du diesen nicht hast. Dann musstest du irgendwie von dem einen Bildschirm arbeitest, und mit dem Programm, und dann musst du irgendwie zwei Bildschirme nach rechts mit deiner Maus rüberziehen, nur um diesen Scheiß-Menue-Eintrag da anzuklicken.
Wie ist das jetzt genau gedacht? Der hat immer gesagt, man kann da hinrufen. Muss ich da hinrufen oder taucht? Also wenn ich... Taucht das Menü und der Dog immer darauf, wo meine Maus gerade ist.
Wenn ich das richtig gesehen hab, dann ist es so, dass das Menü und Dog bleibt erstmal, wo es ist. Und wenn du mit der Maus auf den entsprechenden Bildschirm gehst, und entweder ganz nach oben, dann klappt oben das Menü raus oder ganz nach unten, dann klappt von unten das Dog hoch.
Ist mir recht. Ist okay.
So wie jetzt schon quasi in so einem Fullscreen-Modus.
Ja, so hab ich es verstanden. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt richtig verstanden hab.
Ja, klingt sinnvoll. Und auch dieses Mission-Control schien mir jetzt die richtige Abstraktion zu bieten. Jetzt kann man damit wahrscheinlich sogar tatsächlich mal was anfangen. Und was natürlich ganz großes Kino ist, ist, dass sie jetzt endlich auch Airplay-Devices als vollwertige Bildschirme machen. Ich frag mich mal nur, wie dynamisch dieser ganze Kack ist.
Das ist eine der Sachen, die ich gefordert hatte. Nur weil ihr mal so, weil alle jetzt mit Tolltis so Bescheid... Ich hab ja letztes Mal gesagt, geht jetzt in diese Richtung, wir machen die Matrix komplett, dass jeder Gerät irgendwo anders auf jedes andere Gerät irgendwie hin displayen oder so kann.
Du kannst noch nicht ein Mac als Target benutzen.
Ja, nächste Runde. C-Line. C-Line 2.
C-Line.
Shopping Mall. Auch ne amerikanische Errungenschaft. Weiß nicht, was gibt es da noch für Orte?
Ich sag doch Rocky Beach.
Rocky Beach?
Ist der Ort, in dem die drei Fragezeichen spielen. Supposedly auch in Kalifornien.
Verstehe. Ja, das ist natürlich cool, aber wo ich so ein bisschen Schiss hab, das ist so diese Dynamik, weil heißt das, dass ich... Was heißt denn das? Angenommen, dieser Airplay-Bildschirm ist mein drittes Device. Ein dritter Bildschirm, oder überhaupt mein zweiter Bildschirm. Ich hab so einen Hauptbildschirm und dann hab ich da so einen Apple TV und das ist jetzt mein zweiter Bildschirm. Klar, ich selektier das, wähl das aus, hab ich zwei Bildschirme. Zack, wunderbar. Jetzt schieb ich das in der Konfiguration so hin und her. Wo ist denn der relativ zu dem anderen? Pipapo. Dann leg ich da meine Programme drauf, mach vielleicht mal einen Fullscreen. So, jetzt kommst du irgendwie auf deinem scheiß iPhone auf die falsche Taste und wählst dieses Apple TV als Target aus.
Was macht das Apple TV? Du bist jetzt schon getargetet. Das geht jetzt schon nicht. Nein, wenn du zwei iPhones hast, die auf das Ding beide zugreifen. Der, der es hat, hattet.
Nein, das ist genau nicht so, sondern der letzte, der kommt, haut immer den anderen weg. Weiß ich genau, haben wir mehrfach schon bei Workshops sozusagen benutzt. Wer zuletzt kommt, hat gewonnen. Und da musst du dann schon mit Passwörtern arbeiten, um das zu verhindern. Da gibt es überhaupt keinen, ist schon belegt. So, die Frage ist, was macht dann das OSX? Also wenn jetzt dieses Apple TV kurzfristig einem anderen jetzt Platz macht, haut das dann diesen Bildschirm komplett weg und ist nicht mehr da und schwupps und alle deine Programme werden wieder auf den ersten Bildschirm geworfen, damit die Fenster da sind.
Klar, es wird alles blau und dann werden die Fenster umsortiert.
Let's try it out.
Ja, oder?
Mit Pause und Hallo, du hast ja hier so ein Ding, oder? Du hast ja hier so ein Puck.
Ja, aber ich hab keinen.
Aber er, hier, da. Wir haben da hier gerade ein Zielein zu laufen.
Hast du den jetzt laufen? Ja?
Na ja, gestartet schon so, theoretisch. Aber laufen würde ich das nicht sagen. Der ist eher so Schneckentempo.
Ja, dann kannst du da einen Bildschirm auswählen.
Du kannst da oben hier den...
Black Magic?
Ja, aber das ist ja so wie jetzt auch, sozusagen. Wo ist denn da der Unterschied?
Ich weiß nicht, was soll ich machen?
Kannst du da als zweiten Bildschirm auswählen oder kannst du nur so mit Mirroring?
Ich weiß schon, aber ich weiß auch, was noch Black Magic heißt. Egal, lassen wir das. So, jetzt wollen wir es sehen. Und der hängt jetzt hier auch dran irgendwie. Nein, schalt doch mal um bitte hier den tollen Beamer.
Ich müsste jetzt mal umschalten.
Da ist die Beamer-Fernsteuerung.
Irgendetwas hat er jetzt hier gemacht, aber was er gemacht hat, weiß ich nicht so genau.
So, da ist die Surf-Wave. Jetzt gehe ich hier hin und mache mein Tollid-iPhone und sehen jetzt gleich irgendwie Dennis Rechner abstürzen und werde jetzt gleich diesen Bildschirm da konka. Achtung.
Warte, dann zeig doch erst mal, wie das mit dem Menü. Also, der Menübar ist immer zu sehen, der ist nur so leicht ausgegraut. Und wenn du da jetzt reinklickst, dann bleibt der auch ausgegraut, oder was?
Nee, nee, der hier ist ausgegraut.
Ach so, das ist so Translucency. Das ist wieder dieser Scheiß, mit alles ist durchsichtig und so.
So, und wenn ich aber jetzt hier mit der Maus auf meinen Schirm gehe und hier ein Feiner drücke, dann ist der ausgegraut und meiner nimmt...
Okay, aber der verschwindet nicht komplett wie in diesem Fullscreen-Modus, sondern er ist nur weniger zu sehen. Okay.
Ja, macht ja auch Sinn. Warum sollte man den dann nicht auch haben?
Und wenn du jetzt Menü aufrufst, klappt das aber nicht auf allen Bildschirmen?
Nee, nee, er macht gerade, also das...
Da wo die Maus halt gerade ist, also ist ja auch ganz easy, hätte er schon immer so machen können.
So, jetzt kann ich ja mal... Jetzt kann ich ja mal den Bildschirm hier übernehmen.
Nee, das mach ich gerade schon. Was dachte er, ein Ding? Ist das oben noch blau oder ist das gestorben?
Das ist noch blau.
So, jetzt mach ich mal ein Ding hier wieder weg. Sag ich jetzt, hier, du darfst wieder auch noch eine Leine haben.
Jetzt ist das Apple TV... Macht niemanden mehr.
Na ja gut, es kann natürlich sein, dass du das Apple TV Update dann auch haben willst.
Da ist es wieder. Ja, wahrscheinlich auch mal ein Apple TV Update machen oder so.
Wenn ich jetzt hier drauf klicke wieder auf das Apple-Dings, dann kann ich es wieder auswählen. Jetzt hat das gerade aufgegeben, oder was? Jetzt hat er zurückgeschaltet, genau. Hat eine Weile gedauert, aber dann hat er zurückgeschaltet.
Also fällt weg und jetzt sind wieder deine Fenster wieder alle auf einem und so.
Ja genau, jetzt hat das hier wieder rübergeschmissen.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt, halte ich jetzt mal, tendenziell für ein lösbares Problem. Ja gut, ich glaube, es wird so bleiben. Also das hier ist noch ein sehr junger Seelöwe, der hier umspringt.
Und dafür das Apple TV drauf, also insofern.
Das ist super, gerade als zweiter Bildschirm, das ist natürlich vor allem für Präsentationssituationen, das ist einfach top, weil dann kannst du nämlich jetzt auch diese klassische Keynote-Präsentation mit, du hast deine Notes auf deinem Laptop-Bildschirm und hinten auf dem Beamer wird irgendwas angezeigt.
Du nimmst halt jetzt einfach einen Punkt mit und drückst den Video in die Hand, wo du deinen Vortrag machst und gut bist.
Du hältst einfach keinen Vortrag, wenn da nicht ein Apple TV dran ist. Ja mal ehrlich, das wird sich in 0,0 nix aus sowas wie der Republika.
Also ich war jetzt auf so einer Art Konferenz, da gab es einen Raum mit einem Beamer, das war alles super. Aber der Beamer, da war ein VGA-Kabel dran.
Die 90er haben angerufen und wollten den Bildschirmstandard wieder.
Das geilste an diesem VGA-Kabel, weil du vorhin davon sprachst, das wäre ja vielleicht noch am ersten Industrial, wie auch immer.
Man konnte den fest schrauben, war immer scheiße, aber man konnte den fest schrauben.
Genau, da war ein Pin verbogen. Der rote.
Klassiker.
Und deswegen fehlte bei dem Beamer halt einfach die rote Farbe. Weil der war so verbogen, dass wenn du das Kabel reingesteckt hast, hat der halt keinen Kontakt gehabt. Und zwar gar keinen.
So ist das.
Hab ich dann erst mal mit ein bisschen kruder Technik wieder hingebogen und dann ging's.
Nächstes, schwergewichtiges, von Apple angepriesenes Update. Notifications. Die dann so interaktiv sind. Das heißt, ab heute wird zurückgetwittert direkt aus den Notifications. Was ich aber richtig geil finde, ist, dass sie jetzt auch diese Web-Notifications so integrieren, dass das Betriebssystem sie quasi handelt und nicht nur deine Browser ab. Das heißt, du musst deinen Browser gar nicht offen haben, kriegst aber trotzdem von Webseiten Notifications.
Da haben wir alle von geträumt.
Ich finde das ganz cool, weil du Web-Ups auf einmal ganz anders angebunden bekommst. Wenn du sowas benutzt wie Trello oder sowas, das pusht dir dann die Notifications hin.
Ich bin mir ja noch nicht sicher, ob ich das gut finde. Aber wir werden sehen, wie es in der Praxis ist.
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht schlecht.
Ich sehe gerade noch was anderes. Ich sehe mich das Wort Updates. Das haben wir natürlich bei iOS 7 ganz vergessen.
Wir haben über iOS 7 noch gar nicht gesprochen. Das gibt es noch nicht. Da sind wir noch nicht.
Genau. Und dann gibt es das Ganze auch noch im Log-Screen. Obwohl, das muss ich sagen, finde ich jetzt nicht so toll, weil der Log-Screen soll ja nun auch die Menschen einfach mal auch fernhalten von so einem Bildschirm.
Der heißt nicht umsonst Log-Screen.
Er heißt nicht Privacy-Screen, offensichtlich.
Ja, schon, aber du baust in einen Tresor ja auch kein Fenster rein, damit jeder sehen kann, was drin ist.
Man kann sich jetzt IPv6 DNS einstellen. Das ging vorher nicht, oder?
Finertubs.
Lass mich mal da einen VPN konfigurieren, während die hier Finertubs gibt.
Schon wieder.
Finertubs finde ich jetzt nicht schlecht, aber finde ich auch kein großartiges Feature.
Also weiter. Ja, ist toll. Kann man dann irgendwie Fullscroll machen.
Tags ist ganz witzig.
It's about time. Also ich meine, dass man irgendwie seine Datei nur mit Blue, Yellow, Green und Red markieren kann.
Ja, aber du kannst es da mehr als Blue und Yellow. Du kannst Blue-Yellow.
Ja, ich meine ja, das ist sozusagen ein Auslaufmodell. Es wurde Zeit, dass das mal vorbei ist. Und was ich ganz interessant finde ist...
Die heißen aber übrigens immer noch Blue, Yellow, Green und so weiter. Wenn du das Ding neu installiert hast, dann haben die Tags erstmal nur den Namen der Farbe.
Ja klar, das ist ja quasi so wie es vorher war. Weil das übernehmen sie dann sozusagen.
Aber du kannst jederzeit ein neues Tag eintippen. Also du kannst sagen, also in jedem Safe-Dialog ist auch der Tags-Dialog mit drin und du kannst halt direkt Tag eintippen.
Das finde ich nämlich in der Tat auch das tollste. Also dass sie wirklich dieses Tag nicht nur ermöglicht haben, sondern dass sie das quasi im Safe-Dialog so zu einem First Class Citizen machen. Das ist ja sozusagen genauso wie der Dateinamen. Das Einzige, was außer dem Dateinamen in diesem Standard eingeschränkten View noch zu sehen, das sind eben jetzt diese Tags.
Also für die 10 Minuten, 15 Minuten, die ich mich damit beschäftigt habe, hat es mich eigentlich gleich mal überzeugt. Man wird sehen, wie schnell das dann funktioniert und vor allen Dingen, wenn sie das irgendwie über Spotlight Metadata Search machen, ob das dann so stabil läuft wie Spotlight Metadata Search oder ob sie irgendwas anderes tun, na das weiß man nicht.
Ich meine, suchen kannst du ja jetzt auch schon danach. Also in dem Sinne ist das ja gar nichts Neues, oder?
Ja, schon. Aber es passiert immer wieder, dass einem die Spotlight-Suche kaputt geht, weil die Metadata-Datenbank kaputt geht.
Achso, ja gut, aber das ist ja dasselbe. Aber dieses Label konntest du ja auch schon vorher...
Du konntest es vorher als Label setzen. Du konntest nur nicht einer Datei zwei Labels geben. Also du kannst jetzt beliebig viele Tags an eine Datei ranhängen.
Richtig!
Und dann ist sie halt nicht nur rot, sondern auch grün und blau. Ja, das ging natürlich. Nein, was ich meine ist, wenn sie das über die Spotlight-Technologie machen, dann bist du halt wieder abhängig davon, dass dir dein Spotlight-Index nicht kaputt geht. Was halt passieren kann? Was unser einer noch in den Griff kriegt, aber Oma Müller halt eben nicht mehr.
Ja, aber wenn der Spotlight-Index dir kaputt geht, dann macht er sich den neu unter das Ruhr. Dann helfen dir aber auch die Texte. Ist ja auch nichts besser dann.
Naja, wie auch immer. Advanced Technologies steht hier noch.
Ja, das V6 haben sie immer noch nicht in Ordnung gebracht.
Also da ist... Ich hab hier mal so einen Screenshot von der Keynote. Immer wenn dieses Light kommt, wo so diese ganz vielen Worte sind, hab ich schnell einen Screenshot gemacht.
Ja, das hab ich auch gemacht. Wovon hast du jetzt konkret gerade einen gemacht?
Das mit den beiden analogen Anzeige-Instrumenten.
Ach so, mit dem Power und Performance.
Ja, genau. Ja, es kommt noch, aber es gibt nicht diese Light-Instrumenten.
Interessant ist, dass sie sich überhaupt so wo ist denn Server noch äußern?
Server ist insofern interessant, dass dieses da Continuous Integration Testing, Repository Hosting Services, da ist ihn mal aufgegangen. Hallo, da gibt's noch Leute, die Apps entwickeln. Und Xcode läuft aber nur auf einem Mac, da könnten wir doch mal was ordentliches bauen. Statt dass sich jeder seinen Jenkins zusammenklickt, was ewig dauert und beim nächsten Update ist immer Zittern angesagt. Und was weiß ich, jeder sich seinen Git-Server irgendwie zusammen bastelt, also ich weiß auch nicht. Was genau jetzt dieser Server dann kann mit den Developer Tools, das weiß ich nicht genau.
Eine Frage kam, ist das auch Bestandteil des Beta-Programms? Kann man sich den Server auch unterladen?
Normalerweise ja. Normalerweise ja. Ich glaube, ich hab's auch gesehen. Also runterladen funktioniert ja, aber in dem Beta-Programm inzwischen so, du lockst dich ein, klickst auf den Button und kriegst einen Code. Und dann kriegst du auf Redeem-Code und dann geht dein App-Store-Ding ins Auf und sagt, ich leite jetzt mal runter. Und für den Server kriegst du halt noch mal so einen Code. Ja, runterladen.
Ich hab bei Kunden so ein Ding im Einsatz, so ein OSX-Server, recht beliebt auch. Und da kann man mal gucken, was da kommt.
Also inzwischen ist der Server ja nur noch ein Add-on.
Ja, aber trotzdem werden da auch noch ein paar Fummeln oder so. Das ist ein Thema, das mich mal interessiert. Gucken wir mal hier an, wenn es sich irgendwie mal ergibt. Mal reinschauen, was sie da gemacht haben.
Du hast dir die Advanced Technologies draufgeklickt, oder?
Ja, ich bin so ein Typ.
Timer-Core-Lasting. Das ist ganz interessant. Der gibt es unter Coco. Kannst du jetzt zu einem Timer sagen, wie genau er denn sein soll? Also der Timer, der ja vorher so genau feuert, wie du ihm halt gesagt hast, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich will zwei Sekunden.
Vielleicht soll man mal kurz erläutern, was man unter Timer, also ich verstehe das, aber...
Was man unter Timer versteht.
Ich glaube, das ist mal so ein Konzept, das kann man mal erklären.
Oh ja, wie sage ich denn das?
Wie sage ich es dem Kinde?
Also Timer ist, ich sage meinem Betriebssystem, gib mir mal Bescheid in so und so viele Millimikro-Nanosekunden, je nachdem, wie genau der Timer ist, bzw. gib mir mal genau dann und dann Bescheid. Also unter Coco kannst du sowohl ein Endestate, was halt ein Zustand, also ein Timestamp ist quasi, kannst du sagen, dann will ich bitte schön den Timer haben. Oder du kannst halt sagen, ich will den in so und so vier Sekunden.
Also du willst nicht einen Timer haben, sondern du timest einen Interrupt. Du sagst, weck mich auf, sag Bescheid.
Ja, Interrupt, ein Event. Ein Event.
Wir folgen nämlich so da aus, wenn die Zeit rum ist.
Weck mich auf.
Genau, genau.
Ruf diese Funktion auf, wenn der Timer feuert, abgelaufen ist. Und tue das entweder regelmäßig oder tue das nur einmal. Also das ist das, was du sagen kannst. Und unter Coco kannst du jetzt unter 10.9 sagen, dieser Timer soll die und die Genauigkeit haben. Ich kann ja sagen, in einer halben Stunde plus minus drei Minuten ist mir egal. Und dann kann der halt dieses, was da unter Timer Coalescing steht, der kann halt dann sagen, ich räume jetzt alle Timer zusammen, die mir gesagt haben, ich will es jetzt nicht hypergenau haben und feuer alle zusammen, damit der Prozessor halt nur einmal aus dem Idle-Modus aufweckt.
Aber jetzt Programmer, die jetzt bisher nur für Linen, Mountain-Line, was auch immer, für Katzen programmiert wurden. Die für die Katze. In welchem Maße kann dieses Timer Coalescing da jetzt schon greifen und zusammenfassen? Hast du da was zu gefunden?
Klarer Antwort, ich weiß es nicht.
Bei Ars Technica gab es einen Artikel darüber. Und die meinten, dass Apple schon immer gesagt hat, dass wenn man die Timer benutzt, dass die halt bis zu so nur bis zu einer gewissen Genauigkeit irgendwie arbeiten. Zehntausendstel Sekunden oder irgendwie so. Und ab da wird es ein bisschen ungenauer. Und dass sie jetzt dieses Ungenauer noch ein bisschen erhöhen mit Fee-Line oder Mavericks.
In dem Maße sozusagen dann Anpassungen vornehmen.
Du kannst halt jetzt als Developer noch mal explizit sagen, der Timer ist nicht so wichtig. Mir egal.
Vor allem, wenn du so einmal pro Sekunde was machst, ist dir auch wirklich Schnurz egal.
Ich kann dich ja auch fast gar nicht mehr ansagen, weil eine Sekunde, dann ist Apple glaube ich auch egal, wenn du nur einmal pro Sekunde machst.
Vor allem die 32 Mal in der Zeit.
Ist aber gut, wenn sie dann den mit irgendwas anderem zusammenlegen, dass gerade für sowas Sinnloses dann nicht unbedingt nochmal extra aufgeweckt werden muss.
Das macht übrigens aber alles nur dann Sinn, wenn deine Applikation zwischendurch nichts tut. Wenn sie jetzt sagt, ich hab jetzt eh nichts zu tun, weck mich mal in 30 Sekunden. Wenn du nicht schläfst, sondern anderen Quack machst, dann ist das albern.
Eigentlich alle Apps haben halt eine sogenannte Event Loop. Also was da ist, in der App läuft so eine Art Schleife, die wartet immer darauf, dass irgendwo ein Event herkommt. Der Event kann halt ein Mausklick sein, ein Mausmove, das kann ein Tastendruck sein, das kann sein, der User hat das Fenster geschlossen oder eben ein Timer. So lange kein Event kommt, tun die meisten Applikationen halt nicht, es sei denn sie rechnen im Hintergrund was oder laden was aus dem Netz, aber auch da kriegst du halt ein Event dafür, wie ich hab jetzt Daten oder so.
Daten sind da, Platte hat geantwortet.
Genau, und insofern ist das schon sinnvoll. Also ich meine, dieses Timer Coalescing kann halt auch heißen, der Netzwerkstack, der wartet halt für mehrere Programme noch ein bisschen, bis sich was angesammelt hat und sagt dann allen Programmen gleichzeitig da Zeitbescheid. Übrigens, ich hab hier mal Daten.
Ja, wie gesagt, wenn er zwischendurch halt Zeit hat zum Schlafen, wenn der Netzwerkstack natürlich im Hintergrund läuft, der braucht ja auch eine CPU. Also da muss ja auch irgendwas tun. Aber du hast schon recht, für diese ganzen Event Loops, die jetzt auf ein User-Event warten oder so was, oder gerade eben, die haben ja dann meistens einen Timer drin, weil sie irgendeinen Icon updaten müssen oder einen Ball, der sich dreht oder was weiß ich sonst. Da macht es natürlich dann auch irgendwie Spaß, dann zu sagen, die feuert man alle zusammen, dass sozusagen das System zwischendurch immer mal richtig tief schlafen gehen kann. Und wenn das dann aufwacht, naja, dann kann das auch gleich mehrere Prozesse in einer Tour abfrühstücken.
Ja, also meiner Erfahrung nach benutzt man diese Timer aktiv ja wirklich nur dann, wenn du irgendwie so ein Polling machst. Also das klingt jetzt blöd, wenn ich das so sage, aber wenn du halt irgendwo guckst, ob sich irgendwas geändert hat, irgendwelche Netrequests losschickst, date mir mal meine Daten alle 30 Sekunden ab oder so, dann benutze ich einen Timer.
Sonst benutzt du den eigentlich nicht. Achso, in welcher Timer benutzt du?
Nicht wirklich, was man manchmal...
Ich hab ja hier mein Programm, was diesen Motor steuert. Und der Motorcontroller ist ja per USB angebunden. Und ich will ja den Stand des Motors haben, weil ich schicke irgendwie den Kommando und dann will ich ja wissen, wo sich der Motor gerade befindet. Und da feuer ich, glaube ich, ich mache 25 Updates die Sekunde, also...
40 Millisekunden. Das könnte jetzt sein, dass du ein bisschen ein anderes Verhalten kriegst, ne?
Nee, ich glaube, das korrigieren ist noch im viel kleineren Bereich.
Oder sagst du halt eben zukünftig an, dass du es so genau haben willst?
Nee, das ist ja mir, also 40 Millisekunden, ob das jetzt 45 sind, 45 sind mir total Schnurz. Und ich glaube, das... Ich kann es ja dann mal ausprobieren, wenn ich das dann demnächst mal code dafür und dann diesen neuen Coil benutze, kann ich ja mal sagen, ey Jungs, mir sind plus minus 20 Millisekunden und ich denke, das ruckelt trotzdem nicht. Ich kann es halt so lange treiben, bis es halt ruckelt.
Kannst du dann mal nachmessen, wieviel du tatsächlich bekommen hast, wenn du dir die letzte Zeit auch merkst?
An Differenz meinst du? Ich weiß nicht, ob die da auch die Bugging-Future haben, wo man sagen kann, ok, jetzt gib mir mal das maximal Schlimmste, was du mich sozusagen wegkorrigieren würdest, damit ich mal sehe, was am schlimmsten Fall sein könnte.
Nee, du kannst ja einfach die Zeit merken.
Ja, aber ich weiß ja nicht, ob das System gerade maximal mich beeinflusst. Kann ja sein, dass gerade eh nichts los ist.
Nein, aber wenn du sagst, weg mich in 20 Millisekunden plus minus 7. Und du merkst dir die Zeit, quasi. Und dann, wenn du ja den Event bekommst, dann schaust du nochmal auf die Zeit. Wie viel wirklich jetzt von diesen 20 Millisekunden abgewichen wurde.
Das sag ich halt, da weiß ich nicht, ob das System gerade überhaupt diese Abweichen ausnutzt. Vielleicht brauchst du das System das ja gar nicht und gib mir meine perfekte Zeit.
Tim möchte gerne, dass du in deiner zukünftigen Update den Jitter misst.
Ja, das ist schon klar, aber ich will ja nicht nur messen, sondern ich will ja auch mal den Worst Case sehen und da gibt's vielleicht einen Debug-Flag, wo man sagen kann, gib mir mal was wir im schlimmsten Fall kriegen würden.
Ich find überhaupt diesen Fokus jetzt in diesem Update, dass sie sagen, we care about energy und wir versuchen jetzt mal hier alles unter die Lupe zu nehmen, was Energie verbraucht. Und dass du jetzt auch im Activity-Monitor sehen kannst, wie viel Energie verbraucht dein Programm. Gar nicht mal nur wie viel CPU, sondern wirklich, was ist tatsächlich die Last, die durch was auch immer deine abtut, gerade von den... Bei Android gibt's das ja auch glaube ich schon ganz lange, wie viel Batterieverbrauch die einzelnen Programme haben. Und ich frage mich natürlich auch, woher sie das eigentlich immer so genau wissen. Weil das ja alles auch sehr sekundär sein kann.
Du rechnest doch einfach, wie viel CPU-Zeit du kriegst.
Das ist ja nicht nur die CPU, ist ja auch die GPU.
Ja, alles mögliche, das kannst du ja machen. Was ich eher spannend finde an der Sache ist, dass sie das zu einem Thema gemacht haben, einer Keynote. Dass sie in einem derartigen Detail-Level in einer Keynote auf solche Kernel-Verbesserungen eingegangen sind, wo die meisten dieser Otto-Normal-User, okay, war jetzt auch eine Developer-Konferenz, muss man sagen, aber die ganzen Normal-User, die alle zu Hause saßen und dachten sich so, what the fuck, wie Timer, wie Kernel, wie Compression.
Sicher nicht ein Otto-Normal-User.
Ja, aber ich fand es trotzdem interessant, dass sie das in der Ich glaube, wir haben in der Kino in einem derartigen Detail-Level da so Körnelsachen diskutiert haben.
War das jetzt das erste Mal, dass ihr solche Technologien im Detail vorgestellt habt?
Es ist insofern interessant, weil, also wir können ja mal weiter runterscrollen, es gibt da ja noch App-Nap. Auch das hat Auswirkungen auf die API und auch da gibt es in Coco gewisse Events und Sachen, die du selber abfragen kannst, wo du dann auch Events bekommst, dass deine App jetzt in den Nap geht und so weiter. Also das ist insofern interessant, als dass es für die Developer wirklich wichtig ist, dass mit dem Timer Coalescing, das funktioniert natürlich umso besser, je eher ich das unterstütze als Developer, genauso wie dieses App-Nap. Also ich glaube, dass das so out of the box, so viel wie sie da versprechen, nur so mäßig funktioniert, dass du da als Developer eigentlich auch so sein möchtest, wie ach, mein Fenster ist jetzt nicht mehr zu sehen. Dieser View, der braucht jetzt auch nichts mehr zu tun und die Animation, die ist jetzt auch für die Katze.
Aber mal eine provokante Frage. Noch aus meinen Zeiten, als ich mal so X-Programme geschrieben habe damals, da wusste ich schon, ob mein Fenster gerade sichtbar ist oder nicht. Gibt's das nicht bei Coco?
Na bei OSX sind ja alle...
Als ab nicht mein Fenster gerade irgendwie vorne ist.
Bei OSX ist es so, dass der Fenstermanager jedes Fenster quasi auf eine OpenGL-Bitmap legt und deswegen nicht mehr so ganz klar ist, ist die jetzt sichtbar oder nicht.
Sie bauen das jetzt quasi wieder ein. Früher war das ja so, dass du das eben machen musstest, weil ja den Programm dann in dem Moment, wo das Fenster wieder sichtbar war, die Programme ja den ganzen Inhalt wieder neu aufbauen müssen. Und heutzutage ist alles double buffert. Da renderst du alles so, als wärst du immer sichtbar. Und ob du dann wirklich zu sehen bist, das ergibt sich letztlich aus der Position der Fenster und ist eine Frage der GPU. Die Ressourcen sind dann halt trotzdem weg, aber das hat ja zahlreiche Vorteile. Fenster verschieben und so weiter. Inhalt ist sofort da. Dieses ganze Redraw, das war ja schon immer eigentlich totaler Quatsch. Nur, dass man eben jetzt nicht so diese Optimierung drin hatte mit tun nichts. So, weil du bist ja eh grad nicht zu sehen.
Also, das was du beschreibst existiert auf View-Ebene. Solang du keine Layer benutzt, da ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Also es existiert noch auf View-Ebene. Ein View, der hinter einem anderen View ist, der wird nicht redrawt, weil man ihn nicht sieht. Aber ein Fenster ist quasi immer sichtbar. Und wird immer redrawt und refreshed. Und das haben sie jetzt quasi abgeschaltet.
Oder sie sagen jetzt Bescheid, wenn es nicht mehr so ist.
Und wann kann eine App in ein App gehen? Also wann müssen die Apps jetzt das...
Wenn das Fenster komplett verdeckt ist.
Ja, aber du willst ja jetzt nicht eine bestehende App, die von AppnApp noch nie was gehört haben, dass wenn die mal verdeckt ist oder gehind ist, dass sie dann sofort ausgeht. Das will ich ja unter Umständen gar nicht. Die tut ja unter Umständen was Sinnvolles. Wenn sie ja nicht Handbrake in den Hintergrund legen und dann holst du sie nach zwei Tagen wieder vor und dann macht er endlich mal wieder weiter mit den DVDs. Das ist ja nun wirklich Quatsch oder iTunes.
So genau hab ich es mir noch nicht angeguckt. Da gibt es zwei Dinge. Das erste ist, wenn du nicht gegen das C9 SDK gebaut hast, dann sowieso nicht, dann passiert da wahrscheinlich eh nicht so viel. Und das zweite ist, dieses ganze AppnApp Zeug bezieht sich, glaube ich, vor allen Dingen auf die ganzen Views. Also alles, was du im User-Interface machst, und das wird alles schlafengelegt quasi. Also solange das Fenster nach hinten ist, kriegst du ja auch keine Mouse-Over mehr, du kriegst auch keine Mouse-Klicks, auch keine Tasten und nichts mehr. Also die Event-Loop der ganzen App wird wahrscheinlich komplett abgeschaltet, es sei denn du hast, wir hatten es ja vorhin schon, Timer oder Netzwerk oder so. Das ist glaube ich das, was in dem App da mit reinspielt. Aber das müsste ich mir nochmal genau angucken, wie das jetzt funktioniert. Hab ich nur mal so überflogen.
Das wird aber auch schon ein großer Teil sein, warum die MacBooks erst so lange Batterielaufzeiten haben.
Ach, sie haben jetzt Click-to-Flash eingebaut? Das haben sie ja gar nicht erwähnt. Das ist ja geil. Du hast sozusagen jetzt schon mal einen Build-In für einen Adblocker?
Ja, jetzt wissen wir warum die Dinge 12 Stunden halten plötzlich.
Na ja gut, aber du kannst die MacBooks erst ja gleich kaufen. Und das gibt es ja auch erst im Herbst. Das gute Mavericks.
Sie haben ja Flash sozusagen. Aber das ist natürlich eine klare Ansage gegen Plugins generell. Weil das wird sie ja sicherlich nicht nur auf Flash hier beziehen. Ich glaube, das ist auch eh bald vorbei mit den ganzen Plugins. Sobald es irgendwie geht.
Also sie werden sicherlich auch so etwas wie Plugin-Nap haben oder so. Oder wenn ein Tab nicht vorne ist, dann wird halt alles stillgelegt. Ich weiß nicht, wie das mit den Plugins ist.
Wer spielt denn bitte HD mit iTunes ab? Okay, die Leute, die sich Filme ausleihen und so. Aber sonst?
Gut, weiter.
Ja, ist irgendwie besser, ist toller. Super, aber das finde ich jetzt nochmal ein geiles Feature.
Compressed Memory.
Genau. Ich habe mir das auch mal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut, worauf das eigentlich basiert. Da gibt es nämlich so ein Paper.
Von vor zehn Jahren.
Ich bin mir gar nicht ganz so sicher.
Mich wundert es ein bisschen, dass sie jetzt erst drauf gekommen sind.
Macht das irgendjemand anders? Also gibt es einen Linux-Körner, wo das drin ist?
Bei Linux gibt es auch sowas. Da gibt es den LZ4-Kompressor, den sie auch hier erst benutzen, und den benutzen sie, glaube ich, auch. Bei Linux gibt es irgendwas, um irgendwie einen Swap wegzupacken und so.
Dass man Sachen komprimiert, bevor man sie auf eine lahme Platte schleibt, ist jetzt sozusagen kein neuer Hit. Aber innerhalb des RAMs, sich die Dinge wegzupacken, ist so simpel, dass es schon fast wieder genial ist. Als ich sie gesehen habe, habe ich gedacht, ja, scheiß, warum sind wir da nicht eher drauf gekommen? Weil es wirklich sehr simpel ist.
Das macht ihr bei Linux auch schon, ne?
Ich hab mir mal das Paper Swap durchgelesen.
Also die Memory-Pages?
Schmeißt mal einen Link in die.
Lass mal Tim erzählen, ich glaube, der weiß da schon mehr.
Das Einzige, was ich nicht rausfinde, ist, von wann dieses Paper ist, weil irgendwie in diesem Paper kein Datum drin steht.
Also ich hab was von, dass es von 2003 schon wäre, stand irgendwo. Ich glaube auch Ars Technica.
Das kann gut sein, aber in diesem Paper wird davon geredet, dass noch kein Betriebssystem das tut. Ich kann jetzt sozusagen nicht genau sagen.
Aber wenn es von 2003 ist, ist doch kein Wunder.
Genau. Und zwar heißt es, ich weiß nicht, ob es das einzige Paper ist, das nicht, glaube ich, das Paper, was jetzt konkret den Algorithmus im Detail beschreibt, aber quasi so eine Studie ist zu dem Thema. The Case for Compressed Caching in Virtual Memory Systems. Und das ist halt von Wilson Kaplan. Das ist halt das W und das K aus diesem Algorithmus. WKDM heißt der Algorithmus, den Apple da verwendet. Der halt hier getestet wird, zusammen mit so diversen anderen bekannten Lempel-Zev-Sachen. Und sie machen da halt so verschiedene Aufstellungen darüber, wie effizient dieser ganze Klimpim denn jetzt letzten Endes ist. Und weisen dann quasi hier in ihrer Studie nach, dass ihr Algorithmus da eigentlich in allen Fällen der effizienteste ist oder zumindest genauso effizient ist, wie die anderen auch.
Okay, von 2003 kann es nicht sein, weil ich glaube, da gab es noch gar kein LZO, oder?
Wie gesagt, hier steht einfach kein Datum drin.
Hier steht was von Spark, also...
Spark gibt es schon seit Ewigkeiten.
Gibt es Spark noch?
Wie auch immer, sie können da wohl immer 50%... Also ich hab mir den Algorithmus kurz angeschaut, das ist ganz wenig Code, der arbeitet halt mit so einem Dictionary, also mit so einer Table quasi, und arbeitet wohl recht schnell und kann wohl in der Regel 50% Kompression erzielen.
Aber das ist einfach ein Kompressor, oder was ist das?
Das ist einfach ein Speicherkompressor, das ist einfach ein Datenkompressor und Kompressionsalgorithmus, so wie man ihn für Falls auch verwendet, der aber eben die besondere Eigenschaft hat, sehr, sehr, sehr schnell zu sein. Und diese Studie sagt im Prinzip aus, dass diese Kompression von RAM immer interessanter geworden ist durch die Zunahme der Geschwindigkeit der CPUs. Und dass jetzt seit Längerem schon der Punkt erreicht ist, wo du einfach sehr viel mehr Benefit davon hast, diese Kompression im RAM anzuwenden, als es nicht zu tun mit eben diesen neuen Algorithmen. Und genau das haben sie jetzt in C9 eingebaut. Das heißt, du hast ja immer den RAM, der gerade in Benutzung ist, und dann hast du den RAM, der, ich weiß gar nicht, wodurch das festgestellt wird, in Active Memory, wodurch, was definiert Memory als in Active? Dass da seit Längerem nicht mehr drauf zugegriffen wurde, ist das einfach die Page-Activity.
Ich fange mit dem Prozess auch zu tun, in dem die Page gehört und so.
Genau, aber wenn einfach ein Prozess auf bestimmte Speicherbereiche nicht zugreift, dann weiß, glaube ich, die MMU, dass...
Sie weiß auch, wann sie den ins Virtual Memory auf die Platte auslagern kann, dann weiß sie auch, wann er komprimieren kann.
Genau, es gibt da irgendwie so ein Alter. Und in dem Moment, wo sie jetzt, also angenommen, du hast jetzt viele Programme gestartet, der gesamte Free-Memory ist zugeteilt an Programme. Es mag aber dann gut sein, dass zwei Drittel inactive ist. Also wenn man so ein Aktivitätsmonitor mal anschaltet und sich da RAM-Verbrauch anzeigen lässt, dann wird das ja entsprechend aufgeschlüsselt. Können wir mal gerade gucken...
Du siehst doch bei der Prozessgeschichte, siehst jetzt schon die Real Memory, da kannst du bestimmt noch eine Spalte Virtual Memory mit dazu anklicken. Ding Ding. Contact Click in die Leiste.
In die Headline.
Es gibt da Real Memory, Real Private Memory, Real Shared Memory und Virtual Private Memory.
Real Shared ist auch noch spannend, aber okay. Virtual Memory, das ist sozusagen der Gesamtprozess-Size. Siehst du jetzt bei deinem Prozess da oben, Safari Web Content hat halt eben Virtual Memory 1,43 Gigabyte, davon eben 1,28. Echt in echt, ja, der Rest gammelt irgendwo rum.
Ja, also hier bei meinem Chatclient zum Beispiel, 560 MB, wozu braucht der 560 MB?
Genau, frage ich mich auch immer wieder, jedes Mal mit diesen Tabellesee.
Das sind die ganzen Libraries, die mit reinkommen.
Ja, dann mach mal bitte Shared mit an. Dann gucken wir gleich mal, wie viel davon in der Library steckt und wie viel die davon einfach gewastet haben.
Weil die Libraries werden natürlich geshared.
Real Shared Memory.
So, von den 500 sind, wie viel geshared? 50.
Noch nicht so viel.
Was macht bitte ein Chat klein mit einem halben G-Ram?
Wasten.
Übrigens nur so nebenbei. Das kann durchaus sein, dass bei solchen Dingern der Kompressor wahnsinnig zuschlägt. Weil wenn du halt so ein Spacken-Programmierer bist, der sagt, Maloc, ich weiß nicht, die Koka-Programmierer dürfen eh keinen Maloc benutzen. Ihr machtet anders. Ich denke immer noch, so ein altes C-Termini. Und es gibt halt viele Leute, die trauen den Maloc nicht oder haben da keinen Bock drauf. Das heißt, die machen erst mal, wenn sie starten, machen sie erst mal ein riesengroßes Maloc und verwalten dann selber, was da drin ist. Das heißt, da sind dann auch sehr viele Nullen drin. Und da kann natürlich so ein Kompressor echt Spaß mit haben, mit solchen Seiten.
Ja, und dann gibt es die Leute, die machen das, legen sich den riesen Speicherbereich an, lesen einmal komplett durch, damit es auch alles schön im Speicher ist. Ich will nicht das, was ich letztes Mal hatte.
Ich will kein Salty Caramel, das kann ich dir schon mal sagen.
Ja, ich auch nicht, aber ich hatte das letztes Mal schon. Deswegen, ah, gib mir die Cookies & Cream. Es gibt jetzt irgendwas. Es gibt jetzt Eis.
Ich hab einfach mal Mund auf Feier des Tages. Bei diesem Rechner passiert mir das mit Memory-Fall eh nicht. Aber auf meinem R ist das, sagen wir mal, eine tägliche Begebenheit. Und auch auf so einem alten iMac, da ist der Speicher halt einfach mal voll. Und dann wird eigentlich geswapt. Und das ist dann genau der Moment, wo Computer wirklich richtig langsam werden. Also, wenn der Bereich Swap nicht sagt. Also, Speicher muss hergestellt werden, weil Programme, welche nachfragen, theoretisch ist aber alles vergeben. Und dann wird eben das, was am inaktivsten ist, auf die Platte geschrieben.
Ich hab übrigens noch eine Idee, warum sie das machen.
Wer was macht.
Warum Apple das macht.
Die Kompression.
Da weil sie nur 8 GB in den R's haben.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen, weil sie da Flash-Laufwerke drin haben. Und du mit dem Virtual Memory natürlich den Flash am schnellsten ausblühst. Mit den Schreib-Lese-Zyklen.
Das ist sicherlich nicht der einzige Grund. Nebeneffekt ist ja übrigens auch, dass die Swap-Files kleiner werden. Weil die sind ja teilweise ganz schön enorm. Also wenn man mal nach die Kommandozeile marschiert und einem lange rechnenden Rechner mal in slash var vm nachschaut, kann mir das eigentlich mal einer erklären, warum da eigentlich immer so unheimlich viel Zeug rumliegt. Also ich hab jetzt hier gerade 8,6 GB Swap-Files.
Ja, wie viel RAM hast du?
Manchmal hab ich mehr.
Wie viel RAM hast du in deinem R? Du hast in deinem R 8 drin?
Ne, 4.
Ich hab da 6 Swap-Files und ein Sleep-Image.
Der Sleep-Image ist normalerweise so groß wie dein RAM. Wie groß ist dein Sleep-Image?
Warte mal, jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt. Wieso hab ich 4 GB in meinem R?
Ist das gewachsen über Nacht?
Ich dachte ich hätte 8. Du hast gerade gesagt, dass der tolle R jetzt 8 kann. Ist das jetzt das erste R mit 8? Ich hab so ein alteres...
Haben sie dir nicht ein neues Display gegeben? Vielleicht ist da auch noch was anderes neu.
Ich bin irgendwie in einer irrigen Annahme.
Aber dein Sleep-Image ist genauso groß wie dein RAM, ne? Genau. Da donnerst du nämlich einfach alle drei, bevor er stirbt.
Genau. Und der Rest sind Swapfiles. Das ist sozusagen nochmal dasselbe.
Ja, die entstehen und verschwinden auch mittelfristig mal wieder.
Ja, aber mit diesem Verschwinden, das funktioniert nicht so gut. Also ich hatte da schon ganz andere Größenordnungen.
Er weiß, wenn das zu fragmentiert ist, dann kann er sie vielleicht nicht mehr wegmachen.
Ja, aber wieso hab ich auf einem Mac Pro Swapfiles?
Also wieso hab ich auf diesem Mac Pro Swapfiles?
Weil Swap hast du immer.
Swap hast du immer, weil er wirklich lange nicht benutzt und Speicher immer rausswoppt. Egal, ob du jetzt noch was frei hast oder nicht. Warum, weiß ich nicht, aber er tut das.
Und es ist durchaus so, dass...
Das sichert dir aber die Performance, weißt du? Wenn du sagst, nehmen wir mal an, du hast 8 Gig, und du hast jetzt irgendwie Speicher für 16 Gig verbraucht. Ne, nehmen wir an, du hast 8 Gig, und deine Programme verbrauchen etwa 7 Gig. So, und da ist jetzt ein Programm dabei, das tut gar nichts mehr, hat aber 3 von den Gig. Und das Betriebssystem ist in der Lage, 2 davon wegzutun, dann hast du plötzlich wieder 3 frei. Und irgendein Programm, was jetzt ganz schnell ganz viel Speicher braucht, kann den haben, ohne dass das Zeug erst ausgelagert werden muss.
So ein präventives Rauszwoppen.
Richtig. Also es kann Sinn machen.
Ja, aber schau mal, dieser Computer hier hat gerade 23 Gigabyte RAM frei. Laut Activity Monitor ein 1,7 Gigabyte Swap-Use. Und laut meiner Auskunft von dem VAR-VM-Directory sind hier 3,2 Gigabyte.
Ja, die lümmeln, der 1,7 lümmelt da drin rum.
Swap-File.
Der macht nicht die Files sound immer größer, weil gerade bei seinem scheiß HFS-Plus-Filesystem macht das auch keinen Spaß. Achso, ja klar. Es gibt auch sogenannte Sparse-Files.
Ja, aber wie kann ich feststellen, wie viel hier von real belegt wird?
Da gibt es bestimmt VM-Stadt. Guck mal, VM-Stadt gibt es, oder mal, gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Man fühlt sich auf jeden Fall immer latent beschissen mit diesem ganzen Subsystem.
Vor allem unter Strich Stadt.
Auf jeden Fall mit der Kompression wird tatsächlich, wenn die Swap-Files auch kleiner, weil sie nur noch die komprimierten Varianten rausschreiben. Das ist schon mal die Hälfte. Ich meine, wenn ihr jetzt hier auf so einem R mal eben, was hatte ich hier gerade, 9 Gigabyte, auch dieses Sleep Image könnten sie ja im Prinzip komprimieren.
Das Problem ist folgend, du musst dir das vorhalten in deinem Fallsystem, weil du weißt ja nicht, wie gut du komprimieren kannst, weil du ja nicht vorhersagen kannst zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du das brauchst, wie gut du es komprimieren kannst. Und das ist dann blöd, wenn du sozusagen sagst, ich hab ja Platz auf der Platte. Genau, und dann mittendrin, wenn du jetzt mal absichern willst, dass dein Fallsystem sagt, nö.
Da ist doch dann genau dieses Sparse-Files.
Damit stirbt eben gerade meine Sparse-File-Theorie. Weil du möchtest gerne mal in einem Prozess mal dazu gesagt hat, dass er so viel Memory haben kann, dann solltest du das auch zur Hand haben. Selbst wenn du das gerade nicht brauchst. Das ist sonst richtig böse. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es bei OSX ist, aber bei Solaris, ich hab ja früher sehr viel auf Solaris machen müssen, erwartet so, dass du sozusagen den Swap, du musst den Plattenplatz haben, um den Swap-Bereich angeben zu können. Sonst hast du so viel Swap gar nicht konfigurieren können. Und manche Software, die letzten, manche Java-Sachen, die lassen sich zum Beispiel in Janik starten, weil sie nicht sagen, ich kann gar nicht so viel Zeug alle zieln. Egal, ob sie das später nutzen oder nicht. Also das war immer so eine Pest, dass du sozusagen, wenn du Swap-Space erst mal sagtest, ich hab den, dann musst du den noch garantieren können, das heißt, der wird dann auch belegt auf der Platte. Deswegen, wie gesagt, leider, da fällt ja die Nummer mit den Spars-Files, da ist wahrscheinlich echt Trommel drin. Aber die lassen sich gut komprimieren. Also die Komprimierungsnummer ist insgesamt eine gute Idee, weil die CPU wartet eh sonst. Bei dem alten System musst du darauf warten, dass endlich die Scheiß-Platte aus dem Kniff kommt, und dass man den ganzen Quack da hinschreiben kann. Jetzt kann sie in der Zwischenzeit natürlich auch noch schön komprimieren.
Der Witz ist, dass wenn du eine Festplatte hast, dann ist das wahrscheinlich komprimieren und speichern immer noch schneller als direkt speichern, weil die Platte ist nur mal das Langsamste. Und wenn die weniger speichern muss, also deswegen hat ja ZFS auch Compression, weil es dann dadurch schneller wird. Es geht ja nicht um Platz sparen, sondern es geht um EOS sparen.
Selbst eine SSD, also die modernen CPUs können das immer noch schneller komprimieren, als die schnellste SSD, die das wegschreiben kann.
Was meinen wir jetzt zu Mavericks?
Also das, was ich gesehen hab, ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass sie irgendwas kaputt gemacht haben. Also die große Gefahr, dass da jetzt der Blood Bear antanzt und irgendwelche Sachen nicht mehr benutzbar sind, die hab ich jetzt nicht mehr. Also ich hab das Gefühl, das kann ein rundes Release werden. Auch wenn es jetzt nicht so viele super neue Features sind, aber das wird glaube ich ganz gut.
Aber sie haben einfach viele Lücken geschlossen.
Ja.
Das ist wirklich eine sehr umfangreiche Lückenschließung.
Also mein Ziel ist sozusagen eine neue Snow Lappart.
Naja, ja in etwa schon. Ich frag mich allerdings sehr, wie das Adressbuch aussieht. Das war nirgendwo zu sehen. Das hast du da vielleicht schon vor deiner Nase?
Ja, aber das sieht nicht viel anders aus.
Ohne Kühe und Windfahnen.
Da ist wahrscheinlich das Leder noch drin, deswegen wollten sie es nicht zeigen, weil es nur noch wegkommt.
Das sah nicht groß anders. Es sah so ein bisschen OS7-nigra aus, aber im Großen und Ganzen, okay, es sieht... Das Leder ist weg, sieht eigentlich so aus, wie vor dem Leder.
Wir haben einfach die alte Version genommen, hat sich eh nichts geändert, oder? Wir haben einfach einen Rollback im Git gemacht und fertig.
Ja, der Einwand, die komische Papierbindung in der Mitte ist weg. Und die Seiten...
Was sollen sie auf der Keynote damit zeigen? We ran out of green carpet oder so, aber ich meine... Der Kalender sieht so ähnlich aus.
Der scheiß Kalender scrollt mal genauso, wie ich das immer wollte.
Ja, kannst du mal sehen.
Ja, ich bin jetzt zufrieden.
Halt! Unterzeugen! Läuft die Aufnahme? Haben die schonest das mitgeschrieben? Say it again!
Ich bin zufrieden. Ich rannte ja gern, aber wenn es dann okay ist, ist es auch okay.
Tim ist einfach nur leer, spielt von 3 Stunden NSFW.
Geht in Ordnung, sag ich mal, das Release.
Tim Pritlev abruft.
Es könnte jetzt dann auch mal kommen. Aber... Vor Storage-mäßig hat sich meiner Auffassung nach nüscht getan.
Hab ich auch nichts gehört.
Fallsystem ist einfach immer noch Borkon.
Und das muss angeprangert werden.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die schrauben am ZFS, aber das ist mal wann anders. Nicht noch eine Themenbaustelle aufmachen hier. So. Noch was ist mir noch aufgefallen. Ja. Video ist jetzt aus Messages raus.
Wie?
Haben sie gesagt. Aus?
Diese iChat-Geschichte, diese coole?
Es gibt jetzt die Facetime ab. Schon länger für macOS. Und sie haben Video jetzt wohl komplett rausgenommen. Also Multi-User-Video ging ja schon unter 10.8 nicht mehr. Ja, es geht nur dann, wenn du einen eigenen Jabber-Account hast. Dann machen sie es über Jabber. Aber das ist jetzt irgendwie raus.
Es gibt gar kein Video mehr in der Messages ab.
Nee, gibt's nur noch als Facetime. Vielleicht deswegen, ja.
Facetime funktioniert auch nicht immer.
Eigentlich schon ziemlich cool.
Es kommt einfach nicht immer durch die Nuts durch.
Also ich hab hier, ich hab mir das hier nochmal aufgeschrieben. Also man kann einen Occlusion-State einer Applikation abfangen und man bekommt eine Message, wenn sich der Occlusion-State geändert hat. Soviel zum Thema App-Nap.
Wie, man wird nochmal, es wird Bescheid gesagt, dass man gleich runtergefahren wird?
Ja, dir wird Bescheid gesagt, dass deine App jetzt nicht mehr zu sehen ist. Beziehungsweise, dass sie jetzt wieder zu sehen ist. Wenn du jetzt irgendeinen fancy Schwiegelschwaggel machst und der Occlusion-State ändert sich auf Fully Occluded oder was auch immer der dann ist, dann kannst du sagen, lass mal gut sein Leute, zieht eh keiner.
Also ich hab jetzt immer noch nicht verstanden. Muss man sich dagegen wehren runtergefahren zu werden oder muss man explizit sagen, dass man das jetzt erlaubt und man kriegt es dann auch nochmal mit und könnte das dann auch nochmal verhindern?
Wahrscheinlich eine Mischung, aber das kann ich dir nicht genau sagen.
Ja, kann das Sinn machen oder haben?
Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie sowas wie Netzwerkzugriffe einfach nur dadurch abbremsen, dass du nicht mehr zu sehen bist. Das wäre auch sinnlos.
Ja, ich meine, dann würde ein Webserver nicht mehr funktionieren.
Sondern ich denke, es geht vor allen Dingen um all diese Frontend-Applikationen.
Diese Rumgammeln und so Zeug tun.
Und Animationen.
Wahrscheinlich reicht das auch schon, dass es im Safari drin ist.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, weil Safari ist einfach so ein CPU-Hog mit vielen geöffneten Seiten. Und da macht es natürlich total Sinn. Kann es trotzdem sein, dass diese Apnap-Geschichte auch nochmal mit diesen APIs, ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt, die damit zu tun haben, ob der Rechner sich jetzt runterfahren darf oder nicht. Also ob man einen Sleep verhindert, damit gekoppelt ist.
Ja, es gibt ja sowas, das gibt es schon länger, dieses Sudden Termination. Ich glaube, das muss deine App unterstützen.
Was ging nicht? Drehen ging nicht, oder was heißt das?
Nee, kippen.
Kippen ist doch hier.
Ja, aber eben nur das.
Ich bin beim Maps wieder gerade.
Echt?
Ich kann jetzt dir nicht genau sagen. Ich muss da noch mal reingucken. Dann können wir da noch mal Nachruf machen. Was interessant ist, es gibt jetzt zwei neue Frameworks, die ich mir aufgeschrieben habe für Mac OS X, die ich interessant fand. Das eine hieß Media Library, wo du also in deinen ganzen, also zumindest in den ganzen Apple Apps, wie iPhoto und iMovie und bla und so weiter, auf die entsprechenden Libraries zugreifen kannst. Da gibt es noch eine extra Framework, das heißt iTunes Media Library. Warum jetzt das andere nicht bei der Media Library? Keine Ahnung, also habe ich mir nicht so genau angeguckt. Das Problem war ja immer, es gab bisher so ein Modul, das nannte sich irgendwie Media Framework. Nee, so ein Third-Party-Ding, wo das mal jemand zusammen programmiert hat, auf all diese ganzen Libraries zuzugreifen und wo du im Prinzip dir ein Fenster aufmachen konntest, wo der User dann aus diesen ganzen Libraries irgendwelche Assets auswählen konnte. Und das ist natürlich mit der Sandbox hinten übergefallen, das ging nicht mehr. Und Apple hat jetzt endlich diese Libraries nachgereicht, wo du auf das Zeug zugreifen kannst und trotzdem Sandbox-kompatibel bist. Insofern, gut. Und das letzte, was ich mir zum OSX aufgeschrieben hab, was jetzt weniger OSX ist, mehr ist mehr Xcode, diese Module-Geschichte in C, worüber wir mal vor, weiß ich nicht, wie vielen Folgen gesprochen haben, dieses Apple will die Includes wegmachen und stattdessen Module, weil und so weiter und so weiter, ist jetzt in Xcode drin. Wenn du ein neues Projekt machst, kriegst du automatisch Module und keine Includes mehr.
Einen Recherche-Auftrag hab ich noch, weil ich hab ja ein Gerücht gehört und ich wär jetzt mal interessiert, ob das jetzt eigentlich stimmt. Dieses AV Foundation Framework, das ist ja sozusagen so dieses einfachste Ding, mit dem du Audio in out machen kannst.
Ja.
Das konnte bisher, bot es dir nicht, die Auswahl des Kanals auf deinem Audio-Device an und ich habe gehört, dass dieses Problem gefixt sein soll. Und das fände ich ja mal jetzt wirklich interessant.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein Recherche-Auftrag.
Den Einfach-Abs. Du kannst das ja mal...
Ich schreib's mir mal auf und für nächstes Mal weiß ich dann wahrscheinlich Bescheid, wenn ich's nicht irgendwie verschmeiße und vergesse. Ich wär dann mit OSTN durch.
Sonst noch jemand? Dennis? Fällt dir noch irgendwas ein? Ah, ich weiß noch was.
Und zwar...
Schocker. Ist auch was für Clemens. Clemens hast du zu? Clemens ist auf dem Klo. Ah, ist gut.
Die sind jetzt alle vom Stuhl oder Fahrrad oder aus der U-Bahn gefallen.
AFP ist deprecated. Der Default-File-Sharing-Zugriff von einem Maverick auf einen anderen Maverick ist jetzt SMB 2. Apple benutzt das Windows 8 und ich glaube auch 7 SMB-Protokoll. Steht in dem Core-Technology-Overview. AFP ist raus.
Du es mon, du es mon. Was?
AFP ist raus.
Jetzt, wo net a talk endlich mal richtig funktioniert.
Da wird dich aber einer ärgern. Da haben sie so lange ihren GPL-Core zurückgehalten und Leute geärgert und so weiter und wollten eine dicke Firma aufbauen und dann sowas.
Ist das dann auch Time Machine im Backup? Also, Time Machine über Netzwerk, bla. Ich hab diesen Technology-Dingens da nur reingeblättert.
Hier steht es auch auf Apple Insider. Genau. Ich hab's aus diesem Core-Technology-Doku.
Das ist natürlich mal...
Aber mal ehrlich, was ist denn SMB 2?
SMB 2 ist quasi die überarbeitete Version von SMB.
Aber Apple hat doch, die haben doch das SMB neu geschrieben, weil sie wollten nicht zu SMB Version 4 wechseln, weil das irgendwie GPL 3 ist oder irgendwie so was und haben sich ihr Zeug selber neu geschrieben oder sowas. Richtig?
Also ihr Samba oder was?
Ja, genau, Samba, Entschuldigung. Also sie wollten kein Samba Version 4 einsetzen und haben sich deswegen eine Eigenentwicklung nahgemacht.
Richtig.
Aber jetzt geht's ja nicht um eine Version von Samba, sondern jetzt geht's sozusagen um die nächste Generation SMB. Ich kann ja mal kurz zitieren, was sie in ihrem Core Technology Overview PDF schreiben. SMB2 ist der neue Default Protocol für die Schätzung von Files in OSX, Mavericks. SMB2 ist super schnell, erhöht die Sicherheit und verbessert die Windows-Kompatibilität.
Wer braucht denn die jetzt noch?
Na ja, das ist halt, sagen wir mal, um auch weitere Windows-Frechner. Genau, also da ist halt in diesem ganzen industriellen Umfeld, ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt klar, wenn sie jetzt dasselbe Protokoll sprechen wie Windows. Also, haben sie auch schon vorher probiert. Aber ihre Argumente sind halt, dass es jetzt sehr viel effizienter ist, weil du halt mehrere Requests bündeln kannst und Large Read und Vreiz und so weiter werden unterstützt. Ich vermute mal was. Und große MTU, 14 Gigabit Ethernet etc. Extended Authentication Security using Kerberos NTL-MV2.
Du, wenn es besser funktioniert, warum nicht?
Genau, das wird doch der Hintergrund sein. Weil sie wussten, dass sie mit ihrem AFP jetzt mal was tun müssen. Weil das ist wirklich richtig alt. Das ist so richtig, richtig alt. Das ist genauso alt wie der HFS-Quack. Und das mussten sie jetzt mal anfassen, auch aus verschiedenen Gründen. Und dann haben sie sich wahrscheinlich, denke ich, mal wirklich die Frage gestellt, okay, machen wir jetzt wieder was Neues? Das heißt, da finden wir wieder ein Rad neu. Müssen aber trotzdem ohnehin SMB unterstützen, weil sie müssen ja mit ihrem Zeug in einer Corporate-Welt irgendwo leben. Und dann haben sie sich gesagt, naja, mein Gott, das Protokoll ist okay, das können wir gebrauchen, dann schlagen wir gleich zwei Klappen mit einer Fliege. Und dann haben wir das sozusagen da vom Tisch. Kann ich durchaus nachvollziehen. Was jetzt spannend ist, wie gut die Implementation ist, wie sie das schaffen, die Sachen, die so Apple-spezifisch sind, wie Extended Attributes und diese ganzen anderen Schnöcken, diese Flex da, um so ein Pfeil so rot zu markieren und diesen ganzen Tra-la-la oder sowas, ob sie das irgendwie so hin gespeichert kriegen und mit welchen Attributen, dass sie das auch wieder so zurückkriegen oder ob sie dann sozusagen das Pfeilsystem wirklich da an Funktionalität verliert. Das werden wir mal sehen.
Das mussten sie doch auf SMB und AFP auch schon draufsatteln. Also ich denke, das ist nicht so schwierig.
Auf AFP haben sie das oben drauf gemacht. Nee, in AFP ist das drin. Das kannst du machen, wenn du mit AFP Sachen sharest. Das haben sie damit eingebaut. Aber wie gesagt, spannend. Zu der Frage, die Tim natürlich stellen muss, als ich mich gerade ums Bier gekümmert habe. Time Machine ist derzeit noch der Grund, warum AFP noch offiziell da drin ist. Also es ist zwar deprecated, aber sie sagen, für Time Machine machen wir noch AFP.
Nein, nicht nur für Time Machine.
Überhaupt auf Zugriff von Rechnern mit anderen. Klar, altes Gerümpel ist klar, aber sie haben jetzt auch gesagt für das neue Ding, SMB 2 ist default, außer für Time Machine.
Die Frage ist, also das heißt auch, die Airports machen noch kein SMB 2?
Derzeit nicht gesehen.
Vielleicht kriegen sie ein Update über gebügelt, aber ich glaube, die alten Airports werden...
Wir sagen, es stand extra irgendwo drin. Wir machen es halt für alle, was mit Time Machine zu tun hat, machen wir derzeit nach AFP.
Wo stand das drin?
Keine Ahnung, gab ja diverse Zettel und White Paper. Übrigens auch das interessant, Apple hat jetzt mal Paper ausgerückt. Roddy hat jetzt zwar so schön kommentiert mit, naja, das steht jetzt auch nicht alles super in Detail drin, aber ich fand das toll, dass Apple mal sagt, hier haben wir mal ein Update und nicht so wie, na, findet mal die Dinge alle selber, wir sagen euch auf keinen Fall, was wir da irgendwie dran geändert haben, außer Security-Fixes, Punkt. Sondern sie schreiben jetzt mal, was sie so gemacht haben, was sie angefasst haben. Das fand ich mal ganz spannend.
Was ich gemeint hab, ist, das, was da drin steht, ist im Wesentlichen bekannt, aber du hast natürlich recht, es ist schön, dass das mal alles an einer Stelle steht.
Und dass es offiziell, dass es nicht jemand rausprepeln muss von draußen, sondern dass es jetzt mal von Apple, mit dem Apple-Logo oben drauf steht, hallo, das haben wir gemacht. Das ist mal was Neues, weil das tun sie ja sonst nicht.
Ja, aber da sind halt 5% von dem, was da drin steht, ist neu, wenn es nicht nur 3%, also an neuen Technologien. Und das, was alt ist, das findest du auch in anderer Dokumentation. Es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt was schreiben, was sie vorher noch nie offiziell geschrieben haben, aber die Zusammenfassung ist natürlich super. Auf einem technischen Level, den man jetzt nicht so kennt, unter den Marketingmaterialien von Apple.
Das fand ich mal interessant. Also in dieser Hinsicht auch, bin ich zufrieden. Weiter so, Apple. Ihr werdet noch erwachsen irgendwann.
Ja, das wird, das wird. Hat ich noch was? Ich glaube, das war's.
Also es ist natürlich spannend jetzt auch für die Zulieferindustrie, weil es gibt ja nur, selbst im Saturn gibt's ja diese Mini-File-Server mit ein bisschen Tralala drauf. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob's die inzwischen auch schon, weil es in SMB 2 gibt, weil ich kauf sowas nicht, aber das könnte jetzt natürlich auch wieder spannend werden, weil da war natürlich Apple immer so mit hinten dran. Wenn du jetzt so eine Platte gekauft hast, die jetzt nicht in USB, sondern Ethernet hinten dran hat, ausm Saturn sag ich mal so ein Ding, dann sprach das immer nur SMB.
Das wird sich wahrscheinlich auch erstmal nicht ändern.
Und das sprach niemals, nie, irgendeine dieser Platten, die ich gesehen habe, sprach irgendwie AFP oder irgendwas.
Doch, es gab ab und zu mal eine, aber das waren dann meistens veraltete AFP-Versionen oder so. Also nichts, was du wirklich mit AFP verwenden willst.
Klingt wie eine nachvollziehbare Entscheidung.
Das finde ich jetzt mal spannend zu gucken. Also du öffnest da auch nochmal so ein bisschen den Markt.
So, Kapitelmarke, kommen wir zu iOS 7. Und was ist unser erster Eindruck? Also ich warte die ganze Zeit noch, dass mich jemand aufrüttelt und sagt Tim, Tim, wach auf! Das ist nur ein Traum.
Also ich hab das seit gestern Morgen auf dem eigenen iPhone und jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass es die erste Developer-Preview ist, die nie gut läuft und das Teil halt stürzt halt irgendwie alle Nase.
Das Abstürzen stört ja einen auch nicht, das geht ja mehr um so Optiken.
Ja, das Abstürzen stört natürlich schon, aber das ist jetzt was, worum es jetzt erstmal nicht geht, sondern du machst das an und denkst dir so, aua, ich hab jetzt hier ein Android in der Hand oder so.
Ich fühlte mich eigentlich eher, ich fühlte mich eher so an Windows Phone erinnert, muss ich sagen.
Ja, so eine schlechte Mischung.
Aber ich weiß auch, wie wir hier saßen vor zwei oder vier Wochen, wo wir uns dieses Video von dieser irischen Designer-Bude angeguckt haben und ich meinte, das könnte sein und du so, ne, auf gar keinen Fall, da könnte man sich ja gleich ein Windows Phone kaufen.
Ja, und es ist noch schlimm geworden.
Und dann kaufst du jetzt ein Windows Phone?
Also auf jeden Fall ist das das erste Mal, wo ich mir denke so, mal gucken, wie lange ich das Update rauszögern kann. Wenn das so bleibt, also mach ehrlich.
Ich glaube, das sieht jetzt so schlimm aus, weil sie halt wirklich noch nicht komplett fertig sind, weil ich denke mal, wenn sie es durchziehen...
Also, wenn irgendetwas äppelt, schon immer konnte man's. Aber das sieht einfach, das sieht furchtbar aus. Mal ehrlich, das sieht wirklich, das ist furchtbar.
Also zu den Icons möchte ich Folgendes sagen. Zum Beispiel, oder aber, äh, die halbe Welt findet Van Gogh gut. Ich konnte mit dem nie was anfangen, weil ich die Farben immer schrecklich finde. Insofern möchte ich mich zu den Icons eigentlich gar nicht weiter äußern, weil das ist möglicherweise Geschmackssache.
Dieses Bild, weißt du, war doch diese Frau, die hat auch dieses Fresco übermalt von Jesus da. Dieses Jesus-Fresco. Weißt du, was ich meine?
Vive la restauration.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, ne?
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Das ist doch auch ein geiles Meme hier, dieses, genau, hier Renten-Rent übermalt Jesus-Fresco. Vorher, nachher, wo ist sie jetzt hier? Genau, ne? Und ich finde, das trifft sie in etwa. Ja, also vorher, vorher hat sie halt so Icons mit maximalem Detail.
Ja, sie waren schon ein bisschen angeeltert, blätterte die Farbe an einer oder anderen Stelle ab. Aber sie waren gut gemacht.
Ich finde, es gibt wirklich ganz großartige Icons in iOS. Also ich finde die wirklich schick.
Zum Beispiel?
Das Safari-Icon zum Beispiel.
Keine Frage.
Also das einzige, mit dem ich wirklich bisher immer gehadert habe, seit es das gibt, das sind diese glubschigen, aquaartigen Message-Bubbles. Damit komme ich nicht klar, noch nie. Also diese Sprechblasen, die habe ich sehr gestört. Die sind jetzt auch geflettend.
Die sind extrem geflettend.
An der Stelle kann ich das noch verschmerzen. Aber auch so dieses Mehl-Eiken, mit irgendwie Wolken dahinter. Auch dieser Kalender sieht irgendwie wirklich klar aus. Da ist dann ein schickes, bold... Ja, also die 12, die mich da jetzt gerade anleuchtet, die ist einfach gut zu erkennen. Was machst du denn da?
Er scrollt.
Ja, die wobbeln hin und her. Unglaublich, ob das ein Bug ist oder Absicht. Aber es irritiert mich auch immer.
Also Kalender ist das beste Beispiel, weil jetzt ist da so ein dünnes, helvetica, ultra thin, nochmal extra abgespeckte Johnny-Ice-Version. Da bleibt ja einfach von so einer Eins auch nichts mehr übrig. Ich meine, wie willst du denn das bitte optisch erfassen? Wo ist da jetzt bitte der und wie das aussieht? Allein das Kearling irgendwie. Also das ist doch einfach, das geht gar nicht.
Das Schlimmste meiner Meinung nach ist, dass Buttons nicht mehr wie Buttons aussehen. Da steht nur noch ein Wort und du kannst jetzt raten, ob du jetzt da draufklicken kannst und es passiert was oder nicht. Also ich meine, seit Ende der 90er gibt es diese Design-Idioten, die der Meinung sind, boah eine Webseite sieht doch total geil aus, wenn man bei allen Links jetzt mal die Unterstreichung weglässt. Weil das war doch schon immer mal schlimm. Und dann machen die das sechs Wochen und dann merken die Scheiße, da findet keiner mehr die Links. Weil man erkennt die Links nicht, wenn sie nicht unterstrichen sind. Und dann müssen die Jungs nach Canossa zurückkriechen und dann kriegt die Webseite wieder die Unterstreichung. Und das ist das größte Problem an diesem OS, ist du erkennst nicht mehr, was ein Button ist. Also manch einer würde sagen, funktional kaputt. Weißt du, ein Button, der nicht nach Button aussieht, den kann ich nicht drücken, weil ich nicht weiß, dass da ein Button ist. Ich meine, das ist so das allererste, was in jedem UI-Designbuch stehen müsste. Leute, das Zeug muss nach einem User-Element aussehen, sonst ist es keins.
Und jetzt kann ich nochmal aufgreifen.
Ich hatte die Diskussion heute mit Holgi.
Wo ist das Digitales? Schon mal so ein bisschen. Also zwei Herzen wohnen in meiner Brust, ja. Also kann natürlich auch sein, dass jetzt Apple irgendwas entdeckt hat, wo wir einfach noch nicht reif genug sind, um das sozusagen in seiner vollen Wandbreite zu verstehen und so. Naja, also erstmal, ich bin ja da ganz deiner Meinung. Also was mich am allermeisten stört, ist, dass ich das allererste Mal wirklich, das allererste Mal bei einem Produkt von Apple das Gefühl habe, es sieht hässlich aus. Ich will diesen Homescreen, der da leuchtet, nicht angucken. Ich finde die Farben ätzend. Ätzende Farbpalette. Ätzend. Wirklich schlimm. Diese ganze Flatness, diese ganze, wie dünn irgendwas ist, es sieht brüchig aus, es fällt auseinander. Und vor allem, es schwabbelt alles. Es vermengt sich auch zu so einer, also es ist einfach, das geht einfach überhaupt nicht. Allein diese Farben und wie sich das alles so gibt. Vorher wirkte das sehr viel konsistenter. Und ich will da in meinem iOS 6 Look, der liegt mir. Dazu gibt es noch diese ganze parallaxige Tour mit irgendwie, ja, wir haben jetzt die Layer und mein Background-Image, ja super, das schwabbelt jetzt so hin und her. Wozu brauchen wir das nochmal gleich jetzt, damit ich weiß, dass mein Background-Image, mein Background-Image ist?
Damit es nicht ganz so schlimm wie Windows Mobile aussieht.
Ja, aber das muss ich jetzt die ganze Zeit mit meinem Telefon hin und her wackeln, damit ich irgendwie noch die Pixel unterscheiden kann. Und was ist, wenn ich das nicht will, wenn mich das stört? Ich mein, dann bewegt sich die ganze Zeit was, was ich nicht bewegen muss, um was zu finden. Und es bewegt sich die ganze Zeit.
Verbraucht das bestimmt Batterie.
Muss ich, na vor allem verbraucht das einfach Aufmerksamkeit. Ich schau doch automatisch hin, wenn sich irgendwo, wenn hier eine Fliege durch den Raum fliegt, dann denkst du ja auch so, äh? Eigentlich tangiert dich die scheiß Fliege nicht, aber weil sie in deiner Optik steht, nervt dich das. Du willst da irgendwie die ganze Zeit hingucken. Das ist einfach, ja, das ist das Gegenteil von Timer-Core-Lessing, was sie da machen. Teilen meine Aufmerksamkeit in viele kleine Bewegungen, die ich gar nicht wahrnehmen möchte.
Geil finde ich auch diesen Homescreen, also diesen Log-Screen. Man kommt auf diesen Log-Screen und da steht Entsperren und da drunter ist ein Pfeil nach oben. Und was macht man natürlich als erstes? Man schiebt nach oben und bekommt dann dieses komplett überladene Menü, wo irgendwie in der ersten Zeile sind...
Na komm, das ist nicht komplett überladen, das ist einfach ein voller Bildschirm.
Natürlich, fünf Kringel, Flugmodus...
Ey, wenn du da so ein uraltes iPhone hast, ist ja kein Wunder, wenn dein Bildschirm voll ist.
Wieso?
Na bei meinem ist da nichts voll.
Da passiert gar nichts bei deinem.
Ich hab's ausgemacht, aber ich hab's ja hier.
Dass man zum Entsperren, man klickt ja auch nicht drauf, auf das Entsperren.
wie haben sie es genannt? Center?
Control Center nannten sie es, glaube ich. Also dieses Control Center, das ist echt ein Chaos, ein Überladenes.
Das ist voll okay, ist doch voll entspannt.
Dann musst du das Entsperren zur Seite tun. Gut, wenn man mal ein altes iPhone hatte, dann weiß man, dass man halt diesen Schiebebutton da schiebt. Aber bei dem alten iOS-Log war das voll klar zu sehen. Da war dieser Button mit dem Pfeil drauf. Der war in dieser Rinne drin, wo man richtig sieht. Wenn ich den bewege, dann bewegt er sich in dieser Rinne und dann stand da noch Entsperren. Und das hat sich so von links nach rechts so gewuppelt, dass noch mal diese Bewegung hatte. Und dann konnte man da schön rumschieben. Und ich meine, wenn ich jetzt hier ausschalte, zum Beispiel, dann kriege ich das Gleiche. Dann kriege ich oben einen roten Balken, da steht Ausschalten drin. Klicke ich da jetzt drauf? Nein, auch da muss ich wieder...
Ach so geil. Ach Gott.
Also da legt sich so ein roter Beißen drüber.
Das kann man ja noch nicht mal lesen.
Das kann man noch nicht mal richtig lesen, genau.
Weil dahinter wahrscheinlich noch der Hintergrund auch noch mal so durchscheint.
Dahinter scheinen erst die Icons durch und dann noch der Hintergrund. Und dann natürlich parallaxiert alles noch schön. Also das ist irgendwie so...
Was für ein Dreck.
Den abbrechen kann ich aber einfach so untappen, den ausschalten nicht. Den muss ich schieben. Also es gibt nur so Beispiele.
Vor allem wie sieht denn das aus? Das sieht total dreckig aus. Ich meine, das erste, wenn ich einen neuen Mac einrichte, das erste, was ich mache, ist, ich schalte die Transparenz vom Menü aus. Genau aus demselben Grund. Und jetzt erzählen sie mir ausführlich in irgendwelchen Vorträgen, wie geil das ist, dass in jedem User Interface-Control der ganze Mumpel, der dahinter liegt, dann da auch noch ist. Und das soll mir auch noch helfen. Das hilft mir einfach gar nicht. Also zur iOS 7 fällt mir wirklich nichts ein. Das ist, da mag technisch nirgender Fortschritte sein.
Mail geht halbwegs.
Vielleicht macht Apple es ja dann auch, dann gibt es einen 7.1 wie bei Microsoft und dann machen sie das alles wieder weg.
Ja, aber auch mit diesem Textbutton, das ist alles so unsymmetrisch. Ein Button ist auf einmal breiter, wenn das Wort länger ist.
Ja, Feidig, was heißt so geil? Dann ist das alles so zusammengecramped. Man konnte ja unter iOS 6 und vorher konnte man ja, um etwas zu löschen, hat man ja die Zeile, also so in der Tabel nur hat man so die Zeile von links nach rechts geschoben. Und dann ist da der Button erschienen zum löschen.
Genau, benutze ich täglich.
Ich habe gerade Spotlight gefunden, guck mal.
Ja, ich weiß, man zieht nach unten. Wenn du hier in der Zeile nach rechts schiebst, dann kommst du ein Ding ins Zurück. Also du löschst dann nicht, sondern du kommst eine Ebene zurück. Das ist, als würde ich den nach links button drücken oben rechts.
Wie löscht man jetzt?
Man muss nach rechts schieben.
Nach rechts? Nach links?
Ja, nach links, also in die andere Richtung. Und dann kriegt man zwei Buttons. Und mehr.
Nicht zwei Buttons, du kriegst zwei Quadrate.
Was heißt more? Wenn ich mehr drücke, dann kann ich markieren, ungelesen markieren, in Werbung bewegen und E-Mails bewegen machen. In Werbung bewegen? Ja, quasi als BEM-Markierung markieren.
In Werbung ordner Junk?
In Werbung ordner. Werbung ist die Anführungszeichen. Im E-Mail-Protokolle sagen, sonst platzt der Chat wieder. In Werbung bewegen.
Werbung in Anführungszeichen.
In Werbung bewegen.
In Werbung bewegen, ja gut. Vielleicht ist jetzt auch die Lokalisierung noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Das ist aber ein Feature. Das kann man nämlich, wenn man einen ordentlichen Mails-Haube hat, kann man das gebrauchen.
Ja, Junk-Mail. Ach so, Junk-Mail könnte man bisher noch gar nicht machen.
Ja, nee, das hat jetzt noch eine andere Wand.
Das wird mal gelesen. Das zeig noch mal bitte. Filter für Mail-App. Power genug.
Mal löschen wir nicht so viele Mails weg. Sondern das die Ungelesenen noch nicht. Also ich finde, Mail geht noch am ersten.
Vorallem dieses Löschding. Geh mal in den Mail und schieb mal rüber. Guck es dir mal bitte an. Und jetzt schieb mal irgendeine Mail nach links. So, jetzt hast du da Monster-Buttons. Oder auch nicht. Jetzt hast du da zwei riesengroße Quadrate.
So Plan-Quadrate. Na ja, wenn du jetzt auf löschen drückst, dann ist es natürlich weg.
Funktionieren würde schon, aber sieht trotzdem scheiße aus.
Wenn man jetzt mehrere markiert, und dann hat man unten löschen, bewegen, markieren... Was war jetzt nochmal falsch mit Icons? Ich meine, Icons muss man nicht übersetzen.
Wie Icons? Du meinst so...
Na ja, vorher gab es ja so ein Icon, was mir gesagt hat, hier das in einen Ordner rein machen. Und da passt man auch mal so fünf rein.
Ja, aber die hast du gehabt, wenn du in der Mail tatsächlich drin warst. Und wenn du jetzt ganz in die Mail reingehst, kriegst du auch wieder unten die Icons. Die sind aber alle auch ein bisschen zerdesignt. Also das ist... Man kann nicht mehr so recht erkennen, was das Icon mir eigentlich für eine Handlung andienen möchte. Ja, grad noch so ist so ein... Ich rette mich jetzt darüber hinweg, dass es eigentlich auch scheiße ist.
Aber jetzt kann man dafür Auto-Update für alle Apps anschalten.
Das kann man wenigstens abschalten.
Aber ehrlich gesagt ist das orthogonal zu dem Design.
Das haben sie doch kurzfristig eingebaut, weil dieser eine Fregel dieser Präsidentschaft, das kann ich dir hier erkennen, der hat doch neulich bei so einer Senatsbefragung Tim Cook gefragt, was das soll, warum man dauernd diese Upstar updaten soll. Das hat ihn doch total genervt. Und aber ganz ehrlich, möchte man das, dass es dich einfach jetzt mitten unterm Arsch irgendwelche Ups ersetzt?
Du magst es nicht. Andere mögen es. Solange man es ein- und ausschalten kann, ist es okay, ja. Es ist mal wieder abgeschmiert. Also, naja. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie irgendwie noch so Buttons in der Hinterhand haben, die es dann noch gibt. Falls sich herausstellt, dass das dann doch viel zu viele Leute verwirrt. Aber ich seh da ja ehrlich gesagt weiß. Also schwarz.
Ja, hier Chet merkt gerade an, Multi-User ist auch nicht zu sehen.
Na ja, gut, noch haben wir nicht die Version fürs iPad gesehen. Multi-User fürs iPhone. Finde ich jetzt.
Nee, fürs Phone nicht unbedingt. Aber auch da ist das durchaus sinnvoll, weil du hast immer so diesen Effekt mit ich gebe das Telefon jetzt meinen Kindern. Aber ich habe einfach keinen Bock, den Kindern das Telefon zu geben und dann kriege ich es mit fünf gelöschten Mail-Accounts und was weiß ich, was für Mumpets noch wieder. Und da werden dann irgendwelche Voice-Mails gelöscht oder abgespielt oder sonst irgendwas. Die drücken halt alles an, was bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen ist und da sich halt nichts verstecken kann. Es gibt einfach keinen Kindermodus, es gibt einfach keinen Gästemodus, kein was auch immer Modus.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt definitiv nicht mehr. Das geht auch immer weiter. Je mehr Passwörter in die NSA-Chain oder wie auch immer, desto weniger darfst du deinem Phone demnächst aus der Hand geben. Und das geht immer weiter. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie auch nur irgendeinen Schritt dahingehend machen, das dir erlauben würde, deinem Telefon jemand anderes in die Hand zu drücken.
Machst du da irgendwas mit deinem Mikrofon?
Ja, ich merke das auch gerade. Aber ich sitze hier so. Als ich mich zu Dennis rüber gebeugt habe, hatte ich auch nur mal auf einem Kanal was. Auf dem Kopfhörer. Vielleicht ist das Ding hier irgendwie wackelig oder so.
Man wird das Gefühl nicht los, irgendwie mitten in einer Baustelle zu sein, die irgendwie... Das ist so Apples BER hier. Also das wird in den nächsten Jahren nicht gut.
Es ist eine Baustelle.
Wenn es überhaupt irgendwie wird.
Also ich bin immer noch ganz schön entsetzt. Also ich will das überhaupt nicht haben.
Du möchtest lieber wieder gerne Filz und Kuh. Nein, du willst zwar dazwischen hart.
Also ich will erstmal die nächste und übernächste Beta sehen, ob sie ihr Konzept, weil es ist jetzt noch so ein bisschen halbherzig umgesetzt, ob sie das noch irgendwie mal komplett zu Ende bringen. Weil ich finde auch, dass es... Also vielleicht mag man es flacher ja nicht mögen, aber zumindest sollte es am Ende alles einheitlich aussehen. Jetzt ist ja alles noch so halbfertig.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, sie haben das jetzt bejubelt. Diese ganze Keynote ging um Design.
Ja, aber die Leute, die da bejubeln, haben ja auch nur diese Videos gesehen. Und diese Videos sahen ja auch wesentlich besser aus, als das, was man jetzt auf dem iPhone sieht, oder?
Auch wieder wahr.
Also da sah das ja echt schick aus in den Videos. Da haben sie sich ja mal Mühe gegeben. Jetzt mit den Parallax auf dem iPhone sieht plötzlich gar nicht mehr gut aus.
Ganz, ganz ehrlich, also schon, als ich das nur auf der Webseite gesehen hab, so ein paar Screenshots, fand ich schon irgendwie...
Aua!
Das war schon irgendwie schwierig, ne? Und wenn man es dann auf dem Device sieht, denkt man so, Scheiße, das wird jetzt Wirklichkeit. Das ist so, aha! Also ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, an so manche Sachen gewöhnt man sich, aber...
An manche Sachen gewöhnt man sich nicht.
Nach zwei Tage benutzen habe ich irgendwie immer noch das Gefühl, ich bin jetzt irgendwie irgendwo, wo ich nicht hingehört. Also das ist so...
Angenommen, die Icons würden jetzt drumrum einen Schatten kriegen oder so, dass sie sich mehr vom Hintergrund absetzen oder irgendwie so was ganz Simples, was man nur einschalten muss.
Die Icons sind gar nicht mal so mein größtes Problem, weil ich meine, die designt halt irgendjemand, der es kann, mal neu und dann hast du neu die Icons und dann ist es okay.
Textbutton sind nicht das Hauptproblem.
Was mich viel mehr stört, ist dieses Design. Ich will alles flach haben.
Das gefällt jetzt nicht. Das ist ganz normal, wenn man auf die Einstellungen klickt.
Die Einstellungen sind okay, aber du siehst hier auf den Einstellungen, siehst du etwas, du hast diese komischen Ein-Ausschalt-Dinger, diese...
Buttons halt.
Diese Buttons.
Diese Slider-Buttons daher.
Diese Buttons, die kannst du dort als Buttons erkennen. Das ist ein Button. Du siehst, ich kann den nach rechts schieben und dann geht der an. Und dann verändert sich die Farbe von dem. Der Button ist an. Ich sehe der Button, der tut was. Und dann kann ich ihn wieder zurück tun und dann sehe ich, der Button ist wieder aus. Das ist ein Button, der hat... Wie soll ich sagen? Das ist ein User-Interface.
Du meinst diesen Schalter?
Diesen Schalter. Der sah vorher auch besser aus.
Und was dir nicht gefällt, sind jetzt hier...
Ob er vorher besser aussah oder nicht, ist jetzt nicht mein Punkt. Mein Punkt ist, man kann das Ding als einen Ausschalter erkennen. Man kann erkennen, ob er ein oder ausgeschaltet ist. Ich sehe, das ist ein User-Element, das ich wiedererkenne, das ich benutzen kann. Ich hab das Gefühl, ja, ich will Flugmodus anschalten, da drück ich da drauf und dann ist er an. Und dann seh ich, der wird grün. Warum auch immer grün? Und dann ist der Flugmodus an. Das ist ein nachvollziehbares Interface. Aber wenn irgendwo oben in der Headline des Programms irgendein Wort steht, wie bearbeiten, dann ist es nicht klar, dass das ein Button ist, auf den ich draufdrücken kann, um eine Aktion auszulösen. Das ist das größte Problem, was ich mit diesem Interface habe.
Ja, auch dieser Platzverbrauch, den finde ich einfach enorm. Gerade auf so einem Gerät wie dem iPhone, wo wirklich der Platz wirklich knapp ist. So ein Icon zum Bearbeiten da irgendwie, was weiß ich hier, Stift, Schreibt auf, Dinge, das war einfach, ich hab da kein Problem mit gehabt. Und jetzt muss da bearbeiten stehen. Ich frage mich, wie das in Sprachen ist.
Wie war das denn vorher?
In Finnisch ist das Ding wahrscheinlich einfach überhaupt nicht mitzubeben.
Bearbeiten gab es vorher auch, die Schrift war nur kleiner.
Oder da gibt es halt immer auch Icons für. Häufig genug.
Häufig genug Icons für.
Ja, manchmal steht das auch drauf, das stimmt.
Aber, wie gesagt, hier könnt mal wieder die Historie und den Mobile-Max-Hörern mal abspeichern. Wir werden das sehen. Ja, jede gute Zeit war mal eine schlechte neue Zeit.
Und ich meine, wir wissen, das ist alles möglich. Man kann einfach alles klicken und man klickt einfach irgendwie nichts raus. Also die Leute gibt jetzt auch keinen mehr, der nicht weiß, wie man dieses scheiß iPhone anlockt. Meierlich, Roddy.
Es wird diese Leute wieder geben. Ich glaube, wir werden uns da alle ganz schnell wieder einarbeiten.
Ja, aber wir müssen ja, also die drei Leute, die dann das iPhone nicht aufkriegen, das ist uns dann auch egal, oder? Und bisher, ich meine, ich hab jetzt noch nicht irgendwie einen Button übersehen, weil ich dachte, man kann den ja gar nicht klicken.
Ach so, das sind die die Tabs von dem von dem Safari, die sind jetzt quasi Coverflow.
Also nur von oben anstatt von vorne so?
Ja, was ich ein bisschen bekloppt finde, ist, dass er oben in der Titelleiste von Safari nicht mehr den vollen Link anzeigt. Du musst ihn erst selektieren, damit du dann auch alles angezeigt kriegst.
Die wollten halt Platz sparen da. Klar ist jetzt nicht alles perfekt, aber da sind schon auch ein paar schicke Ideen dabei, dass sie den dann halt so wegschieben, wenn man hochscrollt.
Und Abrechnis ab.
Ja, es ist eine Beta, es ist die erste. Wartet mal halt mal jetzt alle die Füße still und dann schauen wir uns nochmal an demnächst.
Also ich will Buttons, die nach Buttons aussehen, die man als solche erkennen kann, die man lecken kann. Nee, ich will nicht lecken, ich will drücken. Zumindest beim iPhone.
Ja, ich hab ja heute auch schon mit Holgi mal drüber geredet und auch schon mal versucht da so ein bisschen die andere Seite zu verstehen, was hier eigentlich vor sich geht.
Welche Seite war dann Holgi? Sollte es jetzt dazu sein?
Keine Seite, ich hab überhaupt erst mal versucht zu vermitteln, was, sagen wir mal jetzt überhaupt userrelevant ist. Weil wir ja gerade festgestellt haben, Developer-Konferenz, viel Developer-Content, das ist jetzt sagen wir mal nicht unbedingt das, was End-User interessiert. Nur dieses UI von iOS ist natürlich das userrelevanteste, was dort präsentiert wurde. na klar, man kann halt jetzt sagen, vielleicht ist die Zeit gekommen, dass wir diese Hilfen mit diesen Buttons, um Computer zu begreifen, so nicht mehr brauchen, weil wir die Computer als solche verstehen. Also es war ja auch so, diese User-Interfaces haben am Anfang sich ja bemüht, viele Metaphern aus der Außenwelt so heranzuziehen, um überhaupt erst mal so ein Benutzungsmodell zu vermitteln. Hallo, ich bin hier auf dem Bildschirm und du kannst was mit mir machen und guck mal, hier ist sogar so was Ähnliches. Am Anfang, interessant ist, dass die ja relativ flat gestartet sind, wenn man sich so System 6 oder so, das UR Mac OS anschaut, wie so ein Button da aussah.
Ja, das war schwarz-weiß, die hatten nicht die Möglichkeit.
Ja klar, aber so sah es aus. Jetzt könnte man sagen, das war flat. Da war alles sehr flat.
Natürlich war es flat, es ging ja nicht anders.
Ja gut, mit System 7 war es dann das erste Mal dreidimensional.
So ein bisschen, ja.
Mac OS 8 hat da noch noch einiges hinzugefügt in dieser ganzen Glubschi-Nest.
Gerüffelte Titelleisten und so.
Ja, fand ich auch irgendwie alles. Also ich fand das eigentlich nie wirklich scheiße. Also mir hat das immer ganz gut gefallen. Und ich fand auch interessanterweise Aqua eigentlich ganz gut, bis auf die Stripes.
Aqua war, also zumindest wenn man zurückblickt, war das völlig überzogen. Aber es war zu einem gewissen Zweck völlig überzogen. Also wenn man so zurückblickt, ich glaube, dass Steve damals das Gefühl hatte, wir müssen jetzt richtig auf die Tube drücken, damit die Leute merken, hier kommt jetzt eine ganz neue Generation, die kann jetzt was ganz anderes. Und es ist viel besser als alles, was da gewesen ist. Und ihr müsst es jetzt alle wollen. Und die haben ja dann mit jeder Version dieses Aqua zurückgebaut. Inzwischen ist glaube ich überhaupt kein Shiny Bubble mehr übrig geblieben. Doch die Ampel-Buttons, die sind auch so ein bisschen shiny. Aber ansonsten ist nichts mehr übrig geblieben von denen.
Na ja gut, die Buttons sind immer noch blau so. scheinen auch noch so ein bisschen.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Viel ist nicht mehr übrig.
So ein Halo ist auf jeden Fall da.
Aber sie haben es eigentlich mit jeder Version zurückgebaut, könnte man sagen.
Na und der Button pulsiert immer noch der Default-Button. Und das fand ich eigentlich auch schon immer gut. Hier Aufmerksamkeit, da das ist ein wichtiger Bereich. Blau leuchtet er und pumpt, weil da musst du jetzt weitermachen und so. Das ist schon auch sehr hilfreich gewesen. Und jetzt kommt diese Webseitenkultur und sagt alles muss jetzt hier irgendwie Text sein. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich finde Text ist einfach schwierig.
Ja, das ist ein User-Interface und keine Werbebroschüre. Also ich meine, wenn ich nicht klicken muss, dann ist es okay, dass ich nur Text habe. Aber wenn ich einfach mal einen Button und einen Slider von einfach normalem Text, der irgendwie Informationen bietet, unterscheiden muss, können muss, dann muss es eine Möglichkeit geben, die zu unterscheiden. Ich sag nicht, dass Buttons dreidimensional sein müssen. Müssen sie nicht. Gut, sind sie jetzt die letzten 20 Jahre gewesen. Aber müssen sie nicht unbedingt. Aber ich muss einen Button halt als Button erkennen können. Sonst kann ich da nicht draufdrücken. Also du wirst sehen, wenn das rauskommt, der User, der das erste Mal ein iOS-Gerät in der Hand hat, der wird wie ein Bekloppter auf dem Display rumtappen, nur um zu gucken, ob nicht doch noch der eine oder andere Text irgendeine Funktion verbirgt. Und das kann es ja wohl nicht gewesen sein. Also so.
Hier gibt es gerade so einen Bericht von auf Macromos, dass sie das Marketing-Team irgendwie mit den Icons beauftragt haben.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt will ich nicht zu sehr auf den Icons rumreiten. Die sind hässlich fertig. Also das ist irgendwie so, aber die kann man fixen. Zu übernächsten Beta sind die vielleicht hübsch, weil sie jemanden angesetzt haben, der sowas kann. Wenn die Icons schön gemacht sind, dann können die auch ein bisschen flatter sein oder so. Das ist mir dann auch egal, wenn die Farbpalette stimmt und und und.
Ich kann da vor allem auch überhaupt keine Verbesserung erkennen.
Das Uhrenicon ist okay.
Schau dir mal diese Messages-Bubble an, wie wohlgeformt das vorher war, was das jetzt für ein bekloppter Luftballon geworden ist. Diese Kamera sieht aus wie so eine Kamera von 1980. Das ist einfach wirklich furchtbar.
Ohne Objektiv, ne?
Ja.
Und dieses Wettericon, das sieht auch...
Und was soll bitte dieses Game Center mir jetzt kommunizieren? Da möchte ich doch wirklich wieder meinen Stoffbezug wieder zurückholen.
Kommt dann da drauf, klickst du an jedem Bubble, die werden dann so groß, steht dann irgendwie was drin.
Wie gesagt, gestern war das nicht auch ein Ask Techniker oder so, aber es gab so einen Designer, der hat diese neue Design genommen und da hat es sozusagen wieder schick gemacht.
Die Bubbles bewegen sich die ganze Zeit, die schwabeln so rum.
Na toll. Und dieses Settings-Logo, das war wirklich ein wirklich schickes Icon vorher. Jetzt weiß ich überhaupt nicht, das sieht aus wie so ein Lüfter-Schlitz.
Ich finde, das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so eine Trommel von einer Waschmaschine irgendwie.
Oder auch dieser Newsstand, also echt mal.
Der Newsstand ist auch nicht die Scheiße. Apropos Newsstand, man kann den Newsstand jetzt in ein Folder räumen. Das ist nur am Rande.
Na hurra! Next World mit iOS 8 kann man ihn wahrscheinlich auch endlich mal löschen.
Eingebaute Apps löschen, das ging glaube ich noch nicht.
Na warum nicht?
Weiß ich nicht, ich hätte das Docs schon in der...
Die kommen eh wieder.
iOS 1 gelöscht.
Die kommen alle immer schlimmer wieder. Die sind ganz, ganz nah.
Zombie-Icons, die kommen immer wieder. Man kann richtig nicht tot.
Also, ich kann nur hoffen...
Also diese generelle Design-Richtung, schlichter, noch schlichter, mehr Text und so weiter, das seh ich noch halbwegs ein, weil viele gehen in die Richtung. Also wenn du dir jetzt sowas zum Beispiel anguckst, wie diesen app.net Passport. Also es ist so ein Ding, das passt eigentlich direkt in dieses Interface rein.
Ja, oder Letterpress geht schon so in die Richtung als App und dieses Bitcoin-Report ist von der Optik her so...
Gut, das hat auch so eine Android-Menü irgendwie. Keine Ahnung, es gibt so viele... Da muss es irgendein Toolkit geben, um dieses Android-Menü zu machen. Aber auch da hast du halt Buttons, die nach Buttons aussehen. Also es ist oval mit einem Text drin, wo klar ist, wenn ich da drauf drücke, dann passiert was. Also es ist irgendwie so... Ich werde mich schon hier... Ich beiß mich an den Buttons fest. Aber es ist irgendwie mein größtes Problem an dem Ding, weil das lässt dann auch so Struktur vermissen, wenn so nicht mehr klar ist, was ist jetzt eigentlich Text und was ist irgendwie Bedienelement. Und das mancht alles so ineinander. Und das ist irgendwie...
Ja, man hat dann auch so...
Soll ich dir deinen Riech als reichen?
Okay, können wir vielleicht mal...
Noch bin ich nicht in Ohnmacht gefallen.
Wir halten fest, there's work to do. Und die Frage ist jetzt, gibt es in iOS 7 noch irgendwelche technischen Neuigkeiten, die wir geil finden? Ich fühl mich jetzt nicht so sehr im User Interface festhalten.
Es gibt in iOS 7... Es gibt Background. Es gibt noch eine technische Neuigkeit, die finde ich überhaupt nicht geil, aber die ist erwähnenswert. Nämlich, man konnte ja bisher schon verschiedene Tastaturen konfigurieren. Also du hast irgendwie... Du hast eine Software... Genau, du hast eine Software, Tastatur, Englisch, Deutsch und so weiter. Und du kannst jetzt zu der Tastatur, die du konfigurierst, also sagen wir Englisch, kannst du die Hardware-Tastatur-Belegung auch mitkonfigurieren.
Nein, wenn du Bluetooth-Hackware dran hast...
Wenn du eine Bluetooth-Tastatur pairst, dann kannst du sagen, wenn ich eine englische Software-Tastatur habe, möchte ich bitte eine englische Hardware-Tastatur-Belegung haben. Wenn ich eine deutsche Tastatur-Belegung habe, möchte ich eine deutsche Hardware-Tastatur-Belegung haben. Kannst du natürlich auch tauschen. Das ist mir das erste Mal im Simulator aufgefallen, als da plötzlich ein Z war, wo ich ein Y getippt hatte. Und ich dachte mir so, hä, was tut der da? Also es ist so etwas unklar.
Kommen wir noch mal kurz zu den API Änderungen. Also da hat sich ja einiges getan. Was ich am bemerkenswertesten fand in der Präsentation, war diese Sache mit den Background-Apps. Naja, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass du einfach einen Prozess startest und der läuft so im Hintergrund, sondern nicht richtig korrigiert. Meine Wahrnehmung ist jetzt erstmal, es wird nicht mehr nach Programmkategorien unterschieden, sondern generell darf jetzt jeder Hintergrundprozesse starten, oder?
Ja, da ist auch API zu entstanden, sag ich mal. Aber auch da, muss ich sagen, hab ich auf die Schnelle nicht so ganz verstanden, was jetzt der eigentliche Trick da dran ist.
Ich auch nicht.
Also es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein, dass du auch wirklich einen Prozess starten kannst. Allerdings unter welchen Bedingungen, der wann und wie lange läuft, kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen. Also das muss ich mir nochmal genauer angucken. Aber irgendwas ist da passiert. Ja, das ist so. Aber es gibt relativ viel anderen Kram, der witzig ist.
Sie haben dann auch noch diese opportunistischen Wake-ups, also dass du quasi diese Hintergrundprozesse, die dürfen dann sozusagen aktiv werden, wenn der User sowieso gerade was anderes tut und so solche Gelegenheiten und wenn andere Sachen aufgeweckt werden, wenn die dann mit aufgeweckt.
Ich glaube, da steckt so was Ähnliches dahinter wie bei bei bei OSX, dieses Tamer-Core-Lessing.
Also generell haben sie sozusagen eine eine Aufwachlogik dort mit eingebaut und sehen es grundsätzlich als mehr tragbar an, mehr Hintergrund zu ermöglichen.
Ja, wie gesagt, das habe ich mir nicht so genau angeguckt auf die Schnelle.
Ich habe das auch nur so aus der Keynote jetzt so rausgelesen.
Irgendwas war da, aber so richtig verstanden habe ich es jetzt auf die Schnelle nicht.
Was ich noch entdeckt habe als Gimmick ist, man kann sich seinen eigenen Vibration Sound klicken.
Das ging doch vorher schon. Du konntest ihn so zusammen tappen. Das ist schon das Rottnuss-Muster.
Irgendwo habe ich das nie gesehen, man hat da nie einer vor Uhr gesprochen.
New Multitasking API.
Hast du jetzt da C-Line drauf oder du hast das alte?
Naja, das C-Line, das war mir zu schneckenmäßig.
iOS C-Line.
iOS C-Line. iOS 7.
Ich kann mal noch ein paar andere Sachen sagen, die mir aufgefallen sind. Zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt eine Klasse, also in der AV Foundation, dieser Audio-Video Foundation, gibt es jetzt eine Klasse Speech Synthesis und eine Klasse AV Video Compositing. Also man scheint tatsächlich sein eigenes Speech Synthesis machen zu können, on the fly und auch Videos compositen zu können. Das fand ich schon mal nicht schlecht. In Core Image ist irgendwas mit Face Recognition drin, wo man halt auf Images Face Recognition machen kann. Bei Core Telephony...
Sekunde mal, Face Recognition, aber nur gegen deine eigenen Fotos. Oder hat jetzt die NSA ihre Leitung auf B-Direktion neu geschaltet, das heißt du kannst also auch Abfragen machen bei denen. Wäre denn schon wieder okay?
Also Core Image geht mal davon aus, dass es von irgendjemanden erstmal einfach nur ein Image bekommt.
Also das heißt, du gehst denn in deine... Die Foto-Up hat ja schon eine Sammlung von Gesichtern mit Zuordnung zu Namen. Da wird es wahrscheinlich reingreifen, denke ich mal, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht. Nee, es geht mehr darum, dass er erkennt, wo ist ein Gesicht. Und er erkennt, glaube ich, noch, wo er... Ob das Gesicht jetzt lächelt oder...
Also es geht nicht darum, eine Person zu erkennen, sondern ein Gesicht zu erkennen. Das benutzen sie übrigens auch im OS schon an vielen Stellen, auch in OSX. Wenn du zum Beispiel ins Adressbuch ein Foto reinwirfst, dann erkennen sie auch, wo sind die Augen und justieren und scalen das Bild auch schon mal für dich.
In welchem OSX, in welchem Universum?
Na ja, was wir jetzt gerade benutzen.
Mal Gesicht da reinschmeißen. Ich meine, ich hab welche drin, aber...
Also du hast jetzt eine API dafür.
Wir schneiden dann einfach immer irgendwie magisch an. Also es ist nicht so, dass das einfach so... Wenn du jetzt so ein Square-Bild nimmst da rein, dann verhält sich das anders, je nachdem wie... Also kannst du gerne mal ausprobieren, das war zumindest immer meine Wahrnehmung.
Core Telephony, du kannst jetzt über den Subscriber und über Netzwerk Infos bekommen.
Ach.
Gibt es jetzt eine öffentliche API zu?
Nämlich welche?
Was spuckt die aus?
So genau hab ich es mir nicht angeguckt, aber es gibt es jetzt.
Gibt es überhaupt erst mal sozusagen Core Telephony?
Gibt es überhaupt erst mal. Na ja, war in den API-Diffs als jetzt ganz neu. Sie müsste jetzt nochmal reingucken.
Aber man ist doch als Ab gar nicht am Telefon. Also da gibt es doch die Telefon-Ab.
Finde ich jetzt nämlich auch spannend. Du gehst da gerade so drüber hinweg, aber...
Du kannst dir wahrscheinlich anzeigen lassen oder sagen lassen, bei welchem Provider ist jetzt derjenige gerade eingebucht und solche Sachen. Ob du jetzt eine IMSI abfragen kannst, weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Oder ein E-Mail oder sowas. Das möglicherweise nicht, aber... Ich sehe schon, ich hätte...
Das kann man ja mal klicken. Kann man sich mal an seinen Developer-Account einloggen und dann mal die... Du sagst, es gibt jetzt Core Telephony, da gibt es jetzt.
Ich glaube, das gab es vorher schon. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht 100% sicher, aber...
Airdrop hier habe ich schon probiert, weil du es gerade auf dem Schirm hast. Das ging irgendwie mit zumindest 10, 8 ging es nicht. Also ich wollte mal so ein Bild auf mein Laptop airdroppen. Das ist ein Feature, das ich schon immer gerne gehabt hätte. Oder auch bei anderen Leuten, vor allem nicht bei mir, sondern zu jedem anderem. Aber hat nicht geklappt.
Wie alt ist denn dein Laptop?
Airdrop kann das. Aber das iPhone war nicht zu sehen.
Kann natürlich sein, dass da sozusagen die Backward-Compatibility noch nicht so ganz fertig ist.
Kann sein, ja.
Was ich an Airdrop besonders interessant finde, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist, dass das auch etwas ist, was die Ups machen können. Also du kannst quasi jetzt nicht... Weil es macht ja eh keinen Sinn, auf dem iPhone ein File irgendwo hinzubringen, weil wo willst du es dann speichern?
Nee, vom iPhone zum Rechner.
Ja, aber du kannst ja auch von iPhone zu iPhone was schicken.
Also es gibt ja jetzt ein sogenanntes Multi-Peer-Connectivity-Framework. Aber wie gesagt, auch da weiß ich nicht genau, was es tut, aber es könnte sein, dass es in diesen ganzen Airdrop-Grammit eingreift. Vielleicht ist es auch nur über Bluetooth oder so.
Aber einen Airdrop-Receive-Modus fürs iPhone gibt es doch gar nicht. Das iPhone kann Airdroppen nur senden, oder?
Was ich ja so geil finde, ist, du schickst jemanden per Airdrop was, ein Bild, und der kriegt das sofort angezeigt.
Noch bevor man es annimmt?
Ja, noch bevor du es annimmst, bekommt er die Vorschau angezeigt.
Grüße von Goatzi!
Ja, nicht nur von Goatzi, sondern halt auch von irgendwie anderen Exploits.
Ja, also...
Also das ist doch mal...
Ich warte auch schon darauf, dass der erste Wall oder so wieder irgendwie seine komische Tonne in die Stadt stellt und wenn du daran vorbei läufst, hautet der irgendwelche Werbebilder auf dein iPhone.
Ja, gut, aber du musst ja explizit AirDrop auch einschalten.
Hier schalten wir ein.
Also das ist ja der Gag wieder weg. Der Gag ist, dass du einfach mal eben schnell, wenn du jetzt erst wieder in Einstellungen gehen musst und das anmachen und so...
Dafür gibt es ja genau dieses Control Center.
Das macht ja total Sinn.
Ich hab jetzt gesagt, wir senden.
Also du schnippst einfach nur von unten dieses Control Center hoch und dann durchst du auf AirDrop und dann bist du quasi im Empfangsmodus.
Ich hab hier keinen AirDrop, also mein Phone ist vielleicht zu alt.
Das ist ein iPhone 5. Sie benutzen ein Feature von dem Radiochipset. Sie benutzen ein Feature von dem Radiochipset, wo sie sozusagen gleichzeitig mit mehreren SSIDs arbeiten können, ohne dich aus deinem WLAN rauszubuchen.
Genau, dazu brauchst du moderne WLAN-Hardware.
Es gibt noch ein paar spannende Sachen, die ich gefunden hab. Game Controller Framework ist jetzt... Ja, gibt jetzt eins, du kannst jetzt irgendwie Game Controller anfangen.
Das ist wirklich sehr interessant. Vor allem sprachen sie explizit von sowohl komplett externen Game Controllern, als auch von so wie drückten sie sich aus? Embedded oder sowas? Also entweder halt etwas, wo du dein iPhone reinsteckst, sowas gibt es wohl jetzt von Logitech, steckst es rein und das ganze Gerät wird quasi zu so einem Nintendo Device, mit Buttons drum herum.
So wie diese iPad Nintendo Box, wo man so eine Game Konsole hatte, wo man nur das iPad reinsteckt und dann hat man da Joystick und Buttons und so.
Genau, sowas. Und das dann eben auch für iPhone, iPad, was auch immer. Oder halt komplett externe Controller, die eben dann auch über Bluetooth zum Beispiel verbunden sein können. Da haben sie auch mit Bluetooth 4 jetzt auch eine ganze Menge gemacht. Da gibt es ja auch diese Beacons und keine Ahnung. Also auf jeden Fall scheinen sie da sehr auf die Tube zu drücken und das wird natürlich einen komplett neuen Markt eröffnen, dass du jetzt alle möglichen Game Controller haben kannst und sie bemühen sich, sagen sie, da von vornherein eine möglichst große Kompatibilität herzustellen, dass du quasi nicht dein Programm für einen bestimmten Game Controller, den du dann erkennst, machst, sondern dass eben diese Controls in gewisser Hinsicht normiert sind, also was weiß ich, User 1, User 2 und dann halt diese typischen Joysticks und so weiter.
Das sieht auch so aus, das User-Interface.
Und dann baust du es halt in dein Programm ein und dann ist es eigentlich egal, was du dir da für einen Controller kaufst, also nicht vollkommen egal, du musst natürlich die Buttons haben, aber wenn er eben dann diese entsprechenden Buttons hat, in einer bestimmten Anordnung, dann kannst du das eben benutzen. Das ist natürlich cool. Erstens kannst du auf so einem Alport Touch dann eben so eine vollwertige mobile Spielkonsole bauen. Kannst es ja auch drin lassen sozusagen, wenn du eh die ganze Zeit nur am Daddeln bist. Beziehungsweise kannst du eben auch noch so fancy Controller bauen. Das ist natürlich auch gerade interessant im Hinblick auf Apple TV.
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. So, dann hab ich was gefunden, wo ich dachte so, Aua, es gibt irgendwie ein Movieplayer-Framework und da gibt's einen Movieplayer-Controller. Und da hab ich einen Pfeil gefunden, das nennt sich IAD Pre-Roll. Auf gut Deutsch, man wird wohl in der Lage sein, in nicht allzu nahe Zukunft zu einem Video, das ich zeige, mir noch eine IAD als Pre-Roll dazu zu machen, damit ich darüber dann Video-Werbung bekomme. JavaScript-Core. Fand ich sehr spannend. Also als Erklärung, wenn ich JavaScript machen möchte, in irgendeinem Programm gab es bisher eigentlich nur die Möglichkeit, ich mach mir ein Webview und bastel da mein JavaScript rein und sag dann dem Webview hier, ruf mal die Funktion in meinem Webview auf. Muss da nicht zu sehen sein, aber in dem Webview läuft dann das JavaScript. Und es gibt jetzt ein Framework, das halt JavaScript kann, wie gut das ist und ob das jetzt irgendwie auf einem Background-Thread laufen kann und so weiter.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel JavaScript benutzen, um deine eigene abzuskripten.
Ja, also du hast dann scheinbar, also wie gesagt, ich hab mir nur die APIs angeguckt, also du hast dann scheinbar tatsächlich eine ganze Scripting-Engine, die du halt dann so benutzen kannst als Embedded Scripting-Engine und hast nicht mehr dieses Ding, ich mach mir jetzt so eine Seite, wo ein Skript drin ist und ruf das auf und es funktioniert nur auf dem Main-Thread und so. Also das fand ich sehr interessant. Bei Maps kann ich jetzt auf das Routing und die Kamera zugreifen, also Kamera in dem Sinne, wenn ich eine 3D-Ansicht habe, dann kann ich die Kamera in der 3D-Ansicht irgendwie positionieren, kann Snapshot machen. So vom Programmieren her.
Kann so was abfotografieren aus der Welt.
Ja, quasi.
Aus der virtuellen Welt.
SpriteKit. Um 2D-Games zu machen.
Gute Idee.
Ja, da ist ja vor allem eine ganze Menge mehr drin. Da ist ja, also SpriteKit, das umfasst einerseits natürlich das Malen von Sprites, also typisch, also ein Sprite ist halt ein sich bewegendes Ding, so dein Spielmännchen, das Monster, was du abschießen musst.
Die Dinger, die sie halt auf dem C64 bewegt haben.
Genau, da hieß es auch schon Sprite. Aber ihr SpriteKit geht halt noch über das Malen hinaus. Also abgesehen davon, dass du natürlich, wenn du das SpriteKit benutzt, möglichst effiziente Routinen, die dann eben direkt an die Grafikkarte andocken benutzt und da nicht tausend Layer dazwischen hast, die nur zu viel Strom verbrauchen, hast du auch noch so eine komplette Physix-Engine mit drin. Das heißt, du hast auch so keine Ahnung, was das alles abdeckt, aber halt Gravity und Impulse und irgendwie ein Magnetismus. Das kommt noch dazu. Dann hast du so eine Particle-Engine. Das heißt, du kannst eben auch sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne mal hier tausend Sternchen und mit der und der Translucency und schick die mal hier so von links nach rechts und zieh mal ein Schleier. Und was war da noch?
Irgendwie, du kannst es in jedem Maße machen und die gegeneinander rotieren und sonst was kannst du irgendwie noch machen.
Ja, das ist ja dann zwangsläufig bei Physik. Achso, und der ganze Climb-Bim ist halt direkt in Xcode eingebaut. Du kannst das sozusagen direkt da previewen.
Aber wie gesagt, alles 2D.
Ja, aber es reicht ja wirklich für die allermeisten Games. Er hat als Beispiel so Angry Birds und der kleine Vogel. Also viele Sachen. Wer ist noch gleich hier, das Vogelspiel? Little Wings. Tiny Wings. Genau, so war es. Ich meine, viele extrem populäre Titel sind einfach nur nochmal 2D und das Minimum so an 3D. Das ist geil. Das heißt, du kannst einfache Games noch sehr viel einfacher machen.
Gut, sollen wir mal noch ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen?
Bitte.
Audio hat sich nicht viel geändert.
Na doch, sie haben jetzt diesen Audiobus ins OS drin. Du hast jetzt so Inter-Up-Audio.
Ja, aber nicht in den... Also, ich habe jetzt keine großen neuen Apis gesehen. Gut, da war was mit Audio-Cue und so weiter, aber das muss man sich sowieso in Ruhe ansehen, um zu verstehen, was da passiert ist. Also, Audio-APIs sind halt immer so ein bisschen...
Na gut, aber du kannst jetzt mehrere Programme gleichzeitig zusammen, sich gegenseitig Sound zu schicken und abspielen und so weiter.
Ja, Audio-Cue, wie gesagt, da ist das glaube ich drin.
Audiobus?
Ja, aber die API heißt Audio-Cue. NS-Data ist in Coco ein Objekt, wo man einfach Daten rein speichern kann. Kann jetzt Base64 out of the box. Yeah, endlich mal. NS-Array ist in Coco ein Container für einen Array. Und es gab schon immer, also seit Next-Step-Zeiten quasi, eine Methode, die hieß Last Object. Die hat einem entweder das letzte Objekt oder nil zurückgegeben, wenn das Ding leer war. Es gab nie eine First Object Methode. Und die gibt es jetzt. Sowohl in 10, 9 als auch in iOS 7. Das ist so was, wo ich dachte, das werde ich nicht mehr erleben, dass die das machen.
Ich hab immer überlegt, warum das so ist. Aber es ist eigentlich ganz logisch, weil für Last Object müsstest du erst noch mit Count, also mit einem weiteren Call, die Länge von deinem Array holen. Aber First Object kannst du einfach immer eine Null eintragen. Das heißt, du brauchst da keinen weiteren Call. Und deswegen braucht man auch nicht wirklich First Object. Deswegen Object.Index.Null war immer auch instant. Und deswegen dachte ich, ist schon okay so.
Du musst noch prüfen, ob das Array leer ist. Weil du sonst eine Exception kriegst. This changes absolutely everything. Also ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich das noch erlebe, dass Apple tatsächlich...
Weißt du, was aber die größte Scheiße ist an diesen geilen neuen Features, weil gerade auch mit dem Basechen 60 dachte ich, oh geil, da kann ich ja so ein bisschen Code in meinen Tools erschlagen. Und was ist, ist natürlich ab 10.9 und musst wieder erstmal für die nächsten 5 Jahre noch mit rumschleppen und erst dann irgendwann, wenn das Programm überhaupt so lange lebt, erst dann kannst du den Scheiß entfernen. Weil alten Scheiß entfernen ist eigentlich das, was am meisten Spaß macht, wenn man Code oder alten Scheiß rausschmeißt.
Einfach, einfach deprecateen. Einfach rauswerfen.
Erzähl das mal deinem Kunden, ey.
Das kann man sich nicht immer aussuchen, leider, leider. Und dann gibt es etwas, was ich sehr spannend fand. Also es gibt einen neuen Typ, der nennt sich Instance Type. Und zwar, den gibt es eigentlich auch schon jetzt, aber... Machen wir's mal, machen wir's mal anders. In Coco, wenn ein Objekt, also wenn du einen Pointer auf ein Objekt hast, dann ist es entweder ein Pointer genau auf die Klasse des Objekts, oder aber es ist ein Pointer, also ein Id-Pointer, so genannt er, der zeigt halt auf irgendein Objekt. Und wenn du, ähm... Auf eine Instanz von einem Objekt, genau. Und wenn du bisher ein Objekt kreiert hast, dann hießen das, also gab's einen Aufruf Alloc, um einen Speicher zu allokieren, und Init, um das Objekt zu initialisieren und alles fein zu machen. Und dann hast du zum Schluss das Objekt zurückgekriegt. Beide Alloc wie Init waren vom Rückgabetyp Id, also irgendein Objekt. Aber der Compiler war bei diesen beiden Funktionen immer schlau genug, zu checken, also zu wissen, dass nur ein Objekt eines bestimmten Typs rauskommen kann, weil ich ja genau dieses Objekt gerade angelegt hab. Und hat deswegen alles, was ich mit dem, was da rauskam, was angefangen hat, konnte er checken, ob es die Methode überhaupt funktioniert. Ob es die Methode kippt von dem Objekt, das ich gerade angelegt hab. Wenn ich jetzt eine andere Methode kreiert hab auf einem Objekt, das Id zurückkippt, dann war das wirklich nur ein Pointer und der Compiler konnte nicht checken, was ist das jetzt?
Mit Id meinste ID, was man als ID immer schreibt. Genau, ID. Der Placeholder für alle möglichen Klassen.
Genau. Und es gibt jetzt diesen Rückgabewert, InstanceType heißt der. Und der sagt explizit, hier kommt ein Objekt zurück von dem Typ dieser Klasse, das dieses Objekt zurückgibt. Und dann kann der Compiler auch checken, ob das alles so seine Richtigkeit hat. Und das haben sie jetzt, also diesen InstanceType, den gibt es irgendwie schon unter 10.8 und unter iOS 6 und unter iOS 5 und weiß ich nicht.
Das ist ein eigener Method oder was, mit dem man es checken kann oder wie?
Nee, das ist ein Typ, den der Compiler kennt. Den kannst du halt verwenden.
Keine 20 Jahre nach Apple döhnen, kommt dieses Feature dann auch mal in C.
Tja, kannst mal sehen. Auf jeden Fall haben sie jetzt quasi im Großen und Ganzen bei allen Klassen die diesen Instant-Type, bei allen Klassen, wo bisher was zurückgegeben wurde, aber es IT markiert war, haben sie jetzt diesen Instant-Type reingemacht und dann rekompilierst du deinen Code und merkst, oh Mann, da ist ja richtig viel falsch, weil du irgendwie Funktionen aufrufst, die es eigentlich nicht gibt, aber dann doch.
So ein berühmter Fehler ist immer, dass man irgendwo was mit mutable macht und dann das aber als Dings weitergibt oder eher andersrum noch.
Genau, und diese Sachen findet er jetzt. Also dieser Instance-Type, das ist echt eine geile Sache. Ach ja, hier zitiert gerade jemand, Ennis Hipster, da gab es auch mal so einen Hinweis auf Instance-Type. Also wie gesagt, unter Mavericks und iOS 7 gibt es jetzt Instance-Type für viele, viele Objekte von Coco und der Compiler findet viel Mist. Ich bin dafür. Habe ich jetzt alle platt geredet?
Ja, ich kann eigentlich nicht so viel zu sagen, aber ich finde es schön, dass du das wertschätzen kannst, dass es auch so auf den allerniedrigsten Ebenen Verbesserungen gibt, das ist ja nicht ganz unwichtig.
Noch kurze Frage, Roddy, weil du bist der Experte, hast anscheinend mehr Zeit, dich da rein zu formulieren als ich. Wir haben ja vorhin kurz hier das State of the Union irgendwie gesehen. Da hat er noch kurz irgendwas von irgendwie ARK erzählt, das mit den schicken Balken und so. Gab es da auch irgendwelche Neuigkeiten eigentlich?
Ist mir nichts aufgefallen, also er hat halt behauptet Xcode wäre jetzt in ARK. Vorher war Xcode...
Achso Xcode selbst, verstehe, okay.
Ja, Xcode selbst war ja vorher noch garbage collected. Das haben sie zwar deprecated, aber sie haben es dann doch irgendwie für Xcode noch verwendet. Jetzt haben sie Xcode wohl in ARK umgebaut und jetzt soll es gleich viel schneller sein. Man macht ja sowas nur, um hinterher gleich viel schneller zu sein. Keine Ahnung.
Und ist die garbage collection jetzt auch abgeschaltet? Gibt es das jetzt nicht mehr?
Seit 10.8 ist sie deprecated. Ob sie in 10.9 noch drin ist, das habe ich jetzt noch nicht geprüft. Aber ich denke, sie wird noch drin sein.
Das würde ja bedeuten, dass alte Software aufhört zu funktionieren.
Also wenn du es...
Also die garbage collection war ja jetzt eh nicht so der Brüller-Erfolg, muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Haben nicht so viele benutzt.
Haben nicht so viele benutzt, weil es ja dann doch eher nicht so deterministisch war, was der garbage collector so tut, obwohl der relativ gut funktioniert hat. Aber es gab da Leute, die haben sich da die Karten mitgelegt.
Ja, aber die hatten sich auch mit einem anderen die Karten gelegt.
Eventuell.
Ja, das sind diese ganzen fremde Programmiersprachen-Coder, die irgendwie merken, bei Iphone oder IOS ist gerade da, da schwimmt die Welle irgendwie, da geht's ab. Da arbeiten wir mal da und kommen da mit dem Java-Wissen und denken so, ja geil, Garbage Collection und legen los.
Gut, also die Garbage Collection gab's nie unter IOS. Ich weiß nicht, was da jetzt State of the Union ist bei der Garbage Collection, aber die ist jetzt vorbei.
Müll wird nicht mehr weggebracht.
Haben wir jetzt eigentlich schon alles durch?
Doch, der Compiler bringt den Müll weg, aber zur Laufzeit.
Also ich hätte ja gedacht, dass man mehr reden kann über IOS 7.
Zur Compile-Zeit bringt er meinen Müll weg.
Haben wir was vererren?
Das würde mich jetzt sehr erstaunen.
Also das erste ist, er baut den Code ein, dass der Müll später weggebracht wird, so rum.
Also ich meine, wir können jetzt natürlich nochmal auflisten, was ist alles neu, aber das ist jetzt irgendwie, die meisten werden es sich wahrscheinlich eh schon angeguckt haben.
Ja, hat das jemand verstanden, was das ist? Das ist so Last FM oder was?
Ja, das scheint so eine Art Mischung aus Genius Playlist und Last FM zu sein. Und Spotify, irgendwie sowas.
Über Spotify kannst du ja alles Mögliche hören.
Hier kannst du auch gerade Dinge zusammenstellen.
Da kannst du auch alles Mögliche hören. Er macht so Genius-mäßig so nach der Art, der Song gefällt mir nicht, aber den finde ich gut oder ich will jetzt mehr auf Basis dieses Songs hören.
Oder war da diese Trihanna Radio oder sowas, dass er sagt, die sind jeden Artist?
Ja, aber das ist ja so wie bei Last FM. Das heißt, du sagst nur, was du für eine Playlist oder was für einen Artist du hören willst und er sucht dann für dich aus, was als Nächstes kommt.
Ja, aber passend dazu. Also es ist wohl so ein Genius-Ding. Weißt du, du suchst einen Artist aus und er spielt dir auch andere Artists, die aber so ähnliche Musiken irgendwie so. Also so hab ich's verstanden, keine Ahnung.
Ja, Leute, die das hier kauften, kauften auch.
Genau.
Also so ein Shopping-Feature.
Genau, und du kannst dann immer gucken, was hast du denn gehört, dann kannst du es dann gleich irgendwie wegshoppen.
Du kannst dann sozusagen stundenlang dein Telefon da rumspielen lassen, dann hörst du irgendwie Rihanna Radio und fragst dich auch, was eigentlich abgeht. Ja, dann gibt's hier irgendwie Siri mit irgendwie komischer Optik und neuer Stimme.
Also wir haben ja letztes Mal darüber schon gesprochen, sprechen wir mit unserem Telefon. Ich hab irgendwie Siri jetzt auf der neuen Version einmal ausprobiert und er hat mir dann, Siri hat irgendwie auf Deutsch eine nicht sagende Antwort gegeben und auf Englisch dann vorgeschlagen, was ich denn alles auf Englisch sagen könnte. Also es war broken. Aber das ist vielleicht auch einfach ein Developer Preview Problem.
Ja, das ist immer die Hoffnung, aber meistens ist ja nicht der Fall.
Die Hoffnung stimmt, aber zuletzt.
Du, ich würd's wahrscheinlich auch nicht verwenden, wenn's besser funktionieren würde. Insofern interessiert mich das jetzt auch nicht.
Gibt eine Sache, da benutze ich Siri viel mehr neulich in der Diskussion, als ich es neulich mal wieder benutzt habe, da funktioniert es ausnahmsweise richtig gut. Im Auto eine rufnummer wählen. Also jetzt draufdrücken und sagen, ruf mal den an mobile. Die Erkennungsrate ist bei mir extrem hoch. Also er trifft immer die richtige Nummer.
Ich kenn diese Erfahrung noch nicht ein einziges Mal in meinem Leben. Ja, dass ich sage, ruf an Personen und dass dann diese Person auch wirklich kommt.
Nee, ich sag sogar diese Person mobile, damit er mich dann gar nicht erst würde fragen, welche von den 20 Nummern und so.
Ja, aber der ruf dann immer, also immer, wenn ich das ausprobiert habe, ist so, hat sich dann irgendeiner rausgesucht, wo so ein Typ hochkommt, nicht auf gar keinen Fall, wo ich auch nicht auch nur in die Situation kommen möchte, zu erklären, warum ich den jetzt angerufen habe.
Du hast 4000 Leute im Adressbuch und der matchte einfach schlecht und wahrscheinlich hat Clemens irgendwie nur 5 Leute und dann ist...
Nee, knapp 800 oder so.
Auch so viele, verdammt. Vielleicht ist dein Auto zu laut, Tim, und Clemens hat ein Leichtes Auto.
Das soll wieder aufräumen.
Das passiert auch ohne Auto.
Nee, sind nur 752, aber trotzdem. Das soll wieder aufräumen.
Angeblich geht iOS Serie jetzt auch auf dem iPhone 4.
Wat?
Nee, habt ihr letztens schon unsere Liste gesehen.
Ja, aber vielleicht hattet Developer Preview einen Bug, dass das da geht. Das wär natürlich peinlich, wenn sie jetzt alle anzufixen, um den Zeichen, so würde es sein, wenn ihr euch ein neues iPhone holt. Wenn es aber super funktioniert, dann haben sie später echte Erklärungsprobleme, warum sie es nicht regulär anmachen.
Ja, dann machen sie es regulär.
Wenn du es jetzt einmal anmachst, dann kannst du es nie wieder ausmachen. Aber das wär echt ein cooler Bug.
Wenn sie es jetzt aber anmachen, wie erklären sie, dass sie es nicht vorher angemacht haben?
Das sowieso noch. Aber das jetzt wieder auszumachen, mit der dusseligen Begründung, ein iPhone 4 kann das nicht, wäre das doch echt.
Dass es sowieso könnte, wissen wir doch alle, oder?
Aber wenn sie es jetzt Apple selber anmacht und es geht, dann haben sie ein Problem.
Da steht doch Quatsch, Siri geht erst ab iPhone 4S.
Ja, schreibt das jemand, der einen C-Lion drauf hat? Oder schreibt das jemand, der bloß mal wieder Marketingmaterial von vor drei Wochen gelesen hat? Also das Ding heißt nicht C-Lion, sieben Lion. Ich weiß. Sieben Lion.
Was hast du dann, 4 oder 4S? Und hast du da Siri?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe es versucht, aber ja.
Mittel.
Also genauso schlecht wie vorher.
Ich hatte das Gefühl schlechter, aber es ist so...
Jetzt holen wir Leute vom Bahnhof ab. Tim knallt eh schon mit dem Kopf auf die Tastatur.
Sind wir denn glücklich?
Womit? Aller sieben?
Insgesamt.
Die Frage haben wir doch schon verneint.
Du meinst, wir würden jetzt mal sagen, die Optik ist uns jetzt mal egal, ob wir dann happy sind?
Ne, mir geht's jetzt gar nicht mal nur um iOS 7. Das trifft einen natürlich ein bisschen hart.
Ne, dich nur.
Ich find das shocking. Ich find das auch shocking.
Schocking?
Ich bin noch ein Schockstache, und zwar hochkant.
Ich glaub, so ne Leute nennt man konservativ, die sich von ihrem alten Scheiß nicht trennen können.
Ja, genau. Ich hab ein Cutting-Zöpfe since the early beginning. Ich hab nur Interesse an der Zukunft, aber ich find das ist halt ein Rückschritt.
Vielleicht bin ich alt geworden und find's deswegen hässlich, aber es hat halt auch so Issues.
Was wär denn der Vorschritt gewesen?
Na, fix die Sachen, die wirklich kaputt waren. Und ich fand halt jetzt so an den ganzen Icon-Klimbim war jetzt meiner Meinung nach nichts falsch. Und auch an den Buttons fand ich jetzt nichts falsch. So Sachen wie diese Multitasking-Sachen, diese ganzen anderen Hood-Sachen und Maps besser und so weiter.
Eben mal ein ordentliches WebOS-Modus.
Ja, also das ist einfach auch dieses ja, dieses hin und her-Switchen zwischen den Ups mit den Previews und so. Das sind ja alles ordentliche Sachen. Und hätten sie jetzt diesen Cleanup da weggelassen, ich meine, da steckt ja noch mehr hinter. Es ist ja nicht nur so ein Facelift. Sie haben ja da so ein, dieses Multilayer-Modell. Und wenn du jetzt so ein Overlay hast, der sich rüberzieht, dann deaktivieren sich auch diese Buttons, dadurch, dass sie halt dann eben die Farbe entziehen. Also da steckt schon auch eine gewisse Logik drin. Das Ganze geht jetzt nur einher mit einem recht fundamentalen Redesign, wo sie eben auf diese ganze luftige Sache da gemacht haben. Ich glaube, das sind eher so diese viel Text-Buttons und so weiter, die mich irgendwie stören. Also das ist nicht rund.
Ich finde das überhaupt nicht luftig. Ich finde das ganz im Gegenteil, ich finde das total überladen, dadurch, dass es so unstrukturiert ist. Ich finde das extrem viel anstrengender.
Die Elemente untereinander, die sind dann wiederum zu crumpt.
Ich finde es total anstrengend, dass es keine Struktur mehr hat. Das macht mich kirre irgendwie.
Das finde ich ja nicht. Ich finde ja gerade hier die Einstellungen. Ich habe das Gefühl, da sind sie einigermaßen fertig. Das sieht sehr aufgeräumt aus.
Die Einstellungen sind das einzige Beispiel, das ich wirklich gelten lasse.
Vielleicht ist noch nicht alles fertig, ne, Peter?
Ja, aber ich meine, du kennst doch Apple. Also da geht es jetzt hin.
Ja, aber ich finde mal hier so eine neue Optik finde ich jetzt auch mal nicht so falsch. Ich bin auch ein paar Sachen gefallen mir auch noch nicht, aber es könnte halt auch sein, dass ich es mit den nächsten Betas alles noch ein bisschen mehr aufräumt, abhebe.
Schau mal, trotzdem, ich bin ein bisschen geschockt. Also vor allem, weil ich mich wirklich frage, wie kann es sein, dass so hässliche Icons da rauskommen? Das ist für mich einfach so ein Warning Sign, dass irgendwas falsch läuft.
Vielleicht geht es nicht anders, wenn man so ein vollflaches OS haben will mit irgendwie Layers und Zeug, dann hätten die anderen Icons nicht mehr gepasst. Vielleicht kann ja einer mal so einen Mockup machen, wie es aussehen würde, wenn man auf der einen Seite so alles voll und flach.
Das Schlimme ist, die bisherigen Vorschläge im Web, wie man die Icons noch hübscher machen könnte, die waren noch hässlicher. Also mit wenigen Ausnahmen.
Tja, dann hat es halt deinen Geschmack nicht getroffen. Aber wie es halt immer so ist mit Geschmack, da kann man nicht alle zufriedenstellen.
Sind wir denn jetzt insgesamt zufrieden? Wir haben jetzt monatelang gedarbt.
Das ist ja eigentlich nichts da.
Ich sag mal so, Mavericks bin ich zufrieden. Ja, ich auch. Kein Problem. Also das ist eine super Sache. Wenn sie jetzt nicht irgendwas kaputt spielen, irgendwas wichtig ist, dann...
Du könnt noch mal V6...
Du hast ja gesagt, dass ein iChat den Videoquack da rausgemacht haben.
Dann muss ich ja noch mal...
Du musst unbedingt jetzt mal ein paar Developer noch mal diese V6-Sache stecken, weil jetzt wird finalisiert. Jetzt werden die Bugs noch gefixt.
Keine Sauer interessiert, keine Sauer. Die ist ja schon seit Ewigkeiten drin. Ist oft hier noch angesagt worden und gibt offene Cases bei Apple und sie machen es immer noch nicht ganz. Was soll ich jetzt dazu noch sagen?
Keine Ahnung. Erklär doch mal, was nicht funktioniert. Dann können alle Developer, die hier zuhören, noch mal schnell in den Pack fallen.
Sie können es doch gerne alle noch mal selber ausprobieren. Aber ich hab jetzt hier mal kurz ausprobiert auf den diversen Seelöwen, die hier rumfliegen oder Siebenlöwen oder so.
Wie, konnte man da gerade Apps doch killen, die nach oben ziehen oder wie? Ja, das ist so eine Sache, woher soll man das wissen?
Clemens versucht gerade zu erklären, was wichtig ist für die Zukunft.
Ja, nicht für die Zukunft. Aber wir haben jetzt 2013, ja, wir haben jetzt IPv6, der hinter uns ewig. Google macht IPv6, also 40 Prozent des Internets macht IPv6. Und Apple kriegt das immer noch nicht geregelt, IPv6 richtig über das VPN zu machen. Ich hab jetzt mal nochmal wieder probiert, zum Beispiel PPTP, das ist ein Protokoll, was von Hause aus IPv6 kann. Das iPhone holt sich auch, also teilt auch seine Link-Local-Adresse meinem VPN-Server mit und sagt meinem VPN-Server, geil, ich bin dein Router. Du sollst keine anderen Router haben neben mir. Hier ist dein Global-Prefix. Und sowohl der Telefon als auch der Siebenlöwe oder der Sea Lion sagen, schön.
Interessiert mich nicht, geh weg.
Ich interessiere mich für Fische. Dabei ist es so simpel, so, so, so, so super simpel. Und der nächste Schritt wäre jetzt, selbst wenn man das nicht kriegt, sich per DRCPv6 einzuholen, Präfix auch, das tut das nicht. Das heißt, die machen VPN auf, was v6 kann, machen so ein bisschen halb v6 und dann hören sie damit auf. In 2013, das finde ich einfach peinlich. Wir werden es sehen.
Okay, also alle Developer, bitte ein Bug-File, ein VPN mit IPv6 geht nicht.
Es ist bestimmt irgendwo eine halbe Scheißzeile, die sagt, bitte hier, das Router-Advertisement, nimmet doch, mach doch was damit, oder? IF Interface-Type gleich Point-to-Point PPP, dann fuck der Router-Advertisement, oder? Ich hab keine Ahnung, aber das kann ich nicht sagen. Wahrscheinlich, ich muss mal gucken, wie ist eigentlich hier Ihr Chef-Developer? Apple stellt ja gelegentlich mal wieder so ihren Darwin-Könnel mit so ein paar Sachen in so eine Open-Source-Schmuddelecke, die sie irgendwo zu laufen haben. Aber immerhin, ist das einigermaßen recent? Glaubt ihr, dass man da jetzt, wenn ich da mal hingreife jetzt mal wieder, dass ich denn noch was kriege, was so mit Seelöwen zu tun hat?
Das machen sie üblicherweise erst, wenn das tatsächlich released wird.
Oder wenn es schon obsolete ist. Wenn sie es releasen, dann tun sie es draus.
Wenn sie es releasen, dann... Es kann auch ein paar Wochen Verspätung haben, aber sie releasen das... Also sie schmeißen das nicht raus, wenn sie noch keine finale Version haben.
Aber ihr könnt ja trotzdem mal jetzt mal für den normalen Löwen mal gucken, mal runterladen, mal mehrere Stelle Suche im Code. Das kann echt nicht so schwer sein.
Tun sie sich keinen Zwang an, der Herr.
Wie ist eigentlich, hat jemand von euch jemals mal einen Bug-Report gefeiert an Apple? Und, haben sie was damit gemacht? Oder ist er direkt nach Def Null gegangen?
Also sagen wir mal so, es gibt Bug-Reports, es gibt drei Arten von Bug-Reports. Welche, die bleiben offen bis zum Sankt-Nimmerleins-Tag. Die werden dann irgendwann in Old Bugs verschoben, wenn sie so fünf Jahre alt sind oder so. Dann gibt es die Bug-Reports, die werden direkt als Duplicate geflaggt. Wobei du dir den Original-Bug nicht angucken kannst. Und dann gibt es die Bug-Reports, wo tatsächlich was passiert. Nach variabler Zeit. Also das schnellste, was ich je hatte, waren sechs Wochen von Pfeilen bis Fix. Das langsamste waren, glaube ich, drei Jahre oder so.
Aber sie gucken da drauf.
Die gucken da drauf, ja. Also wenn du einen pfeilst, dann gibt es mindestens einen Schergen, der da drauf guckt.
Aber gegebenenfalls auch maximal.
Manchmal ist es so, dass sie tatsächlich, also die Anzahl der Bugreports halt auch als Meter benutzen, wie wichtig ist den Leuten da draußen der Bug. Also es ist nicht so, dass wenn einer ein Bugreport pfeilt, dass sie es dann irgendwann fixen, sondern wenn 1000 ein Bugreport pfeilen oder 2000, dann ist es schon eine andere Aussage, als wenn es nur 5 tun. Ja, machst du so einen Mechanical Turk auf und dann... Aber ich glaube, du musst kein registrierter Developer sein, um ein Bug feilen zu können. Also du musst keinen bezahlten Account haben. Du musst einen Account haben, aber keinen bezahlten. Glaube ich.
Muss mal gucken. Ich frage deswegen, weil ich habe die dumme Angewohnheit, dass ich das bei Firmen mit denen das erstmal zu tun habe, ich glaube immer noch an das Gute in solchen Firmen und werde aber sehr häufig enttäuscht. Ja, ich mache dann wirklich Analysen und Traces und schmeiße damit rein und ich bin ja schon happy, wenn überhaupt mal jemand reagiert. Manche reagieren überhaupt nicht auf irgendwas, was da definitiv kaputt ist. Was dann immer so ist, ja gut, dann hörst du halt damit auf. Und Apple, ich stelle mir halt einfach vor, Apple ist halt so ein riesen Laden mit Millionen von Developern, die da irgendwelchen Quack machen. Deswegen wollte ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen meine Chancen eingeschätzt sehen, wenn ich denen jetzt mal einen ordentlichen Trace um die Ohren haue und vielleicht sogar noch wie einen Patch oder sonst irgendwas, ob die da wirklich jetzt mitmachen oder ob ich mir die Arbeit auch sparen kann.
Also meine eigene Erfahrung als Developer ist natürlich, wenn du einen Bug gefilzt bekommst, wo jemand sagt, das geht nicht, irgendwas geht nicht, dann machst du dafür mit nichts. Wenn jemand einen Beispielcode hat oder ein Beispiel hat, was wirklich 100% reproduzierbar ist, dann bist du an einer Stelle, wo du dann kannst du das angucken und siehst, oh ja geht nicht, da müssen wir mal was machen. Gut, dann gibt es immer noch den Chef, der sagt, das ist nicht wichtig, die drei Leute, die das Problem haben, die interessieren uns nicht, das kann passieren. Aber du bist zumindest mal an der Stelle, wo du sagst, ich bin in der Lage, das zu debuggen und das zu lösen.
Sie machen halt die Hälfte davon, weißt du, wenn sie jetzt in der PPP Newsation V6 komplett ablehnen würden, würde ich sagen, okay, das ist zwar auch lame, aber ist okay. Aber jetzt einen V6-Link zu etablieren und dann nicht den nächsten Schritt zu gehen, den sie ja implementiert haben, weil auf dem Ethernet geht es ja und im WLAN. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie nicht wüssten, wie man Router-Advanteils mit dekodiert oder sich per DRCP noch was holt, DRCP V6. Nur halt eben auf so einer VPN-Verbindung machen sie den ersten Schritt und dann hören sie, uff, so, hm. Ich kalt das mal für einen Bug.
Also es ist natürlich immer gut, wenn man noch relativ wasserdicht argumentieren kann, warum man der Meinung ist, dass es ein Bug ist und warum man der Meinung ist, dass ein Problem ist, das gelöst gehört.
Meine Begründung ist, braucht 4 Zeichen. 2, 0, 1, 3.
Wenn du jetzt ein Bug feilen würdest und sagst, bei iOS 7 sehen die Buttons scheiße aus, dann kann jeder hingehen und sagen, wieso? Sehen doch gut aus. Close. Weißt du, wenn du jetzt sagst, das und das geht nicht aus dem und dem Grund und das ist ein Problem, weil man kann einen Tunnel nicht mit IPv6 benutzen, dann ist es relativ klar, dass es ein Bug ist.
Also du sagst jetzt, ich soll mich das mal trauen, mir mal einen Nachmittag gönnen, mal Traces generieren, schöne Briefchen aufsetzen und das da mal reintun, weil würde am Ende des Tages wirklich jemand lesen.
Lesen tut das auf jeden Fall jemand, ja. Also wenn es jetzt nicht ein größeres technisches Problem gibt, warum das nicht geht.
Die sagt, da hat es ja schon ewig drin. Das kann ich mir auch einen alten Darwin-Können-Marzinen mal drinnen rumstochen, gucken, wo da die Exclusion dafür ist oder so.
Also ich finde jetzt nicht, dass da was dagegen spricht. Also bei Apple Bugs muss man halt auch ein bisschen Geduld haben, weißt du. Wenn du das jetzt gegen 10.8 feilst, kann das sein, dass das mit 10.9.1 oder 10.9.2 dann mal gefixt ist.
Reagieren die vorher? Reagieren die, dass sie dir sagen, ja, das ist ein Bug, haben wir verstanden, kriegen wir jetzt nicht gefixt?
Nee, die reagieren dann, wenn sie noch eine Nachfrage haben.
Aber sonst ist das so ein One-Way. Sie sagen dir auch nicht, hallo, ich habe jetzt deinen Bug gefixt, sondern du findest es irgendwann selber raus, dass er irgendwann weg ist oder was?
Der geht irgendwann auf Closed. Nein, es kann dir passieren, dass sie dir schreiben so nach der Art, hallo, wir haben da diese Beta, lad die mal runter und prüfe mal nach, ob der Bug noch drin ist. Wir sind der Meinung, wir hätten ihn gefixt. Das kann dir passieren.
Ich hab mal vor, keine Ahnung, zu 10.1 oder 10.0 Zeiten, ich glaube 10.1 eher, hingeschrieben, dass wenn man in den Screensaver so ein paar Hundert Zeichen eingibt und dann Return drückt, dass der Screensaver, also auch das Locking abstürzt und man dann in den Rechner reinkommt. Und dann ist eine Weile nichts passiert. Und dann auf einmal kam eine Mail, dass sie das jetzt gefixt hätten, das auch in die Security Notes aufnehmen würden und da sie aus meiner Mail aber nur meinen höchstwahrscheinlichen Vornamen entnehmen können, ob sie dann noch den Rest davon haben könnten, damit sie es ordentlich in die Security Notes irgendwie reinschreiben könnten und ob das dann auch okay für mich wäre, hab ich zurückgeschrieben. Ja, ich heiße so und so und ist okay. Und ich steh da tatsächlich drin. Dabei hab ich das sogar eigentlich nur von jemand anderem aus dem Club, der es mir gezeigt hat, übernommen und hab den Bug-File reported.
Wo ist das gefixt worden?
Na, nach nächsten Security-Dings irgendwie. Hat schon ein paar Wochen gedauert, aber war da nach nächstem Jahr.
Ja, aber welches Release?
Weiß nicht mehr, 10.1 oder 10.2. Ganz früher. Da konnte man halt sozusagen Buffer-Overflow in dem Passwort-Input vom Screen-Log irgendwie machen.
Ach, von dir kam das?
Hatte einer im Club festgenommen. Ich glaube, es war außersehen. Da war irgendwas auf seiner Tastatur und hat einfach alles vollgemüllt. Und der sagte, was ist das? Und scheiße, drückt Return und PENG ist da drin. Irgendwie so. Und da hat der mir gesagt, ey, hier Dennis hier, was ist denn das? Und ich so, ja, alles klar, interessant, meinte er. Weil du mal, er hat keinen Bock. Packet war das.
Der hat mir das gezeigt. Weil jemand im Chat einen Link dazu geschickt hat, du kannst, es gibt so ein Tool, das nennt sich Open Raider, ist so ein freiwilligen Ding ins, du kannst also, wenn du bei Apple einen Bug gefilet hast, kannst du den gleichen Bug da nochmal reintun. Dann können andere Leute sehen, dass du den Bug gefilet hast. Und du kannst eben dort suchen, gibt es so einen Bug schon.
Hat sich nicht der Bug-Reporter jetzt sogar zu WWDC geändert? Ich hab irgendwas gelesen, dass sie da jetzt ein Update gefahren haben.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Früher ging alles zuerst bei Steve auf dem Bildschirm und wurden von dem dann irgendwie vorsortiert. Und da der das ja inzwischen nicht mehr macht, mussten sie sich jetzt umbauen.
Security Update 2003 0714. Also 14. Juli 2003. Fixes Can 2003 0518. Warum nicht 0815? A potential vulnerability when a password is required upon waking from the Screen Effects Feature, which could allow an unauthorized user access to the desktop of the logged-in user. Alter, du bist ja mal hier in den Release Notes. Der Mann aus den Security-Release Notes.
Ich hab auch, was hab ich noch gefeilt? Ich hab hier nämlich ne Menge mit den...
Schon wieder sind die Hacker-Cred hochgegangen.
Jens, ich möchte deinen Namen da auch gerne lesen.
Ich hab mich auch viel über den App-In Streaming-Server mit beschäftigt und den hab ich auch einige Bug-Fixes und Verbesserungen gesendet, auch gerade, dass das besser durch Natt durchgeht und so weiter. Da ist auch, glaub ich, irgendwie zweieinhalb Jahre nichts passiert und dann haben sie ja, glaub ich, den Streaming-Server aufgegeben und dann haben sie alles auf einmal reingeschoben. Also dann haben sie gesagt, hier alles rein und jetzt könnt ihr's haben und macht was ihr wollt.
Ich hab den noch nicht mal runtergeladen, damit ein bisschen gespielt. In dieser Open Source-Schmuddelecke, wo sie auch den Source haben für Darwin, da in derselben Ecke lungertet rum.
Und da hab ich auch einen Bug fix, da konntest du in deinem Movie, konntest du die Metadaten in irgendein Special-Zeichen größer 128 reinmachen und dann ist der Server gecrashed, weil die Metadaten gepasst hat. Und den haben sie auch relativ schnell gefixt, weil das halt auf Server-Seite das Ding halt crashen lassen, also der war schneller gefixt. Aber meine Netfixes, die waren richtig cool. Mein Streaming-Server konnte weiter streamen, obwohl die Telekom mir unter dem Arsch die Adresse gewechselt hat. Das hat mein Streaming-Server nicht interessiert, hat einfach weiter gepostet und der Server hat es weiter angenommen. Das war mein richtig cooler Fix.
Damals noch.
Aber wenn ich mal wieder Sorgen mit dem Ding habe, weiß ich, wen ich anrufe.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt alles gesagt. Zumindest alles, was uns einfällt.
Aber die Frage, ob wir jetzt glücklich sind, ist immer noch nicht abschließend geklärt worden. Also wir sind partiell glücklich, dass überhaupt was passiert ist.
Also Hardware-Updates gehen irgendwie okay schon. Mit dem Mac Pro muss man mal gucken. Ich will das Ding mal sehen.
Naja, noch ist er nicht draußen.
Und vor allem will ich mal sehen, was man jetzt für PCI-Karten, wie viele Tausend Euro man hinlegen muss, um eine PCI-Karte in so einen Computer reinzustecken. Und ich wollte schon noch ein paar da reinstecken.
Vielleicht kaufst du einfach eine tolle Audiokarte mit Thunderbolt und sparst dir diesen ganzen Blech mit nach PCI gebastelt Fummel.
Zeig mir mal eine tolle Audiokarte mit Thunderbolt.
Vielleicht gibt es ja sowas dann wieder.
Du hast wahrscheinlich auch allein wegen Verwendung des Thunderbolt-Chips nochmal 300 Euro extra. Weil das irgendwie die Intel-Steuer ist. Na ja, wie auch immer.
Gut, Hardware sind wir so semi zufrieden mit.
Ich habe recht, im Bereich Video, Capture und so weiter gibt es durchaus auch Thunderbolt-Lösungen, aber es ist halt wieder dieses ganze Gebimsel. Und das hasse ich einfach generell.
Aber du musst eh bei deinem Zeug immer mal dranstecken. Ob du dir das Audio unterfällst von deinem Mischpult oder deinem Kopfhörer oder deinem Mikrofon da reinprepelst oder das ganze da ist und bleibt gebimsel. Wenn du die Karte in dein Rechner einbaust, musst du von außen eh wieder ein Kabel draufstecken. Du hast jetzt Gebimsel-Technik, nicht so richtig. Das Stecker hat mich nicht viel gewonnen.
Aber die Gigabit-Ports, da hätten sie schon mal ein bisschen den nächsten Standard nehmen können. Das finde ich schon ein bisschen schade. Weil gerade diese Kisten willst du wirklich an den dicken Storage dranhängen, wo halt die Final-Cut-Jungs ihre dicken Movies haben. Und dann willst du da mehr als 100 MB durch die Gegend schieben können.
Und dazwischen ist es auch nicht mehr so unglaublich teuer. Also 10 GB ist jetzt schon demnächst in ihrem Saturn.
Aber ich bin auch kein Final-Cut, da hat die Waller bei der für irgendeine Bude arbeitet. Aber bei so einem dicken Buden sollten sie sowas haben.
Demnächst 10 GB in ihrem Saturn. Nächstes Jahr wirst du sehen.
Vielleicht kommt es ja auch noch. Ist ja für die vielleicht kein Problem, das auch noch zu ändern, oder?
Na ja, es gibt dann halt jedes Jahr jetzt einen neuen Mac Pro.
Da ändern sie halt irgendeinen neuen Chip rein. Die nutzen ja eh keine Intel, die nutzen ja Broadcom.
Ich denke, die werden es eh über Thunderbolt machen. Ähnlich wie es jetzt sozusagen so ein Gigabit Ethernet-Dongel gibt für jetzige Thunderbolt.
IP-over-Thunderbolt, da gibt es irgendwelche.
Das kannst du ja jetzt schon machen. Er meint, dass er Ethernet gleich weglässt. Dass du eine Storage hast, die jetzt neben ihrem Ethernet-Port auch gleich einen Thunderbolt-Port hat. Wo sie aber IP drauf sprechen. Und so weit möchtest du haben. Übrigens auch eine Technologie, die andere Betriebssysteme schon länger drin haben. Mit sich rumschleppen, for free oder wie auch immer. Kannst du bei Apple immer noch nur extra zu kaufen, nämlich iSCSI. Finde ich auch wie ein bisschen lame für 2013. Aber wir waren ja gerade schon im Resümee. Wir wollen jetzt ja nicht wieder zurückkurbeln. Also Resümee ist, wir sind so semi-zufrieden mit der Hardware. Außerdem sind wir mit dem Seelöwen so, ja, haben wir jetzt keine großen Kritikpunkte, was für Berliner ja schon ganz okay ist, wenn man nicht mehr drüber meckern kann.
Da kannst du nicht meckern.
Kann man nicht mehr drüber meckern, ja. Aber das iOS findet ja alles im Schrein bisher.
Die Features sind gut, das Design ist zum Weglaufen.
Ich glaube, das Design ist noch nicht fertig.
Ich hoffe, das Design ist noch nicht fertig, aber ich befürchte das Schlimmste.
Ja, ich auch.
Obwohl irgendjemand meinte...
Du kannst downgraden. Das Ganze letzte ist damit voll. Das Einzige ist ja noch... Vorher hatte ich eine Firmware 3.0.25 oder irgendwie sowas und jetzt habe ich eine Firmware 4.0. irgendwas. Das heißt, die wird natürlich bleiben, aber ist ja okay eigentlich. Also die Baseband-Firmware. Genau. Jetzt sind ja wurscht.
Tschüss.
Was für ein dramatisches Ende.
Ja, sonst finden wir ja kein Ende.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.